HI GOOD AFTERNOON FROM
THE CALL THE JOINT OVERSIGHT
HEARING OF THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE THE
ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE AND THE SENATE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE TO
WATER- DUE TO ONGOING COVE IN
NINETEEN SAFETY. CONSIDERATIONS
WE ARE PRACTICING PHYSICAL
DISTANCING HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM AT THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. SO WE ARE ONLY ABLE
TO HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WATCH AND PARTICIPATE IN
THE HEARING IN PERSON WE'RE
ALSO REQUIRING THAT MASKS BE
WORN AND PHYSICAL DISTANCING BE
MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TESTIFYING. WEATHER
HERE IN THE ROOM ARE AND THE
VIDEO CONFERENCING SITE. IF YOU
DO NOT HAVE A MASS WE CAN
PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU WE HAVE A
FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS- FOR THE
PUBLIC TO PARTICIPATE. FOR THE
PUBLIC HERE IN THE ROOM WHEN WE
REACH THE PUBLIC COMMENT
PORTION OF THE AGENDA ADDRESS
THAT ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
HERE IN THE ROOM TO PLEASE
APPROACH THE MIKE ONE PERSON AT
A TIME. AND PLEASE MAINTAIN
SOCIAL DISTANCING AS YOU MOVE
AROUND THE ROOM. I WOULD ASK
THE PUBLIC NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU ARE DONE
PROVIDING YOUR COMMENT OR
RETURN TO YOUR SEAT PLEASE BE
SURE TO OBSERVE PHYSICAL
DISTANCING UPON LEAVING THE
CAPITAL INCLUDING LIMITING THE
ELEVATOR YOU JUST ONE PERSON
OUT OF TIME. FOR REMOTE
WITNESSES. OUR PANELISTS. FROM
THE CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR'S
OFFICE AND THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD WILL BE
TESTIFYING REMOTELY TODAY.
THESE WITNESSES WILL APPEAR ON
THE SCREEN SO MEMBERS CAN WATCH
THEIR TESTIMONY LIVE FROM
OUTSIDE OF THE HEARING ROOM AND
ALSO ASK THEM QUESTIONS. FOR
DIAL IN PUBLIC COMMENT WE WILL
ALSO BE USING A MODERATED
TELEPHONE SERVICE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR
THIS HEARING IS. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN AGAIN THAT NUMBER IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS THIRTEEN
FIFTEEN. FORTY TWO ZERO TWO.
THE ACCESS CODE IS. THIRTEEN
FIFTEEN FORTY TWO ZERO TWO. YOU
CAN ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON
THE ASSEMBLY WEBSITE AND ON
YOUR TV SCREEN. THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN QUEUE TO PROVIDE YOUR
PUBLIC COMMENT. IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE THIS INCLUDES
MUTING YOUR LIVESTREAM
BROADCAST AND YOUR SMART
DEVICES TO REDUCE THE SOUND
DISTORTION. WE MAY NEED TO
LIMIT HOW LONG EACH PERSON HAS
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT AS WE
WILL NEED TO EXIT THIS HEARING
ROOM. AROUND FIVE PM I ALSO
WANT TO NOTE THAT WE WILL NOT
TOLERATE DISRUPTIONS SO WE CAN
KEEP THIS HEARING ON TRACK.
THAT'S IT THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. NOW MOVING UNDER
HEARING TODAY WE WILL BE
DISCUSSING THE FINDINGS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS. IDENTIFIED BY
THE STATE AUDITOR AND THE AUDIT
REPORT RELEASED JUST LAST MONTH
TITLED. CALIFORNIA RESOURCES
BOARD IMPROVE PROGRAM
MEASUREMENT WOULD HELP
CALIFORNIA WORK MORE
STRATEGICALLY TO MEET ITS
CLIMATE. FIRST I WANT TO THANK
US SENATOR BRADFORD FOR
REQUESTING THIS AUDIT REGARDING
THE TRANSPORTATION RELATED
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
PROGRAMS OVERSEEN BY CARB. IS A
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE THE
CALIFORNIA'S ME TREMENDOUS
STRIDES IN REDUCING GHG.
IMPROVING PUBLIC HEALTH FOR
MANY AND ADDRESSING CLIMATE
CHANGE. HOWEVER THERE ARE STILL
LARGE AREAS OF OUR STATE I KNOW
LIKE FOR THE CENTRAL VALLEY FOR
INSTANCE I WHERE I RESIDE THAT
WHERE THE AIR QUALITY RANKS
AMONG THE WORST IN THE NATION.
POLLUTED AIR IS LINKED TO A
VARIETY OF HEALTH CONCERNS
RANGING FROM. SERIOUS DISEASES
OR EVEN PREMATURE DEATH NOT
ONLY ARE FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
LIVING IN POLLUTED AREAS WHERE
THEY ARE EXPERIENCING HIGHER
HEALTH RISKS BUT SOME ARE ALSO
LIVING IN EXTREME POVERTY. LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
INDIVIDUALS HAVE CARRIED THE
DISPROPORTIONATE BURDEN OF
ENVIRONMENTAL INJUSTICE.
THEREFORE IT IS CRITICAL THAT
IN ADDITION TO REDUCING HG
EMISSIONS. THE PROGRAMS
OVERSEEN BY CARP SHOULD ALSO
ACHIEVE SOCIAL ECONOMIC
BENEFITS. PARTICULARLY FOR
THOSE RESIDING AND
DISADVANTAGED AND LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES. MOREOVER I BELIEVE
THAT GHG POLICIES AND PROGRAMS
IN THE TRANSPORTATION SECTOR
MUST BE APPLIED FAIRLY AND
EQUITABLY IN ORDER FOR THEM TO
BE EFFECTIVE. HOWEVER IN LATE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE RELEASED A
REPORT ON THE ECONOMIC IMPACTS
AND BENEFITS. OF CALIFORNIA
STATUTORY GHG EMISSION GOALS
AND THAT LEFT ME AND MANY
OTHERS WITH MORE QUESTIONS THAN
ANSWERS. OR FOUND THAT THE
OVERALL ECONOMIC IMPACTS AND
BENEFITS OF THESE PROGRAMS AND
POLICIES ARE LARGELY UNCLEAR.
THE ALEJO'S FINDINGS LEFT ME
WONDERING. HOW THE STATE COULD
SPEND BILLIONS OF DOLLARS ON
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS AIMED AT
LOWERING GHG BULAK PROGRAM
MEASUREMENTS TO GUIDE ITS
INVESTMENTS. THE OTHER REPORT
THAT WAS RELEASED BY THE STATE
AUDITOR LAST MONTH CERTAINLY
RAISES SIMILAR QUESTIONS AND
CONCERNS SPECIFICALLY IT FOUND
THAT CAR HAS NOT DONE ENOUGH TO
MEASURE THE GHG EMISSION
REDUCTIONS- IN ITS INDIVIDUAL
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS
SPECIFICALLY IT HAS NOT
COLLECTED OR EVALUATED
SUFFICIENT DATA TO ALLOW TO
DETERMINE WHETHER. OR HOW ITS
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS REDUCE GHG
EMISSIONS WITHOUT PROGRAM
MEASUREMENTS WE DO NOT KNOW THE
VALUE FOR EACH DOLLAR WE ARE
INVESTING TO DETERMINE WHETHER
WE ARE HAVING THE BEST IMPACT
FOR THAT DOLLAR IN OUR MOST
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
ADDITIONALLY THE REPORT FOUND
THAT CARBON IS NOT CONSISTENTLY
COLLECTED OR ANALYZED DATA TO
DETERMINE WHETHER SOME OF ITS
PROGRAMS PROVIDE THE SOCIAL
SOCIAL ECONOMIC BENEFITS TO
CALIFORNIANS LIVING IN
ENVIRONMENTALLY DISADVANTAGED
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AS
WELL AS LOW AND MODERATE INCOME
COMMUNITIES. I LOOK FORWARD TO
A REPOSE ROBUST AND MUCH NEEDED
DISCUSSION TODAY REGARDING THE
AUTO REPORT- WITH. WITH THE
AGENCY IN DOING A POEM IN
IMPLEMENTING THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND STRATEGIES
TO ACHIEVE CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE
GOALS AT THIS TIME I DO WANNA
MENTION ANOTHER HOUSEKEEPING.
ITEM BEFORE WE PROCEED FORWARD
A FEW HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS TO
ENSURE WE CAN HEAR FROM
EVERYONE ASKED THE PANEL KEEP
THE PRESIDENT PRESENTATIONS TO
THE TIME ALLOTTED. AND- WHAT
THAT'LL ME GO AHEAD INVITE
EITHER ASSEMBLY MEMBER FREE OR
SENATOR GONZALEZ FOR OPENING
REMARKS. AND OKAY WELL I FIRST
WANT TO THANK MY CLLEAGUES FOR
BRINGING LIKE THIS A VERY
IMPORTANT TOPIC AND FOR
ALLOWING CARP TO HIGHLIGHT
THEIR WORK AS WELL AND FOR US
TO DO A DEEP DIVE A LITTLE BIT
INTO THEIR WORK I'VE CLIMATE
CHANGE- RIGHT NOW IS CERTAINLY
ON EVERYONE'S MIND IN FEW
BELIEVE IN SCIENCE WHICH I DO
AND LISTEN TO SCIENTISTS
CLIMATE CHANGE AND CLIMATE
IMPACTS IN THE FUTURE IF WE
DON'T TAKE RADICAL ACTION ARE
GOING TO BE THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGE THAT THIS THAT ANYONE
IN RECENT MEMORY HAS EVER
FACED. IT'S SOMETHING THAT I
WORRY ABOUT EVERY DAY I WORRY
ABOUT MY DAUGHTER AND THE
PLANET THAT SHE'S GOING TO
INHERIT I WORRY ABOUT OUR OWN
STATE AND OUR CONSTITUENTS AND
THERE WILL HOW THEY WILL ADJUST
TO CLIMATE CHANGE TO DROUGHT TO
THE TYPES OF CROPS THAT WERE
ABLE TO ARE NOT ABLE TO GROW IN
CALIFORNIA TO WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN TO OUR COASTLINE TO OUR
COMMUNITIES THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WE NEED TO TAKE EXTREMELY
SERIOUSLY. NOW THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR HAS
STRUGGLED FOR MANY YEARS WITH
GHG REDUCTIONS IN THE CONTINUES
TO STRUGGLE IN. IN MY MIND IT'S
NOT JUST BECAUSE OF THE TYPE OF
FUEL THAT'S USED. IT'S ALSO
HAS- HAS TO DO WITH LAND USE
POLICIES. AND HOW WE ALLOW
PEOPLE ARE DOING ALLOW PEOPLE
TO MOVE AROUND THEIR
COMMUNITIES- IT'S ABOUT WHERE
WE LIVE IT OUT WE CAN AFFORD TO
LIVE IT'S ABOUT WHAT WE- NEED
TO GET TO HAVE OUR LIVES.
BEYOND A MANY OF THESE ISSUES
GO WELL BEYOND CARBS OR CARBS
OF THIRTY. AND SO I THINK AS WE
MOVE FORWARD IT'S IMPORTANT TO
REMEMBER THAT THERE'S A LOT OF
FACTORS THAT GO INTO. HOW
PEOPLE MOVE AROUND THE
COMMUNITY HOW THEY DRIVE AND
WHAT CAR WAS ABLE TO DO AND NOT
ABLE TO DO. THAT I WANT TO SAY
JUST KIND OF OUTSIDE OF THIS
TOPIC A LITTLE BIT I THINK THAT
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT AS WE
MOVE FORWARD THAT WE DECIDE LOW
A LOT OF THESE CONVERSATIONS
TRANSPORTATION LAND USE
HOUSING. THEY'RE ALL PART OF A
LARGER. CONVERSATION THAT NEEDS
TO BE MORE HOLISTIC. I AM
CHAIRING A NEW SELECT COMMITTEE
AND URBAN DEVELOPMENT T COMBAT
CLIMATE CHANGE. AND I INVITE
ALL OF YOU TO PARTICIPATE IN
THAT. I DO TODAY WANT TO DIVE
INTO TALK ABOUT FEASIBLE
REALISTIC CHANGES THAT CAN BE
MADE. WITH THE UNDERSTANDING
THAT THE ANSWERS TO SOME OF
THESE QUESTIONS MIGHT VERY WELL
BE ON NOBLE. AND I HOPE TO COME
AWAY TODAY WITH AN
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION. CAN WORK
TOGETHER. TO BETTER TACKLE-
THIS HUGE CHALLENGE AND OUR
GOALS AND THANKS AGAIN FOR.
HOLDING THIS HEARING. THANK YOU
OUR CHAIRWOMAN- FRIEDMAN WILL
MOVE NOW TO WHERE SENATE
TRANSPORTATION CHAIR SENATOR
LENA GONZALEZ. THANK YOU SHARE
SALAS- I'D LIKE TO FIRST START
BY THINKING YOU- THE CHAIR OF
THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE AS WELL AS CHAIR. OF
THE ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE LAURA FRIEDMAN- WHO'S
BEEN A PARTNER WITH ME OVER THE
LAST COUPLE MONTHS AND
TRANSPORTATION ISSUE AND
POLICIES- AS WE KNOW STATEWIDE
MORE THAN TWENTY EIGHT MILLION
CALIFORNIANS LIVE IN AREAS THAT
EXCEED. OZONE AND PARTICULATE
MATTER STANDARDS ONE OF THOSE
HAPPENS TO BE IN MY OWN
DISTRICT- THERE ARE MANY LOW
INCOME AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES EXPERIENCE
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER POLLUTION
LEVELS WHICH HAVE SERIOUS
HEALTH. IMPACTS MY DISTRICT
INCLUDES THE PORT OF LONG BEACH
IN PART OF THE SEVEN TEN
CORRIDOR WHICH ARE HUGE JOB
DRIVERS. BUT THEY ALSO CREATE
SEVERE AIR QUALITY CHALLENGES
SO WE NEED A STRATEGIC AND
DEDICATED INVESTMENT
OPPORTUNITY AND PROGRAMS TO
DEVELOP CLEAN FREIGHT CORRIDORS
AND GET CLEAN. HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLES IMPORT EQUIPMENT AND
USE- ALONG OUR CORRIDORS FOR
BETTER AIR QUALITY IMPROVEMENT.
AND ON THE LIGHT DUTY SIDE HALF
OF ALL EV'S SOLD IN THE U. S.
HAVE BEEN RIGHT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA SO WE'RE DOING
SOMETHING RIGHT BUT IT'S NOT
ENOUGH TO MAKE SURE. THAT
EVERYONE CAN PARTICIPATE IN THE
ZERO EMISSION FUTURE ADDRESSING
BARRIERS. ENSURING AGAIN THAT
LOW INCOME INDIVIDUALS ARE AT
THE FRONT OF THE LINE. THE
LEGISLATURE HAS CREATED OR
FUNDED MANY PROGRAMS TO ACHIEVE
THESE BENEFITS AND OF COURSE
THIS YEAR WE'RE CONSIDERING A
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLAR
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION PROPOSAL
FROM THE GOVERNOR. ACROSS
INCENTIVES AND INFRASTRUCTURES.
I'M ENCOURAGED THAT THE AUDIT
HAS FOUND SOME- OPPORTUNITIES
WHERE- THEY'VE EXIT EXCEEDED
MINIMUM SPENDING REQUIREMENTS
FOR LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES. BUT
WE HAVE TO LOOK DEEPER THAN
THAT LET HIGH LEVEL METRIC AT
THE PROGRAMS THAT ARE AVAILABLE
NOW AND ENSURING THAT THEIR
INTENDED. OUTCOMES ARE REALLY
ACHIEVING WHAT WE NEED FOR
THESE COMMUNITIES. WE KNOW THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS A LOT MORE TO
DO. AND ASKING THE RIGHT
QUESTIONS AND ENSURING THAT
THEY'RE TOUGH QUESTIONS AND
ANALYZING THE RIGHT INFORMATION
AND USING IT TO IMPROVE
EXISTING PROGRAMS CAN
DEFINITELY HELP US GET HERE AND
I KNOW THIS COMMITTEE CAN
CERTAINLY DO THAT. WITHOUT
AGAIN I WANT TO SAY THANK.
THANK YOU SENATOR- WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE TO CENTER LAYERED THE
VICE CHAIR OF THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE ACCESS. CAN UP.
JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE BUT AT THAT. THIS
POINT I'D LIKE TO UPDATE. THE
ACCESS CODE THE ACCESS CODE HAS
BEEN UPDATED FOR THE CALL IN
NUMBER OF THE CALL IN NUMBER
AGAIN WAS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN THE UPDATED ACCESS CODE
IS FORTY TWO ZERO TWO. THIRTEEN
FIFTEEN. AGAIN THAT ACCESS CODE
IS. FOUR TWO ZERO TWO ONE THREE
ONE FIVE AND WHAT THAT WILL
MOVE TO SENATOR ALERT PLEASE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHIP.
ARM THE N. R. I APPRECIATE
HAVING A HEARING AND BE HERE
WITH POST TRANSPORTATION CHAIRS
AS WELL. I WAS IN THE
LEGISLATURE OF FIFTEEN YEARS
pADOPTED AND IT WAS BASICALLY A
BI PARTISAN EFFORT PASSED BY A
DEMOCRATIC LEGISLATURE AND
SIGNED BY REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR.
TO DO. AT THE STATE LEVEL WHAT
WAS WALKED AWAY FROM AT THE
NATIONAL LEVEL. THERE WERE THE
KEY AUTO ACCORDS AND AB THIRTY
TWO BASICALLY SAID WE WOULD
APPLY THOSE TO CALIFORNIA IN
THE ABSENCE OF OUR FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WALKING AWAY FROM
THEM. AND IT'S SET THE GOAL
THAT WE WOULD BY TWENTY TWENTY
GO BACK TO THE EMISSIONS LEVEL
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS LEVEL
BY NINETEEN NINETY. ARE THAT
BILL PLACED THE AUTHORITY FOR
THAT PROGRAM AND ALL THE
SUPPORTED FOR FISCAL AND- AN
ADMINISTRATIVE AUTHORITY WITHIN
THE CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES
BOARD THAT'S WHAT BROUGHT US
HERE TODAY. AND WE HAVE MET
THOSE GOALS OF THAT VERY HIGH
GOAL WAS MET SO AND NOW THE
LEGISLATURE WITH THE GOVERNOR
HAS SET NEW GOALS ON BOTH THAT
AND OTHER CLIMATE ACTIVITIES.
SO IT'S VERY APPROPRIATE THAT
WE DO A CHECK IN A CHECK IN
ABOUT WHETHER THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESSES
WORKING AND IT'S EFFECTIVE
WHETHER INJURE ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE GOALS. ARE BEING MET
WHETHER WE HAVE MEASUREMENTS TO
SEE. BUT IT'S ALSO APPROPRIATE
NOT TO TAKE OUR PIE OFF THESE
GOALS THAT IS WHAT IS IN FRONT
OF US. BECAUSE THE NATION LOOKS
TO CALIFORNIA FOR OUR
LEADERSHIP ON THESE ISSUES AND
WE'VE PROVIDED SO I THINK THIS
HEARING. WILL GIVE US A GOOD
CHANCE TO HAVE A CHECK AND BUT
I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE WE DON'T
TAKE OUR EYE OFF OF WHERE WE
HAVE TO HAVE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN FOR ALLOWING ME TO
MAKE OPENING COME BACK THANK
YOU SENATOR LAYERED WITH THAT-
WE WILL GO. AHEAD AND MOVE TO
OUR FIRST HAND ALL THIS IS A
ITEM TWO OVERVIEW OF THE ID OF
THE CAL AIR RESOURCES BOARD WE
HAVE JOINING US OUR CALIFORNIA
STATE AUDITOR ELAINE HOWLE-
TAMMY LOZANO OF PRINCIPLE AND
MARK- RIGHT RT AUDIT SUPERVISOR
KNOWS WE'RE GETTING READY FOR
THEM. I DO WANT TO JUST MENTION
AND THANK- THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
HERE IN ATTENDANCE. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN SENATOR
GONZALEZ ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRAZIER SENATOR LAYER ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FONG. SENATOR DOLLY AND
REMOTELY WE HAVE I BELIEVE
TWENTY THREE MEMBERS JOINING US
REMOTELY THAT'S ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KILEY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL SENATOR
BACKER CENTER GLAZER SENATOR
HERTZBERG SENATOR NELSON.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON ASSEMBLY
MEMBER NAZARIAN SIMPLY MEMBER
WHEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER O'DONNELL
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARS AND ONE
MEMBER WICKS SENATOR BATES.
SENATE ARCHER LETTER THE
SENATOR MCGUIRE CENTER MELENDEZ
SENATOR MAN SENATOR RUBIO.
SENATOR SKINNER SENATOR
MCCASKEY SENATOR ALAN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CUNNINGHAM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EARLY. AND WHAT THAT WAS GOING
TO MOVE. TO OUR- CALIFORNIA
REESE BOARD PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS- I'M MY
NAME'S ELAINE HALL IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR AND
MARK RANDY AND I WILL BE
PRESENTING INFORMATION RELATED
TO AN AUDIT WE ISSUED IN
FEBRUARY R. AS TO CAR AND ITS
EFFORTS TO IMPLEMENT AB THIRTY
TWO AND OTHER PROGRAMS AND SO
WE HAVE THREE KEY ISSUES THAT
WE'RE GOING TO GO OVER AYE WE
PROVIDED A PACKET OF FOR A FOUR
PAGE PACKET TO THE COMMITTEE-
I'M GOING TO BE REVIEWING AND
GOING OVER THE FIRST PAGE AND
THEN MISTER REGNERY WILL STEP
YOU THROUGH THE- FOLLOWING
THREE PAGES AND BASICALLY WHAT
THOSE PAGES WILL DO WILL
ILLUSTRATE. EACH OF THE KEY KEY
ISSUES THAT I'M GOING TO
DISCUSS SO THE FIRST ISSUE AS
AS SOME OF THE MEMBERS THAT
INTRODUCED IT. NUMBER FRIEDMAN
MISTER SALAS AND GONZALEZ IS
THERE ARE IMPORTANT PROGRAMS
THAT CALIFORNIA ADMINISTERS-
BUT WHAT WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
IN THE FIRST ISSUE IS WHETHER
OR NOT CARD IS ABLE TO.
PROPERLY MEASURE THE EFFECT OF
THOSE PROGRAMS AND WE HAVE
REGULATORY PROGRAMS REQUIRED
PROGRAMS AND THEN WE ALSO
CERTAINLY HAVE INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS AND THOSE PROGRAMS AND
MANY CASES WORK TOGETHER. ON
THE ISSUE WE HAVE IN CALIFORNIA
IS CARD DOESN'T HAVE THE
ABILITY OR DOESN'T AT THIS
POINT IN TIME. HAVE THE
CAPABILITY OF MEASURING THE
DISTINCTION BETWEEN WHAT GHG
EMISSION BENEFITS AS CALIFORNIA
RECEIVING FROM ITS REGULATORY
PROGRAMS VERSES IT'S INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS THE REASON THAT'S
IMPORTANT IS AS CALIFORNIA.
DECIDES TO INVEST MORE AND MORE
DOLLARS INTO INCENTIVE PROGRAMS
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
INVESTING IN THE PROGRAMS THAT
ARE MOST BENEFICIAL TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. ARE IN
REDUCING GHG EMISSIONS AND
CERTAINLY- CREATING-
SOCIOECONOMIC BENEFITS OFFER
COMMUNITIES DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES SO THE FIRST KEY
ISSUE IS. WHETHER OR NOT CARD
AND WE FOUND A CAR DOESN'T HAVE
THE ABILITY RIGHT NOW WE THINK
THEY CAN AND SHOULD. BE ABLE TO
IDENTIFY THE BENEFITS DERIVED
FROM ITS REGULATORY PROGRAMS
VERSUS ITS INCENTIVE PROGRAMS.
THE REASON THIS IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT AS WELL IN ADDITION
TO INVESTING IN THE APPROPRIATE
PROGRAMS IS. A WE HAVE A VERY
AGGRESSIVE. ALL OF READ. GHG
EMISSIONS BY TWENTY THIRTY AND
IT HAS TO BE REDUCED
SIGNIFICANTLY WE'RE GONNA
SPEAKING ABOUT TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR THAT'S SPECIFICALLY WHAT
THE AUDIT COMMITTEE MR
BRADFORD'S REQUEST ASK US TO
LOOK AT. BECAUSE THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR.
PASSENGER VEHICLES TRUCKS-
HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS ETCETERA. ARE
MAJOR CONTRIBUTORS TO EMISSIONS
IN CALIFORNIA GREENHOUSE GASES-
SO THAT'S THE SECTOR THAT
CALIFORNIA REALLY NEEDS TO
FOCUS ON IN FACT THAT SECTOR
OVER THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS
CONTINUES TO SHOW AN INCREASE
IN EMISSIONS RATHER THAN A
DECREASE IN THE NATION SO.
THERE REALLY DOES NEED TO BE A
FOCUS ON THIS PARTICULAR SECTOR
AND THOSE REGULATORY PROGRAMS
AS WELL AS THE INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS SO THAT'S THE FIRST
ISSUE THAT WE IDENTIFIED IN THE
REPORT- AND MR WRITER REAL
STEPPING THROUGH SOME MORE
SPECIFICS RELATED TO THAT. THE
SECOND ISSUE IS THE SOCIO
ECONOMIC BENEFITS OF THE
LEGISLATURE CLEARLY HAD
INTENTION AT SOME OF THESE
PROGRAMS WOULD BENEFIT
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES LOW
INCOME YOU LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES- AND ACTUALLY
REQUIRED CARD TO INVEST A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF FUNDING IN
THOSE COMMUNITIES 25%
DISADVANTAGED. 10% AND LOW
INCOME IN THE AGGREGATE
CALIFORNIA IS DOING THAT WE ARE
INVESTING A LOT. MORE THAN THAT
THOSE PARTICULAR PERCENTAGES.
THE PROBLEM WE FOUND WITH THIS
PARTICULAR AREA IS CARD NOT
DOING AS GOOD A JOB AS IT
SHOULD AND IS REQUIRED TO DO TO
MEASURE WHETHER OR NOT THOSE
SOCIOECONOMIC BENEFITS ARE
OCCURRING IN THOSE COMMUNITIES-
I'M SPECIFICALLY TALKING ABOUT-
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES. AND
SOME OF THE JOB TRAINING
PROGRAMS THAT THAT CARB
INTENDED TO ESTABLISH AND FUND
WHETHER OR NOT THOSE PROGRAMS
ARE PROVIDING JOB TRAINING TO
INDIVIDUALS IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES SO THEY CAN GAIN
EMPLOYMENT IN THIS INDUSTRY. IN
ADDITION THERE WERE SOME
REQUIREMENTS RELATED TO JOB
CREATION HI OF JOBS THAT THESE
PROGRAMS SUPPORT. AND SO WE
EXPECTED TO SEE BETTER
MEASUREMENT BY CARD AS TO THOSE
BENEFITS AND IN FACT CARBS OWN
GUIDELINES FROM TWENTY FIFTEEN
THEY ESTABLISHED IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN REQUIRED THEM TO TRACK
SOME OF THIS INFORMATION. AND
MAY NOT ARE NOT DOING AS GOOD A
JOB IN TRACKING AND CERTAINLY
REPORTING THIS INFORMATION TO
LEGISLATURE AS THEY COULD AND
SHOULD BE DOING. SO IN THE AREA
OF SOCIOECONOMIC BENEFITS EVEN
THOUGH IN THE AGGREGATE AGAIN
THEY ARE INVESTING IN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IN
LINE CAN COMMUNITIES THE
IMPORTANT ASPECT IS ARE THEY
MEASURING. BY INDIVIDUAL
COMMUNITIES BY REGIONS WITHIN
THE STATE ARE THEY MEASURING TO
DETERMINE WHETHER JOBS ARE
BEING CREATED JOB TRAINING IS
BEING SUPPORTED INDIVIDUALS ARE
RECEIVING BENEFITS- THAT MAKE
THEIR LIVES BETTER. ONE
PARTICULAR PROGRAM AS AN
EXAMPLE WE MENTIONED IN THE
REPORT IS A FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM THIS IS A
PROGRAM WHERE LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUALS CAN EITHER RECEIVE
A GRANT OR FOR FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE TO BE ABLE TO
PURCHASE. A A. AS ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE- AND WHERE WE'RE
EXPECTING CARP TO BE ABLE TO
TRACK THAT INFORMATION IS HOW
MANY INDIVIDUALS ARE RECEIVING
THOSE TYPES OF LOANS IS THE
LOAN BEING PAID OFF BECAUSE ONE
OF THE BENEFITS TO THOSE
INDIVIDUALS NOT JUST THE
VEHICLE. BUT ACTUALLY
INCREASING THEIR CREDIT
WORTHINESS OR THEIR FINANCIAL
SITUATION BECAUSE NOW THEY HAVE
A VEHICLE THAT MAY AFFECT THEIR
ABILITY TO GET A JOB- AND
REDUCE THEIR TRANSPORTATION
COST THOSE SORTS OF THINGS
THOSE ARE THE KINDS OF THINGS
THAT. I THINK THE LEGISLATURE
IN ENACTING LEGISLATION ARE
PASSING LEGISLATION BACK IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN AND AGAIN IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN REALLY
EXPECTED CARB I TO BE TRACKING
THIS TYPE OF INFORMATION AT
THIS MORE SPECIFIC. LEVEL
RATHER THAN JUST IN THE
AGGREGATE. THE THIRD AREA IS.
TO THE FOR TWO AREAS IN THAT.
THE INFORMATION THAT CARP
REPORTS TO THE LEGISLATURE
CLEARLY THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE. TO THE
LEGISLATURE IN CALIFORNIA THE
ADMINISTRATION IN CALIFORNIA-
AND TO BE ABLE TO BE PARTNERS
WITH CARBS THE LEGISLATURE
NEEDS TO HAVE THE APPROPRIATE
INFORMATION TO MAKE INFORMED
DECISIONS AS TO. WHERE WE
INVEST OUR MONEY AS HAVE BEEN-
GONZALEZ INDICATED WHERE DO WE
GET THE BACK BEST BANG FOR THE
BALLOT BOX USE ME AS A STATE.
AND IF WE ARE MEASURING THE
BENEFITS OF THESE INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS WE DON'T KNOW AS A
STATE WHETHER OR NOT THOSE ARE
THE PROGRAMS WE SHOULD CONTINUE
TO SUPPORT OR WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT DO WE NEED TO DO TO MODIFY
THIS PARTICULAR PROGRAM TO MAKE
IT MORE BENEFICIAL. TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO THE
PEOPLE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND CERTAINLY TO REDUCE GHG
EMISSIONS SO WE HAD A MULTITUDE
OF RECOMMENDATIONS TO OUR THE
LEGEND TO THE ACT A. R. B. E.
R. R. REQUIRING BETTER TRACKING
OF DATA BETTER AND- ANALYSIS OF
DATA. SEPARATING THE RESULTS OF
THEIR REGULATORY PROGRAMS
VERSUS THEIR INCENTIVE PROGRAMS
PROVIDING ALL OF THIS
INFORMATION TO THE LEGISLATURE
IN THE PUBLIC SO PEOPLE REALLY
DO UNDERSTAND. WHICH PROGRAMS
ARE WORKING WHICH PROGRAMS
PERHAPS ARE NOT WORKING AS WELL
MAYBE NEED TO BE MODIFIED OR
MADE MAYBE NEED TO BE
ELIMINATED. SO I'M GONNA HAND
IT OVER TO MR REINER HE'S GONNA
STEP YOU THROUGH THE NEXT
THREE. PAGES IT'S JUST THREE
MORE PAGES OF THE GRASS OF THE
GRAPHICS PACKAGE- AND THOSE
THREE PAGES WILL ILLUSTRATE
SOME OF WHAT I WAS JUST
DISCUSSING. SOME HANDED OUT TO
MARK. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH IS MEMBERS OF THE CA FOR
THE RECORD MY NAME IS MARK OR
DO YOU HAVE A THE OFFICE YOU
PROVIDE ON THE PROJECT- AS THE
STATE UNDERSTAND I'M GONNA WALK
YOU THROUGH IN SLIGHTLY MORE
DETAIL SOME OF THE ISSUE AREAS
THAT SHE COVERED AND TOUCH ON
OUR RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THOSE
AREAS- THE FIRST REALLY TO TALK
ABOUT HAS TO DO WITH THAT THE
STATE OF EMISSIONS AND IN
CALIFORNIA AND I WON'T BE LABOR
THAT DISCUSSION BECAUSE
HONESTLY FOLKS ARE FAMILIAR AND
WE COVERED SOME OF THAT
ALREADY. BUT IF YOU WOULD TURN
TO PAGE TWO OF YOUR PACKET
YOU'LL SEE A FIGURE WE PRESENT
IN THE REPORT THAT SHOWS THAT
ALTHOUGH YES THE YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY JG ARE REMISSIONS GOALS
HAVE BEEN MET THE COMPANY IS A
LONG. WAY TO GO IN HIS TWENTY
THIRTY GOALS AND BEYOND. I
THINK WE AS A MOST RECENT DATA.
CALIFORNIA USED TO REDUCE TOTAL
GHG EMISSIONS BY ANOTHER FORTY
PERCENT. GIVING HERE TO REACH
ITS TWENTY THIRTY GOALS. AND
HAS BEEN DISCUSSED
TRANSPORTATION IS A HUGE. HUGE
ELEMENT TO THAT THAT EFFORT.
ARE CURRENTLY TRANSPORTATION
ACCOUNTS FOR ABOUT 40% OF
EMISSIONS IN THE STATE AND IT
HAS BEEN. THAT MOST STUBBORN
SECTOR IN TERMS OF NOT WANTING
TO. FOLLOW SOME OF THE GAINS
WE'VE SEEN. IN ELECTRICAL POWER
GENERATION FOR EXAMPLE THAT THE
BENEFITS OF SOLAR AND
HYDROELECTRIC SO.
TRANSPORTATION CONTINUES TO BE
AN AREA WHERE WE HOPE THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF OPPORTUNITY
FOR GETTING RETURN ON
INVESTMENT. TO THAT END OUR
OPERATES A WIDE RANGE OF
PROGRAMS DIRECTED AT DIFFERENT
SECTORS OF TRANSPORTATION- SUCH
AS DIFFERENT VEHICLE TYPES
PASSENGER VEHICLES LIGHT DUTY
TRUCKS ALL THE WAY UP TO HEAVY
DUTY TRUCKS IN TRANSIT BUSES.
EVEN FREIGHT AND SHIPPING- AND
THOSE THOSE OBJECTIVES ARE.
COVERED- GOALS LIKE THAT THE
OBJECT CAR WANTS TO SEE. THAT
SHE EVEN THOUGH IN THOSE THE
VEHICLE AREAS IN- TO TRAINS.
WHO REDUCTIONS IN OVERALL
TRANSFER. GEN TO DO THAT AT THE
STATE SAID. CARDS PROGRAMS
BONTA JR TO CATEGORIES.
REGULATORY AND IT'S FOR. ALSO
READ- GROUPS OF BOTH ACROSS A
WIDE RAGE OF YOU TYPE AND
CHECK IF AREAS- REGULATION
REGULATORY PROGRAM CONSIST OF
THE RIGHT. AND THE- AND MEASURE
OF COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE
REGULATIONS- GENERALLY THOSE
REGULATIONS MAY BE DIRECTED
ACT. VEHICLE MANUFACTURERS-
SOME SOME KIND OF OUR NASCENT-
REGULATIONS DIRECTED AT SOME
SOME OF THE FRESHEST TIME. BUT
THEY WOULD REQUIRE THE
PRODUCTION IN SOME CASES THE
SALE OF YOUR SPECIFIC TYPES OF
CLEAN VEHICLES. OR MANDATE THE
OVERALL EFFICIENCY- CLEANLINESS
OF MANUFACTURERS OVERALL
OFFERINGS OF VEHICLES. AND THEN
THE INCENTIVE SIDE OTHER
PROGRAMS THAT ARE GENERALLY
DIRECTED ACT INSURERS KNOWS
MIGHT BE INDIVIDUAL
CALIFORNIANS LOOKING TO BUY A
NEW VEHICLE. ARE THEY MAY BE
TRANSFERRED HE'S OUR COMPANIES.
IN INTERESTED IN MORE HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLES SUCH AS TRUCKS
AND BUSES. AND THE VERY PURPOSE
OF THOSE INCENTIVE PROGRAMS IS
TO MOTIVATE CONSUMERS TO GO OUT
AND PURCHASE THE COMMUTER
VEHICLE ON THE OTHERWISE WHAT.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE REALLY
TALKING ABOUT WHEN WE LOOK AT
THE SWEETER TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAMS AND DISCUSS TODAY IS
GETTING THOSE CLEANER VEHICLES
OUT ON THE ROAD AND KEEPING
THEM THERE. THAT IS GOING TO
GENERATE THE REDUCTION OVER
WHAT WOULD OTHERWISE HAPPEN.
THAT WE NEED TO SEE IN THE
TRAFFIC. SO WITH THAT ALL
ASKING TURN TO PAGE I GET
LITTLE IN. AN OF SOMEBODY FROM
AND HOW THEY- WHAT ARE FINE
WERE RESPECT OUR- I'M IN
STRAIGHT ABOUT. SO WE ARE
FOCUSED ON HERE IS THE-
OBJECTIVE RELAY TO ZERO
EMISSION. AND CAL- YOU KNOW WE
THINK THAT'S AN F. YOU EXAMPLE
PEOPLE FAMILIAR WITH WITH
VEHICLES IN THE PROGRAMS. BUT
AS I LIED TO YOU KNOW OUR TEAM
REVIEWED- PROGRAMS ACROSS MANY
DIFFERENT VEHICLE TYPES
INCLUDING. AGRICULTURAL
EQUIPMENT TRUCKS AND BUSES SO
WE'RE OBVIOUSLY HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE
ABOUT THOSE OTHER PROGRAMS. BUT
FOR THE SAKE OF THEM
ILLUSTRATING OUR CONCLUSIONS
WILL FOCUS ON UNDESERVEDLY ZERO
ZERO. EMISSION VEHICLE
OBJECTIVE HERE THAT- THE
OBJECTIVE AS PUT FORTH IN CAR
SCOPING PLAN AND THIS IS BACKED
UP BY A SERIES OF EXECUTIVE
ORDERS. IS TO PUT ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION JENSEN CALIFORNIA
ROADS FIVE TWENTY TWENTY FIVE.
TOTAL FIVE MILLION ON THOSE
ROADS BY TWENTY THIRTY THAT'S
AN AMBITIOUS GOAL. IN ORDER TO
ACCOMPLISH THAT FARMERS
OPERATING PROGRAMS THAT BOTH.
IT SHOULD BE TOWARD THIS
OBJECTIVE SO THAT'S WHAT THE
STATE ARE WE SAYING THESE
PROGRAMS. WORK TOGETHER OR AND
POTENTIALLY OVERLAP- AND WEIRD
OUR CHARGE WAS TO LOOK AND SEE
HOW WELL CARVE DESIGNS AND
MEASURES THOSE PROGRAMS TO
ACCOUNT FOR THEIR INDIVIDUAL
CONTRIBUTIONS TOWARDS THESE
OBJECTIVES. IS OBJECTIVES ARE
GOING TO GET US TO OUR TWENTY
THIRD GOAL. ON THE REGULATORY
SIDE. OF THE MOST NOTABLE
REGULATORY PROGRAM THERE IS
DOES THAT REGULATION. THAT
REQUIRES CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS TO- SUIT YOU-
MANUFACTURE AND SELL CERTAIN
PROPORTIONS OF VEHICLES.
INSTEAD OF CALIFORNIA. EVERY
YEAR SO PROPORTION OF THEIR
TOTAL SALES HAS TO BE. FOUND
OUT. JEFF IS THEIR VEHICLES.
I'M THE- INSECTICIDE CAR
OPERATION AND PROGRAMS THAT ARE
TARA AT THE STATE SAME. THOSE
ARE SOME OF THE KNOWN PRO ARE.
PETE THAT'S A VEHICLE READING
PROGRAM AND THEN- THERE ARE
ALSO SOME PROGRAMS ARE SLIGHTLY
SMALLER IN SIZE. INCLUDING THE
GREEN CROSS FOR ALL PROGRAM AND
THE- FINANCING ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM. BUT IN ALL CASES THOSE
PROGRAMS PROVIDE FINANCIAL
INCENTIVES TO CONSUMERS TO MAKE
TO. TO A MOTIVATE THEM TO
pALREADY YOU'RE SEEING THE
OVERLAP IS A REGULATION THAT
REQUIRES THE SALE OF THESE
VEHICLES IN PART AND THEN MONEY
PROVIDED TO CONSUMERS. TO
ENCOURAGE THEM TO PURCHASE THE
VEHICLES. THOSE ARE THE
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN CRIMES
CONTROL THEY'RE ALSO NUMBERS
PROGRAMS ARE OUTSIDE OF CRIMES
DIRECT CONTROL INCLUDING
FEDERAL TAX INCENTIVES CONSUMER
PREFERENCES. THE STATE PROGRAMS
LIKE THE HIGH OCCUPANCY VEHICLE
LANES- SO YOU CAN SEE WHERE THE
OVERLAPPING THE COMPLICATION
STARTS. OUR UNFORTUNATELY ARE
REVIEWED ON A CAR DOES NOT DO
ENOUGH TO COORDINATE ITS
MEASUREMENT OVERLAPPING
REGULATORY INCENTIVE PROGRAMS-
THAT HAS TO DO WITH ON THE
FRONT END IT DOESN'T DO ENOUGH
IN THE DESIGN AND
IMPLEMENTATION. ANOTHER AND
THAT IS WHEN THEY DEVELOP A
REGULATION PROGRAM THEY'RE NOT
NECESSARILY LOOKING FOR THE
INFLUENCE OF THE OF THE-
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS AND VICE
VERSA THEY'RE NOT ACCOUNTING
FOR REGULATORY PROGRAMS THAT
MIGHT REQUIRES THEMSELVES WHEN
THEY PUT INTO PLACE SOMETHING
LIKE CTRP OR RATHER WHEN THEY
GO BACK TO THE TABLE AND
DETERMINE WHETHER THEY SHOULD
BE FINE CTRP MAKE ANY CHANGES
TO IT. THAT ISSUE CARRIES ON
THROUGH THE MEASUREMENT OF
THESE PROGRAMS WE FOUND. THAT
WHEN THE WAY THE CAR MEASURES
COMPLIANCE WITH ITS REGULATORY
PROGRAMS DOES NOT TRANSLATE
EASILY HOW IT TALKS ABOUT ITS
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS. THAT IS THE
COMPLIANCE WITH THIS REGULATORY
PROGRAMS ARE NOT FOCUSED ON THE
NUMBER OF VEHICLES NECESSARILY
WHERE IS THAT IS HOW CAR TRACKS
REPORTS ON THE INCENTIVE
PROGRAM SO ALREADY. CARP HAS
PUT ITSELF IN A POSITION WHERE
IT'S DIFFICULT FOR ITS TWO
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS TO TALK TO
ONE ANOTHER IN TERMS OF THEIR
OUT. AND THEN THERE'S A LARGE
QUESTION RELATED TO CONSUMER
BEHAVIOR AGAIN THE PURPOSE OF
THESE INCENTIVE PROGRAMS IS TO
GET CONSUMERS TO DO THINGS THAT
THEY WOULDN'T OTHERWISE DO BY
MAKING IT MORE ATTRACTIVE
PROPOSITION. HOWEVER WE FOUND
THAT CAR GENERALLY CANNOT
DEMONSTRATE THAT ITS INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS TO THAT. ONE REASON
THEY CANNOT IS THAT CRIME
GENERALLY DOESN'T ACTUALLY ASK
ITS PARTICIPANTS WHETHER OR
NOT- THE INCENTIVE PROGRAM WAS
WAS INSTRUMENTAL OR OR WAS THE
DECIDING FACTOR IN THEIR
DECISION TO PURCHASE. AND SO IF
THAT'S NOT THE CASE THEN IT
DIFFICULT FOR CARP TO ASSIGN
CREDIT FOR THAT PURCHASE TO THE
INCENTIVE PROGRAM- THAT THAT'S
IMPORTANT BECAUSE AGAIN ALL
THESE BENEFITS FLOW FROM THE
INFLUENCE OF THE INCENTIVE
PROGRAM ON A PURCHASE DECISION.
AND KNOWING HOW EFFECTIVE THAT
PROGRAM IS REQUIRES
DISENTANGLING THAT BENEFIT FROM
FROM SOMETHING LIKE THE
REGULATIONS. IN THE CASE OF CRP
WHICH IS THE ONE PROGRAM WE
REVIEWED WHERE CAR ACTUALLY-
MEASURES AND SURVEYS ITS
PARTICIPANTS ABOUT WHAT
MOTIVATED THEM TO PURCHASE THE
VEHICLE. ABOUT HALF OF PEOPLE
SLIGHTLY SLIGHTLY LESS THAN
HALF PEOPLE SAY THEY WOULD HAVE
PURCHASED THE VEHICLE EVEN
WITHOUT THE CVR PETE REBATE.
AND SO- WHAT WE WHAT WE NOTED
HOWEVER IS THAT CARPET DONE
VERY LITTLE IN THAT PROGRAM OR
ANY OF ITS OTHER RELATIVES
RELATED PROGRAMS TO DETERMINE.
BASICALLY TO DETERMINE WHAT
THAT MEANS IN TERMS OF THE
PROGRAM'S EFFICACY AND TO MAKE
CHANGES TO THE PROGRAM THAT
WAITING YOU KNOW INCREASED IT'S
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF MOTIVATING
CONSUMERS TO DO YOU TAKE A STEP
THEY WOULDN'T OTHERWISE DO YOU.
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF WHAT WE
CALL THE REPORT. THREE RIDERS-
BUT- THE SO IN ORDER TO EXECUTE
ARMIES TO BE COLLECTING MORE
INFORMATION ON NOT JUST AS
PARTICIPANTS BUT ALSO OTHER
FACTORS THAT MIGHT DRIVE
DECISIONS RELATED TO- CONSUMERS
PURCHASES SUCH AS THESE
EXTERNAL FACTORS LIGHT FEDERAL
TAX CREDITS IS IN PREFERENCE
IT'S BETTER AND SO I'M REALLY
HAS A LOT OF WORK TO DO IN THAT
AREA. AND THESE THESE HAVE
IMPLICATIONS FOR SHORT TERM
REPORTING IT FOR LONG TERM
REPORTING ABOUT GHG EMISSIONS
ON THE SHORT END MISTER
AUDITOR'S ALLUDED TO AT THE
BEGINNING. THANK BY SHOULD AND
VIA THAT PROGRAM PAYS FOR CHIU
IT'S- EMISSIONS REPORTING TO A
LEGISLATURE CARBON OVERSTATING.
THE I. GHG EMISSIONS AND ITS
PROGRAMS ACHIEVE. AN IN SHORT
IS TAKING CREDIT FOR CPR BEFORE
EVERY DEBATE YOU THE ARCHITECT
IS OUT. WITHOUT TAKING ACCOUNT
FOR THE INFLUENCE OF THINGS
LIKE REGULATIONS REQUIRING SALE
WITHOUT TAKING ACCOUNT FOR
THINGS LIKE CONSUMER PREFERENCE
THAT. WOULD HAVE GIVEN THEM TO
PURCHASE THE VEHICLE EVEN
WITHOUT CPR. THAT HAS A SHORT
TERM OF ALSO OBSCURE. THE
PROGRAM'S COST EFFECTIVENESS
BECAUSE WHEN THEY'RE TAKING
CREDIT FOR LARGER AND LARGER
AMOUNTS OF GHG REDUCTIONS THEM
BACK SO WE ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR.
BOB I MAKE THEM LOOK MORE COST
EFFECTIVE OR EFFICIENT THAN
THEY MIGHT IN REALITY. AND
THESE HAVE LONGER TERM
CONSEQUENCES IN TERMS OF CARDS.
ARE USING THESE PROGRAMS YOU-
GENERATE. BUT STILL
SUSTAINABILITY IN THE AMONG
THESE ARE THESE NEW TECHNOLOGY
VEHICLES SO BRINGING USING
INCENTIVES TO BRING HIM. ZYRTEC
KNOWLEDGE YOUR SPRING CLEAN BUS
TECHNOLOGY TO THE POINT WHERE
INCENTIVES ARE NO LONGER NEEDED
AND THEY CAN BE ON THE FAST
TRACK TO ACHIEVING THOSE
OBJECTIVES ABOUT THE PUTTING
THOSE VEHICLES. OUT THERE ARE
SHORT TERM AND LONG TERM
IMPLICATIONS FOR PROGRAM DESIGN
AND FOR REPORTING THE
LEGISLATURE. THAT. STEM FROM
THESE GAPS WERE IDENTIFIED. AS
A RESULT WE MAKE US YOUR
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT AS BEEN
SPENT STATED YOU KNOW FOCUS ON
IMPROVED DATA COLLECTION%
APPROVED DATA ANALYSIS SOME OF
THOSE ARE AS SIMPLE AS
COORDINATING THE METRICS BEING
USED. OTHERS ARE RELATIVELY
SIMPLE IN TERMS OF EXPANDING
CARDS SURVEY ACTIVITIES AND
ENSURING THAT IT'S COLLECTING
INFORMATION FROM PARTICIPANTS
WERE ALREADY YOU KNOW WILLING
PARTICIPANTS RECEIVING A
FINANCIAL BENEFIT FROM THE
PROGRAM. AND THEN YOU KNOW
USING THOSE IN THAT INFORMATION
ABOUT BEHAVIOR ABOUT THE
REGULATORY PROGRAMS IMPACT. ON
AN INTERIM BASIS IMPROVE THE
MEASUREMENT OF THE PROGRAM'S
GHG EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS IN
REPORTS THE LEGISLATURE AND
BECAUSE WE EXPECT THAT TO
CONTINUE TO POTENTIALLY BE AN
ONGOING PROCESS. IT ALSO
RECOMMENDED THAT CAR KEEP IT
SUPPORT IN THE LEGISLATURE
APPRAISE ITS PROGRESS WHERE IS
IT ABLE TO IDENTIFY THIS
INFORMATION IS HAVING PROBLEMS
COLLECTING SOME INFORMATION.
THAT WAY THE LEGISLATURE HAS
MORE TRANSPARENCY ABOUT THE
RELIABILITY OF THE TOOLS IT'S
USING TO ALLOCATE THIS MONEY
THIS MONEY EVERY YEAR AND CAN
POTENTIAL YOU KNOW PROVIDE
ASSISTANCE TO OUR- GIFT CARD IS
RUNNING UP AGAINST
ADMINISTRATIVE OTHER HURDLES.
IN PERFORMING IN PERFORMING-
DISTANT ENHANCED MUCH. SO THE
LAST AREA I'LL SPEAK ABOUT
TODAY HAS TO DO WITH- THE
SOCIAL ECONOMICAL ASSOCIATE
WITH SOME OF THESE PROGRAMS. AS
BEEN STATED THERE ARE SOME
BROAD GOALS THAT CAN PERTAIN TO
THE ENTIRETY OF THE CAP AND
TRADE'S FUNDED PROGRAMS IN THE
STATE BUDGET PERTAIN TO THINGS
LIKE JOB CREATION AND THE ON
THE THIRD DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITY AND LOW INCOME AND
MIDDLE INCOME FROM ANY EXCUSE
ME. SENDING REQUIREMENTS THAT-
THAT HAVE BEEN DISCUSSED-
HOWEVER THERE ARE ALSO VERY
SPECIFIC PROGRAM- GOALS THAT
CARP HAS DEMONSTRATED OR HAS
RATHER- CLEAN FOR ITS PROGRAMS
THAT RELATE TO THINGS LIKE
INCREASING PARTICIPANTS CREDIT
SCORES THE STATE AUDITOR
SUMMARIED IN HER REMARKS. BY
ENABLING PARTICIPANTS TO TRAVEL
OUTSIDE OF THEIR COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE NOW THEY HAVE ACCESS TO
A RIDESHARE PROGRAM ALLOW THEM
TO GET TO DOCTORS APPOINTMENTS
OR GROCERY. STORE THEY COULDN'T
PREVIOUSLY ACCESS. EVEN CLAIMS
A MAXIMIZE. YOU KNOW PROBABLY
MAXIMIZING PARTICIPANTS
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES BECAUSE
NOW THEY HAVE A MORE RELIABLE
LESS EXPENSIVE SOURCE OF
TRANSPORTATION. I CAN GET THEM
TO TWO JOBS THEY CAN OTHERWISE
WORKING GET THEM GET THEM
THEY'RE RELIABLY. HOWEVER WHEN
WE LOOK AT WHAT CARD IS
ACTUALLY MEASURING AND
REPORTING IT REALLY IS JUST
LIMITED TO THOSE LEGALLY
REQUIRED DOLLAR SPENDING AND
DISADVANTAGED LONG. MINUTES
NORTHERN PARDON METRICS BUT
THEY'RE AT THE PROBABLY THE
HIGHEST LEVEL YOU KNOW THE
BROADEST LEVEL OF DETAIL THAT
CAR COULD POSSIBLY BE REPORTING
IN SOME OF THESE AREAS. AND SO
WHEN OUR TEAM WENT TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT WAS HAPPENING BETWEEN
THIS GAP ABOUT THE BENEFITS
THESE PROGRAMS ARE SUPPOSED TO
CONFER. AND WHAT'S ACTUALLY
COMING OUT OF CAR. WE FOUND
THAT THERE ARE TWO BASIC
REASONS WHY THIS IS A CURRENT.
THE FIRST IS THAT CAR MIGHT NOT
JUST. IT MIGHT NOT BE
COLLECTING THE DATA IN NEEDS TO
BE RESPONSIVE TO THE INTENTION
OF THE PROGRAM. THAT'S
CERTAINLY TRUE OF WHAT THE
STATE HONOREE FOR TWO REGARDING
THE LOAN REPAYMENT NUMBERS FOR
ITS FINANCING SYSTEM PROGRAM.
WE ASKED WHY CAR CAN'T MEASURE
THE LOAN REPAYMENT IN ORDER TO
JUSTIFY WERE TO BACK UP ITS
CLAIMS ABOUT INCREASED CREDIT
SCORES. HARPALUS WELL THEY
DON'T THEY DON'T CONTROL THE
LOANS THEMSELVES. SO AS A
RESULT THEY DON'T KNOW WHETHER-
PARTICIPANTS ARE ASKED TO BE
PAYING OFF ONE. NO WE WOULD
OBVIOUSLY ENCOURAGE CARPET DO
WHATEVER IT COULD TO ACCESS
THAT INFORMATION THROUGH ONE OF
ITS THIRD PARTY ADMINISTRATORS
ARE YOU KNOW USING ITS
AUTHORITY. OR LOOK FOR REMEDIES
TO DO SO IN ANOTHER WAY WITH
THE HELP OF THE LEGISLATURE
WHAT HAVE YOU. THAT MINIMUM WE
WOULD NOT EXPECT HARD TO DESIGN
A PROGRAM AND MAKE CLAIMS ABOUT
THAT PROGRAMS I THINK YOU SEE
THAT CAN'T BACK UP. WITH THAT.
ON THE OTHER HAND. THERE ARE
SITUATIONS IN WHICH CARP
HAPPIER LATELY HAS ACCESS TO IT
YOU COULD BE USING TO MEASURE
AND REPORT IS PROGRAMS BUT IT
JUST HASN'T DONE SO. I EXAMPLE
THERE HAS TO DO WITH ITS CLEAN
CARS FOR ALL PROGRAM- THAT
PROGRAM- PAYS PAYS. FOLKS TO
SCRAP OLD INEFFICIENT VEHICLES
TO REPLACE THEM WITH WITH NEWER
USED. VEHICLES INCLUDING SATURN
HYBRID VEHICLES. AND PART OF
THE ASSUMPTION THAT PROGRAM IS.
NOW THIS INDIVIDUAL HAS A MORE
RELIABLE SOURCE OF
TRANSPORTATION NOW THEY'RE
GONNA BE ABLE TO GET TO JOBS
AND JOB INTERVIEWS. WITH THIS
YEAR FINANCIAL BENEFIT TO THEM.
THAT'S THAT'S GOOD BEYOND THE
SECOND OR THIRD ORDER BEYOND
JUST PROVIDING. THEM YOU ACCESS
TO A VEHICLE SO. HI RECOGNIZED
WE KNOW TO BE NOTE BECAUSE NOT
ONLY DOES IT MAKE THE CLAIM
THAT THIS IS THE PROGRAM'S
INTENT. BUT IT DESIGNED A
FOURTEEN DIFFERENT OCCASIONS
WHEN ENTERING INTO CONTRACTS
WITH LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS. IT
DESIGN SAMPLE SURVEY QUESTIONS
THAT TRYING TO GET AT THESE
VERY ISSUES. HOW MUCH HOW HOW
HAS YOUR INCOME CHANGED SINCE
YOU'VE GOTTEN YOUR VEHICLE HOW
LIABLE AS YOUR NEW VEHICLE HOW
MUCH DOES IT COST YOU TO
MAINTAIN YOUR NEW VEHICLE IS
THATMORE OR LESS THAN USED.
RIGHT RUSSIANS ARE VERY
PERTINENT TO BE BIG THE I YOU
KNOW THE THEORY BEHIND THE
PROGRAM'S SECOND THIRD LEVEL
BENEFITS. HOWEVER WE WANT TO
LOOK AT THAT SURVEY DATA WE
FOUND CRIME ISN'T ACTUALLY
COLLECTED. AND NO AND NO AND
NOT ONLY DO THEY NOT COLLECTED
BUT THEY DON'T ACTUALLY
REQUIRE. THEIR DISTRICTS TO ASK
THOSE SPECIFIC QUESTIONS SO
KARMAZIN KNOW WHAT QUESTIONS
THEY ARE DISTRICT IS ACTUALLY
ASKING. THOSE QUESTIONS ABOUT
SOME UNRELATED QUESTIONS IT'S A
MIX OF QUESTIONS- SO. FAR MAY
HAVE A TROVE OF VERY USEFUL
DATA CENTER MAY HAVE SOMETHING
THAT'S COMPLETELY UNUSABLE YOU
KNOW SEVERAL YEARS. INTO THIS
PROJECT. SO CAN TO CONNECT THE
TENER DRESSED BE. THIS OF
ISSUES BY. WE PUT TOGETHER WE
THINK ARE PRETTY CALM. SET OF
RECOMMENDATIONS OF MISTRUST IN
THE LEFT SIDE. THOSE INCLUDE.
ARE GOING THROUGH AND- DOESN'T.
RICHARDS IT EXPECTS TO OPT.
THESE THAT ARTICLE JUST GO BE
GHG REDUCTIONS THAT'S IMPORTANT
BECAUSE IT'S AN IMPORTANT PIECE
OF TRANSPARENCY. TO ALLOW
PARTICIPANTS AND THAT AND
STAKEHOLDERS IN THE LEGISLATURE
KNOW WHAT THE EXPECTATION FROM
THESE PROGRAMS BUT IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT FROM ACCOUNTABILITY
STANDPOINT BECAUSE THESE
PROGRAMS. IT COSTS
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE TO OPERATE.
THE FINANCING ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM COSTS ABOUT SEVEN TIMES
AS MUCH TO REDUCE ONE TONNE OF
GHGS SOMETHING LIKE. T. V. R.
P. AND THE REASON FOR THAT IS
THERE'S A LOT MORE INVESTMENT
AND NOT JUST THE FINANCIAL
INCENTIVE. BUT ALSO THE TO THE
PARTICIPANTS- YOU KNOW THERE'S
HIGHLIGHTED LARGE STAFFING
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH. WALKING
PARTICIPANTS THROUGH THE LOAN
PROCESS COACH YOU ABOUT
FINANCIAL LITERACY BUT AS I'VE
ALLUDED TO ALREADY THAT'S KIND
OF WHERE THE INVESTMENT STOPS
AND WE DON'T KNOW WHETHER THAT
WAS. A SIZEABLE DOLLAR
INVESTMENTS ARE ACTUALLY PAYING
OFF. LIKE OUR STUDENTS.
OBVIOUSLY THE WE WOULD LIKE
CALL TWO GO USE THAT THAT. AND
MAKE SURE THAT MADE METRICS
WITH USABLE DATA. THAT CAN THAT
CAN BE USED TO REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND TO EXPORT ON.
YOU KNOW WHETHER PROGRAMS ARE
ACTUALLY WORKING AS A BASE TO
MAKE YOU BASED ON THE LOGIC
MODELS AND CREATIVE. AND
FINALLY USE THAT INFORMATION TO
RECOMMEND HAS ALREADY BEEN
ALLUDED TO IN THIS DISCUSSION.
THIS PROGRAM IS REALLY WORKING
IT'S REALLY PAYING OFF IN TERMS
OF THE SOCIOECONOMIC SIDE IT'S
WORTH THE ADDED INVESTMENT
VERSES. WE NEED TO TREAT THIS
OTHER PROGRAM WE NEED TO WE
NEED TO ASSESS WHETHER OR NOT
THESE TYPES OF BENEFITS ARE
ACTUALLY REASONABLE TO EXPECT
MUCH TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM.
AND SO FORTH SO- ON BOTH ON THE
GHGS INTERNET RECKONER SIDE.
THE REAL END GOAL OF ALL OF OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS TO PROVIDE
GREATER TRANSPARENCY AND
GREATER TOOL FOR THE
LEGISLATURE AND FOR CAR. USE TO
PURSUE THE DIVERSE BUT
IMPORTANT GOALS THAT CALIFORNIA
HAS SET FORTH IN ITS AMBITIOUS.
CARBON REDUCTION PLANS. AND SO
WITH THAT I THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AND WE'D
BE HAPPY TO AND ALL THE
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION- WITH THAT I
KNOW THERE'S A NUMBER OF
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS. WHAT
I'M GONNA DO IS WE'LL START
WITH QUESTIONS HERE IN THE ROOM
AND THEN WILL MOVE TO. REMOTE
PARTICIPATION FOR THE MEMBERS
THAT ARE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
THAT HAVE QUESTIONS. AND WITH
THAT I GUESS I'LL GO AHEAD AND
JUST KICK US OFF AND MAYBE I'LL
JUST ASK SOMETHING THAT- THAT
YOU GUYS BOTH TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER AND I MISS HOW
MENTIONED IT BUT THE TWENTY
FIFTEEN CARP. GUIDELINES TO
TRACK. THE BENEFITS THAT YOU
WERE TALKING ABOUT- WHAT WAS
THE REASON WHY CARVE- DID NOT
FOLLOW THESE GUIDELINES THAT
WERE OUTLINED BACK IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN. YOU KNOW WHAT DID THEY
SAY AS A REASON WHY THEY DIDN'T
DO THIS. THEY PROVIDED US TWO
REASONS MISTER SALAS ONE WAS.
THE COMPLEXITY THE TECHNICAL
COMPLEXITY INVOLVED IN
DEVELOPING A WAY TO MEASURE JOB
CREATION AS A FUNCTION OF THE
INVESTMENT ITS PROGRAMS ARE
MAKING HOWEVER WE KNOW WE'VE
GOT THAT IN OUR TEXT BY SAYING
WHAT THEY ULTIMATELY SETTLED ON
WAS A FAIRLY STANDARD AND
WIDELY USE INPUT OUTPUT- MODEL
THAT HAS BEEN USED IN THIS AREA
FOR A LONG TIME SO- WE DON'T
BELIEVE THAT THE YOU KNOW THE
TECHNICAL COMPLEXITY WAS REALLY
A LIMITING FACTOR IN THEIR
ABILITY TO ROLL THIS OUT- THE
OTHER ISSUE THAT THEY- WANTED
TO. IS THESE GRANT AGREEMENTS I
WOULD ADD TO THAT BUT THEY
ENTER INTO WITH THE THIRD
PARTIES THAT ADMINISTER A LOT
OF THESE PROGRAMS IN THE FIELD
AND THEY HAD SAID WELL BASED ON
THE TIMING OF SOME OF THESE
AGREEMENTS WE HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE
TO IN INSERT REQUIREMENTS INTO
THESE AGREEMENTS THAT COMPEL
THE ADMINISTRATORS TO REPORT
THIS INFORMATION TO US. AND YOU
KNOW WE POINTED OUT THAT YOU
KNOW NOT ONLY HOW MANY OF THESE
AGREEMENTS ENTERED INTO POST.
TWENTY FIFTEEN BUT THAT. I'M
THE AGREED THE AGREED THAT WE
WERE. CARP AS A MAN THOSE AGREE
ON YOUR TO. FOR THINGS LIKE
EXTENDING TIME EXTENDING DOLLAR
AMOUNTS AND SO FORTH SO WE
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE CARP TO
REVISIT THOSE ARRANGEMENTS WITH
ITS ADMINISTRATORS SAY. HEY
WE'D LIKE YOU TO THE
PERFORMANCE RELATIVELY- YOU
KNOW WILL COST A PIECE OF
ANALYSIS FOR US SO THAT WE CAN
MAKE SURE WE'RE FILLING OUR
OBLIGATION. TO STATE LAW BUT
ALSO TO OUR OWN FUNDING
GUIDELINES- AND SO WE'RE YOU
KNOW ANTICIPATING THAT QUICKLY
CARVEL PURSUE BOTH OF THOSE
REMEDIES YEAH. THANK YOU SO. TO
THE FIRST POINT THE TECHNICAL
COMPLEXITY YOU'RE SAYING- YOU
BELIEVE THEY CAN STILL PROVIDED
THAT INFORMATION IN TO THE
SECOND POINT- WHEN THEY AMENDED
ALL THE THIRD PARTY
ADMINISTERED CONTRACTS THEY
COULD ADD AN AMENDMENT IN THERE
TO ACTUALLY BUILD IN THE DATA
THAT WAS REQUIRED. UNDER
LEGISLATION. CORRECT HELLO OKAY
I WANTED TO ASK ABOUT ONE OF
THE INCENTIVE PROGRAMS THAT YOU
GUYS TALKED ABOUT IN THE REPORT
AB AND THAT'S THE CLEAN VEHICLE
REBATE PROGRAM THE CVR P.
PROGRAM WHICH YOU KNOW IS THE
SME WAY PROGRAM THAT ALLOWS
CONSUMERS TO APPLY FOR REBATES
IF THEY PURCHASED BATTERY
ELECTRIC VEHICLES HYDROGEN
FUELED ELECTRIC VEHICLES OR
PLUG IN HYBRID ELECTRIC LIGHT
DUTY VEHICLES ARE ZERO
EMISSION- MOTORCYCLES AND WHEN
I LOOKED AT THE REPORTER WAS
NEARLY ONE BILLION IN CAPITAL
RATE FUND THAT HAVE BEEN SPENT
ON THE PROGRAM. WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THAT. WHAT PERCENTAGE WAS
ACTUALLY SPENT AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. SURE
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION- WE
DON'T WE DON'T HAVE THAT NUMBER
OVER THE LIFE OF THE PROGRAM
ONE ONE REASON FOR THAT IS THAT
THE PROGRAM ACTUALLY PREDATES
THE REQUIREMENT IN STATE LAW SO
IT PREDATES THE LEGISLATION
THAT THAT PUT THOSE THAT
CREATED THE AC I DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES- SO WHAT I CAN TELL
YOU THAT IN RECENT YEARS- THOSE
NUMBERS HAVE BEEN RELATIVELY
LOW COMPARED TO SOME OF THE
OTHER PROGRAMS CARVE OPERATES.
I BELIEVE IN TWENTY NINETEEN TO
FOR YOUR ACCOUNT YOUR TWENTY
NINETEEN JUST THE MOST RECENT
YEAR ON WHICH CAR WAS REPORTED
THAT THE RP WAS AROUND TEN OR
11% IN SPENDING IS A PASSIONATE
SPENDING WHEREAS SOME OTHER
PROGRAMS LIKE THE- TRUCK AND
BUS ABOUT YOUR PROGRAM WERE
MUCH MUCH HIGHER AROUND FORTY
OR EVEN UP TO FIFTY PERCENT-
AND THEN I'D ALSO NOTE THAT IN
PREVIOUS YEARS OUR CAR WAS WAS
REPORTING. A LARGER POOL OF
CTRP SPENDING IN THOSE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
HOWEVER THAT WAS UNDER A
PREVIOUS- VERSION OF THE LAW
AND THE KINDS FROM CATTLE YEAH
ALLOWED PARDON OTHER AGENCIES
TO TAKE CREDIT FOR SPENDING
THAT DIDN'T TAKE PLACE DIRECTLY
INSIDE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES BUT RATHER IN A IN
A JOINING OR FINDING
COMMUNITIES THAT WE'RE IN
THIRTY BENEFIT ENVIRONMENTALLY
FROM FROM THE INVESTMENT
ANYWAY. NOTABLY THE LEGISLATURE
I AM TWENTY- TWENTY SIXTEEN
CAME THROUGH AND SAID NO WE
DEFINITELY WANT TO FOCUS THE
SPENDING IN THE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES THEMSELVES THAT'S
WE WANT TO SEE THE BENEFITS BUT
NCPR PIECE CASE THAT THAT SEEMS
TO HAVE COINCIDED WITH THAT A
PRETTY MARKET REDUCTION IN THE
NUMBER OF DOLLARS BEING SPENT
INTO MANAGEMENT. CON THANK YOU
AND I DON'T HAVE MY STAFF- PULL
UP SOME OF THE NUMBERS AND I
KNOW FROM TWENTY SIXTEEN AND
THE CV RP THE REBATE PROGRAM-
MORE THAN 80% WHICH WAS THIRTY
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS WAS SPENT.
OUTSIDE OF THE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND SO I JUST
WANTED TO ASK TO SEE IF YOU HAD
LOOKED AT THAT SPECIFICALLY IF
NOT THAT WE CAN MAKE. SURE
WE'RE ASKING CARP WHEN THEY
COME UP AFTER. AND I JUST I
WOULD NOTE SIR THAT THAT THAT
HE PERCENT AS I. OVER THERE
DISTANT COMMUNITY SPENDING SO.
THEY THEY CLAIM FORTY TWO
MILLION JUST ABOUT WHEN USED.
IN EIGHTY PER OF ACTIVE PLACE
OUTSIDE. OF THE DISK MANAGEMENT
AND SELF SO. IT'S A LITTLE EVEN
MORE NOTABLE THAN THANK YOU
HAVE GOT IT SOME OF THE FORTY
TWO MILLION THAT THEY WERE
SUPPOSED TO SPEND IN A
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY 80% OF
THAT WAS SPENT OUTSIDE OF A
DSADVANTAGED COMMUNITY. OF
THAT POCKET OF MONEY. THAT'S
WHAT I GOT IT. YES SIR. OKAY
AND THEN YOU HAD MENTIONED- AND
MISSILE ALSO TALKED ABOUT IT.
BUT THE OVERLAP IN THE%
PROGRAMS. AB DID THEY IS WAS
THERE ANY METRIC THAT CARD
PROVIDED TO ADJUST FOR THE
OVERLAP IN THE PROGRAMS THAT
YOU GUYS WERE WE TALKED ABOUT
IN THE AUDIT REPORT. NO SO YOU
KNOW WE LOOK AT EVERY PROGRAM
WE WENT TO WE WENT THROUGH IN
DETAIL THE REGULATORY-
JUSTIFICATION DOCUMENTS AND
THEN MANY OF THE FUNDING.
THAT'S ON THE REGULATORY
PROGRAM SIDE AND THEN. ON THE
INCENTIVE PROGRAM SIDE ALL OF
THE MATERIALS ASSOCIATED WITH
THE FUNDING PLANS FOR CARP
POSES FUNDING FOR THE PROGRAM.
LOOKING FOR ANY REALLY ANY
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT. OR ANY FORMAL
KIND OF EIGHT AND NOW IT'S JUST
OF THAT OVERLAP WHICH IS YOU
KNOW VERY STARK IN MANY CASES
AND DID NOT FIND IT- I WILL NOT
AND THIS IS IMPORTANT I DON'T
THE CONCLUSIONS YOU REACH AN
ODD IT. IS THAT THE REASON CARP
GAVE ON THE REGULATORY PROGRAM
SIDE WAS. THAT IT WANTS TO
DEVELOP STANDARDS REGULATIONS
AND RULES THAT ARE ACHIEVABLE
WITHOUT THE HELP OF INCENTIVE
PROGRAM- BECAUSE IT DOESN'T
KNOW WHETHER INCENTIVE POGRAMS
LIKE CBRC WILL EXIST IN
PERPETUITY. OR WHETHER THERE'LL
BE ENOUGH MONEY TO ACCOUNT FOR
THE ENTIRETY OF THE INDUSTRY
THAT'S BEING AFFECTED. AND SO
WE YOU KNOW WE KIND OF GAVE
CARD BENEFIT DOWN SO THAT'S A
REASONABLE APPROACH WHAT THAT
WHAT THAT MEANS ALMOST BY
DEFINITION IS THAT. THE
INCENTIVE DOLLARS SHOULD BE
CREATING REDUCTIONS ABOVE AND
BEYOND WHAT YOU REGULATIONS
WHICH YOU ALONE AND THAT'S
WHERE WE REALLY EXPECTED TO SEE
AN ANALYSIS FROM CLARK ABOUT.
OKAY WE HAVE C. B. R. P. WE
KNOW WE HAVE IS THAT REGULATION
THAT'S SUPPOSED TO STAND ON ITS
OWN IN TERMS OF ITS
EFFECTIVENESS. WHAT ELSE THE C.
B. R. P. BRING TO THE TABLE IN
TERMS OF VEHICLE SO. AND THERE
IS SOME INDICATION IN STATEWIDE
DATA THAT- IS THERE ARE BEING
THERE ARE MORE IS THAT IS BEING
SOLD IN THE REGULATIONS
CURRENTLY REQUIRE. A CAR HASN'T
DONE ANY ANY FORMAL EFFORT TO
DETERMINE WHETHER THAT'S THE
RESULT OF CVR PETE WHETHER
THAT'S THE RESULT OF. THE
CONSUMER PREFERENCE WHETHER
THAT'S THE RESULT OF FEDERAL
PROGRAMS ETCETERA SO THERE
STILL ARE PRETTY MUCH IN THE
DARK ABOUT THE MARGINAL BENEFIT
AT THE INCENTIVE PROGRAM TO
BRING TO THE TABLE. CALLACHAN
NOT OVERLAP DO YOU HAVE ANY
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO RECREATE A
POLICY. THAT ENSURES CLEAR
OUTCOMES FOR THOSE. WE DON'T
HAVE A LEGISLATE RECORD. I
DIRECTOR AT THIS. WE TRIED TO
BE- WE TRY TO GET AWAY BEING
OVER THE- ABOUT THE PROCESS
THAT CARD SHOULD- SHOULD. SHIP
APPROACH THAT'S WHERE ANOTHER
WE WORK. VERY PRESCRIPTIVE
ABOUT THE TYPES OF
CONSIDERATIONS SHOULD MAKE.
PART OF THAT IS YOU KNOW
THEY'RE THESE THIS ISSUE MAY
OR- MAY OR MAY NOT APPLY IN A
MEAT PIE MORE OR LESS GIVEN TO
SPECIFIC PROGRAM GIVEN THE
SPECIFIC VEHICLE. WE
INTENTIONALLY LOOK AT PROGRAMS
THAT WE THOUGHT HAD A HIGH RISK
OF OVERLAP OR POSSIBLE.
DUPLICATION OR REDUNDANCY- AND
IN ANOTHER ISSUE ANOTHER REASON
RATHER IS THAT CAR MADE YOU
KNOW HAS SIGNIFICANT WORK TO DO
TO THINK ABOUT. HOW THESE
PROGRAMS ARE DESIGNED. IN ORDER
TO STIMULATE THE GREATEST
ACTIVITY ON THE BACK END BUT
ALSO TO MAKE SURE THEY HAVE
METRICS THAT THEY CAN THEY CAN
BE ACCOUNTABLE FOR. THAT SAID-
YOU KNOW IF THERE IF THERE IS A
ROLE FOR LEGISLATIVE. OVERSIGHT
OR OR- EVER KIND OF BELIEVE
THAT CAR IS DOING THAT. NO WE
CAN CERTAINLY. KEEP PROVIDING.
SURGICAL SYSTEMS THAT YOU MIGHT
NEED. THANK YOU I HAVE A
QUESTIONS REMAIN A DEFERRED OF
COLLEAGUE IN THE ROOM- FOR
THEIR QUOTE. OF I DO WAY TO ASK.
MEMBERS KNOW THAT ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY IF YOU
WANT TO GET ON THE LISTS TO ASK
A QUESTION. I BELIEVE THE
QUICKEST AND MOST EFFICIENT WAY
IS TO JUST TEXT. ME AND I THINK
MY NUMBER WAS PROVIDED TO EACH
OF THE MEMBERS- TEXT ME AND
I'LL GET YOU AND Q. FOR A LINE
OF QUESTIONING SO WITH THAT
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE. TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN THAN
TO SENATOR GONZALEZ SENT TO
SENATOR DOLLY. THANKS AT FIRST
I WANT TO THANK THE AUDITOR AND
THANK SENATOR BRADFORD FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD IT'S
CRUCIAL. THAT WE HAVE GOOD
QUANTITATIVE DATA TO UNDERSTAND
THESE PROGRAMS THAT IMPROVE THE
MOVING FORWARD I THINK THAT
SHOULD BE EVERYBODY'S GOAL. AND
I REALLY APPRECIATE FROM. THE
AUDITOR HIGHLIGHTING SOME OF
THE DEFICIENCIES IN THE
REPORTS. I JUST HAVE A FEW
QUICK QUESTIONS- FIRST OF ALL.
ANOTHER STATEMENT I. DO THINK
THAT WHEN IT COMES TO. I'M
LOOKING AT THE ISSUE WITH
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
THE SORT OF UNDER UTILIZATION
OF. THE INCENTIVES I THINK T'S
ALSO REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
USE DATA TO UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE PROBABLY THAT THERE. VERY
WELL MIGHT BE BARRIERS. BEYOND
THE INCENTIVE THAT PREVENT
THOSE COMMUNITIES FROM TAKING
ADVANTAGE. OF THE PROGRAM- THE
INABILITY TO INSURE A CAR IN
ABILITY TO STORE CAR CHARGER
CARD IS A LOT OF THINGS BEYOND
THE PROGRAM ITSELF. SOME OF
WHICH COULD BE VERY WELL OUT OF
CARDS CONTROL AND I REALLY LIKE
THE COMMON FROM THE AUDITOR.
ABOUT LOOKING AT MOBILITY AND
EQUITY- YEAH AND SERVING
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IN
TERMS OF. HAVING AN EYE TOWARDS
NOT JUST SAYING WE WANT
EVERYBODY IN THESE COMPANIES
TO. PURCHASE A VEHICLE OR BE
ABLE TO BUT TO SAY WE WANT
EVERYBODY IN THESE COMMUNITIES
TO HAVE VERY GOOD CONVENIENT
MOBILITY OPTIONS. THAT ARE-
PROVIDE THEM BETTER MOBILITY
MODE TO MOBILITY NEEDS TO BE
THE GOAL NOT ANY PARTICULAR
TYPE OF VEHICLE- SO. MY
QUESTION IS IF AND WHEN MORE
COMMON IN THE MY QUESTION
EITHER CALL COMMENT IS THAT
SOME OF THE QUESTIONS THAT YOU
HAD HIGHLIGHTED AS POTENTIAL
QUESTIONS TO ASK PEOPLE IN
THESE COMMUNITIES ABOUT. THEIR
FINANCIAL STATUS BEFORE HAVING
A CAR AND AFTER INCOME. I DO
THINK COULD BE SEEN BY SOME
MEMBERS OF THE CAN OF THAT
COMMUNITIES BEING VERY
INTRUSIVE QUESTIONS SO I THINK
THAT IT'S NOT THAT EASY. TO GET
PARTICIPATION WITH THAT KIND OF
LINE OF QUESTIONING FOR ANYBODY
THEY'RE THEY'RE PRETTY INVASIVE
QUESTIONS. SO MY QUESTION IS.
THAT I WONDER WHETHER. THAT
THAT A LOT OF THESE IMPACTS ARE
ONLY BE ON CARBS. KIND OF
JURISDICTION UP BEYOND THEIR
ABILITY TO REALLY ASCERTAIN.
AND I'M WONDERING IF THE
AUDITOR HAS ANY SUGGESTIONS OF
WHO REALLY SHOULD BE DOING THIS
pLOOKING AT THIS BECAUSE I SAYS
LISTENING TO I WONDER WHETHER
CARP IS THE CORRECT. BODY TO DO
SO EVALUATION OF THOSE KINDS OF
IMPACTS SO THAT'S MY FIRST
QUESTION. CERTAINLY SO. I DON'T
I DON'T THINK IT'S OUR
INTENTION TO RULE OUT THE
ASSISTANCE FOR THE
PARTICIPATION OF ANY OTHER
ENTITY AND AS WE AS WE INCLUDE
IN OUR REPORT CARD IS UNDER
CONTRACT WITH YOU SEE AND OTHER
ENTITIES AND- I WITH THE- THE
AIM OF. OF A ATTEMPTING TO HAVE
IMPROVED SO MUCH DATA
COLLECTION- BUT I THINK WHAT WE
KEEP COMING BACK SO WE KEPT
COMING BACK TO IN OUR ANALYSIS
WAS IN. UNDERSTANDING THE
BARRIERS THAT THAT YOU THAT YOU
RAISED ABOUT SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS ARE ACCESSING THESE.
THOSE QUITE YOU KNOW THE
QUESTIONS YOU'RE REFERENCING
ARE ARE ARE CARDS ONLY DESIGNED
SO. IT APPEARS THAT THERE'S AN
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT CARL WHEN THEY
DESIGNED THESE PROGRAMS AND
THAT THEY CREATE A LOGIC MODEL
THAT SHOULD BE MEASURABLE- THAT
THEY EXPECT TO HAPPEN- WE JUST
HAVEN'T SEEN. THE LEVEL OF
EFFORT ON THE BACK AND SO YOU
KNOW IF WE HAD MORE OF THAT
EFFORT TRIAL AND ERROR TO
ASSESS AND WE KNEW MORE ABOUT
WHAT- IN ACTUALITY WHAT THE
BEARS HAVE BEEN TO CARD DATA
COLLECTION IT WOULD BE EASIER
FOR US TO SPEAK TO. WHO THE
RIGHT PERSON IS IF IT'S NOT CAR
BUT UNFORTUNATELY THAT'S NOT
KIND OF A- A REALITY WE WERE
ABLE TO EVALUATE. SO YOU DON'T
HAVE ANY ANY IDEAS OF KIND OF
WHAT THE RIGHT. WHO WHAT THEIR
IDENTITY WOULD BE SAID TO DO
THIS KIND OF ANALYSIS OR EVEN
TO THE DATA COLLECTION BECAUSE
IT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE IT'S- DONE
TO MY- CAR. TO ME. WELL IT'S
NOT JUST CAR. CAR PARTY. CAR
PAYS- ERR DISTRICTS AND ALL
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS TO
ADMINISTER. THESE PROGRAMS TO
INTERFACE WITH PARTICIPANTS TO
HANDLE. ALL OF THE APPLICATION
PROCESS SEES. AND SO ON THEY
MAY NOT BE CARVE ON THE GROUND
ASKING THESE QUESTIONS. BUT
THAT WOULD BE YOU KNOW THAT'S
KIND OF A NATURAL. YOU KNOW
INROAD INTO- YOU KNOW WORKING
WITH PARTICIPANTS REMAINING BE.
COLLECTING DATA WHATEVER IT MAY
BE RELEVANT TO THE PROGRAM BUT
WHAT WE HAVEN'T SEEN IS
APPROPRIATE KIND OF FORESIGHT
IN OVERSIGHT I'M CARP TO ENSURE
THAT IS POSITIONING ITSELF. TO
REQUIRE THAT DATA COLLECTION TO
HELP ITS PROGRAM ADMINISTRATORS
KNOW WHAT TO COLLECT AND
CERTAINLY TO REVIVE IT WHETHER
OR NOT IT'S BEING COLLECTED SO
AGAIN I WOULD I KIND OF JUST.
LIKE A BETTER PHRASE DEFERRED
TO THE FACT THAT- THERE DO SEEM
TO BE A RESOURCES IN PLAY AND
WITHOUT HAVING SEEN- EVIDENCE
OF IT BEING UNSUCCESSFUL IN THE
NEXT LEVEL OF EFFORT IT'S HARD
FOR US TO SPECULATE ABOUT WOULD
BE A MORE. A RESOURCE OKAY I
ASK BECAUSE YOU KNOW I DO I
THINK IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HAVE BETTER DATA AND WE HAVE
THE DATA AS WE EVALUATE- THESE
PROGRAMS. AND THEN MY LAST
QUESTION FOR NOW IS- WHAT IS
YOUR OFFICE AND BUSINESS THE
IDEAL OUTCOME FROM THIS AUDIT.
IS IT TO HAVE CARBS SPEND MORE
TIME ON PROGRAMMATIC YOU KNOW
QUALIFICATIONS AND- VALUATIONS
OR IS IT TO ELIMINATE THE
PROGRAM SAID AREN'T REALLY
DIRECTLY. REDUCING EMISSIONS. I
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT A GOOD.
POINT OF THE AUDIT IS AT THE
LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO UNDERSTAND
HOW THESE PROGRAMS INTERACT
WITH EACH OTHER RIGHT. BECAUSE
NO ONE PROGRAM IS GOING TO KIND
OF BE THE SILVER BULLET YOU'RE
A LOT OF DIFFERENT PROGRAMS AND
A LOT OF DIFFERENT POLICY. CAN
THIS ONLY BE ACCOMPLISHED WITH
THE QUANTIFICATION OF THE
IMPACTS OF THE PROGRAM OR IS
IT. JUST AS IMPORTANT FOR US TO
HAVE SORT OF A BETTER NARRATIVE
OF HOW ALL THESE PROGRAMS WORK
TOGETHER AND THE REGULATORY
SIDE WORK TOGETHER. THANK YOU.
I THINK THE NARRATIVE. THE
NARRATIVE IS RELATIVELY IN
PLACE IN SOME CASE RIGHT THAT
THE LOGIC MODELS DO YOU KNOW
THAT THE ASSUMPTIONS ARE NOT
UNREASONABLE AND OF PROGRAM BY
PROGRAM BASIS IT'S NOT- I DON'T
WE DIDN'T APPROACH THIS WITH
THE ANY SORT OF PRECONCEIVED
NOTIONS ABOUT YOU KNOW WHETHER
WHETHER IT DOES OR DOES NOT
MAKE SENSE TO ON THE ONE HAND
COMPELS CERTAIN TYPES OF
PRODUCTION AND SALE ON THE
OTHER HAND REALLY TRY TO HELP
PEOPLE. BRING CALIFORNIA PASSED
WHAT REGULATIONS CAN
REALISTICALLY ACHIEVE ON THEIR
OWN I DO THINK AT THIS POINT
REALLY DOES COME DOWN TO BEING
INTENTIONAL ABOUT LEARNING FROM
WHAT FOR MEASURING WHAT
PROGRAMS ARE ACTUALLY ABLE TO
ACHIEVE IN THESE DIFFERENT WAYS
AND WE ARE DIFFERENT DATA
SOURCES. AND BEING INTENTIONAL
ABOUT WHETHER THOSE PROGRAMS
ARE ADDING THE MAGNITUDE OF
BENEFITS THAT THAT THE STATE
WOULD EXPECT AND FUNDAMENTALLY
IN TERMS OF OUR PRODUCTS WE
WOULD HOPE THAT THAT IS
INFORMATION. FOR THE
LEGISLATURE THAT JOINS.
EVERYWHERE DATA ABOUT. YOU KNOW
THESE OF INCENTIVE PROGRAMS
PROVIDE THESE TYPES OF BENEFITS
RELIABLY MAYBE THESE DO NOT AS
MUCH WE SHOULD WE SHOULD INVEST
MORE IN PROGRAMS ACCESS AND
CONSIDER REVISIONS TO PROGRAM
WHY I THINK THE PROBLEM RIGHT
NOW IS THAT THE SAME SORT OF
LIMITATION EDELWEISS
MEASUREMENT WISE REPORTING WHY.
ARE KIND OF PRESENCE ACROSS THE
ENTIRE RANGE OF INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS BE REVIEWED AND SO THE
LEGISLATURE IS AS IT IS FORCED
TO TAKE AT FACE VALUE THE YOU
KNOW THE RELATIVE EFFICACY OF
THOSE PROGRAMS WHEN IN FACT
THOSE DON'T ACTUALLY THOSE
MEASUREMENTS DON'T ACTUALLY
TELL THE STORY ABOUT HOW THE
PUSH AND PULL WITH REGULATIONS
OR THE- THE INFLUENCE FROM
OUTSIDE OF CARDS CONTROL
WHETHER IT BE FROM OTHER STATE
PROGRAMS OR FEDERAL PROGRAMS.
SO IT DON'T START A SAYS IT IS
TO CLARIFY IT SOUNDS TO ME LIKE
YOU'RE SAYING THAT REALLY THE
ULTIMATE GOAL OF THE AUDIT IN
THE END OF THE DAY IS FOR US TO
UNDERSTAND THAT BIGGER PICTURE
OF HOW THESE PROGRAMS. INTERACT
WITH EACH OTHER. RIGHT SO IT'S
NOT REALLY TIED TO SAY THAT
ANYONE PROGRAMS NOT WORKING
IT'S- IT IS TO DEVELOP THAT
DATA SET THAT GIVES US THAT
THAT HOLISTIC PICTURE. WE WOULD
HOPE THAT THAT DATA SAID WOULD
TASK THE ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT HOW
THESE PROGRAMS FIT TOGETHER.
AND GIVE THE IN THE LEGISLATURE
INFORMATION ABOUT WHERE THEY'RE
GETTING BANG FOR THEIR BUCK
WHERE THEY'RE GETTING RETURN ON
INVESTMENT. SO THE LISTENER CAN
MAKE INFORMED AND RELIABLE
DECISIONS ABOUT WHERE TO PUT
OUR RESOURCES IN THE PURSUIT OF
THE CALLS SO YES. UNDERSTANDING
ROGAN'S WHAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED
TO ACCOMPLISH IS A KEY STEP.
BUT YOU KNOW THAT IN AND OF
ITSELF IS NOT GOING TO BE
SUFFICIENT FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO MAKE. YOU KNOW CLEAN BASS
MAKES RELIABLE INVESTMENTS NOW
IT MIGHT ONLY BE SUFFICIENT TO
ALLOW US TO GET TO TWENTY
THIRTY AND THEN LOOK BACKWARDS
AND SAY. YOU KNOW WE'RE OUR
ASSUMPTIONS CORRECT YES OR NO.
THAT'S NOT THAT WE DON'T
BELIEVE THAT'S A SUFFICIENT
PLACE FOR THE STATE TO KIND OF.
WAIT AROUND. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIMPLY WOMAN FRIEDMAN- SOUNDS
LIKE THREE WITH MORE DATA YOU
HAVE YOU CAN DETERMINE. THE
MOST BANG FOR THE BUCK IS KIND
WITH THEIR- TALKED ABOUT WITH
THE WILL OF THE CENTRE GONZALEZ
AND THEN WILL MOVE TO- SON.
SENATOR DOLLY THEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRAZIER THAN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FONG AND SENATOR
MCCASKEY. YES THANK YOU- THANK
YOU CHAIR SALASAND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THIS- PANEL. MOST
OF THE QUESTIONS THAT I ASK
ACTUALLY HAVE BEEN ANSWERED
BUT- I JUST WANT TO DRILL DOWN
ON ON ONE PARTICULAR PROGRAM
THAT YOU'D MENTIONED WHICH IS
THE LOAN REPAYMENT INCREASE
CREDIT SCORES GOAL- AND I GUESS
THE- DISCUSSION THERE WAS THAT
THEY- DON'T. FROM CARBS
PERSPECTIVE IS THAT THEY DON'T
CONTROL THE LOANS BUT CAN YOU
GIVE US MORE. ON WHAT
RECOMMENDATIONS COULD BE PUT
FORWARD IN ADDITION TO JUST
STATING FLATLY THAT THEY CAN'T
CONTROL THE LOANS I MEAN WHAT.
I MEAN THIS I THINK IS A BIG
FACTOR IN. OBVIOUSLY THIS THIS
PROGRAM AS WELL. IT DEFINITELY
SO YOU KNOW POTENTIALLY
POSSIBLY MINUS REMARKS KIND OF
SHOWED UP YOU WEREN'T FULLY
CONVINCED BY THAT YOU KNOW LACK
OF OWNING A LOAN AS A AS A TRUE
LIMITING FACTOR AND- YOU KNOW
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT'S BEEN
RAISED ABOUT THE POTENTIAL YOU
KNOW. INVASIVENESS OF QUESTIONS
YOU KNOW WE ARE ENCOURAGED HARD
TO DO WHAT I CAN TO WORK WITH
THIS PROGRAM ADMINISTRATORS TO
SAY. YOU KNOW ARE YOU A
SUCCESSFULLY REPAYING YOUR LOAN
I MEAN THE CARB CARB
ALTERNATIVE WE IDENTIFIED THE
FREQUENCY- REPOSSESSIONS OF
VEHICLES IS ANOTHER POTENTIAL-
TOOL THEY COULD USE BUT THAT'S
NOT SOMETHING THEY'VE LOOKED AT
FORMALLY WHEN WE RAISE THAT
WITH THAT MAKE IT KIND OF WENT
AND LOOKED TO SEE WHAT HAPPENED
AND- AND SO IT'S A SMALL SMALL
PROGRAM THUS FAR SO WE HAVEN'T
REALLY. UTILIZE THIS DATA TO
TRY AND EXTRAPOLATE ABOUT HOW
EFFECTIVE THE PROGRAM IS. A
HUNDRED AND THAT WAS WELL IT
IT'S A HIGHLY PROGRAM SO IT'S
KIND OF RELATIVELY SMALL BY ITS
NATURE AND WHAT BETTER TIME TO
BE USING TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
THE PROGRAM'S RELATIVE. SIZE TO
BE CREATIVE ABOUT. HOW GOING TO
CALL THE GAP. WHITE WHERE YOU
ARE NOW AND WHAT YOU THINK THE
PROGRAM IS SUPPOSED TO PROVIDE
TO ITS PARTICIPANTS IN TERMS.
IT'S PAST SUPPORT SO. WE'RE NOT
WE'RE NOT OPPOSED TO USING A
REASONABLE STANDING OR PROXY
FOR. CREDIT SCORES BUT CAR IS
KIND OF WELL SHORT OF THAT. AND
I MEAN THE LAST THING I'LL SAY
ABOUT THIS PROGRAM SINCE YOU'VE
EXPRESSED INTEREST IS. ALREADY
OVER THE PROGRAM DATA THAT CAR
DOES COLLECT. THE SUGGEST THAT
THERE'S PRETTY WIDE VARIATION
IN THE LOAN INTEREST RATES THAT
THE PROGRAM IS INVOLVED. SO YOU
DON'T MISS ANY LOANS ACHIEVED
THROUGH THE PROGRAM DIRECTLY
BUT WE SAW ALONE DESPITE YOU
KNOW UPWARDS OF25% ON SOME OF
THESE OTHER VEHICLE. DITIONS
AND SO I GUESS I'M- TRY TO
DIVORCE FROM WHAT'S DIRECTLY
INSIDE AND OUTSIDE OF CARDS
CONTROL WE DO FEEL LIKE IT'S IN
OUR CONTROL IS TO BE. VERY
PROACTIVE AND RESPONSIVE TO
WHAT THEY'RE SEEING IN THAT
THERE THE SITE IS THAT ALONE
THAT WE WANT TO ASSOCIATE WITH
OUR PROGRAM IS THAT A LOAN THAT
PROVIDES. THE PARTICIPATE WITH
THAT TYPE OF OPPORTUNITY
PROGRAM IS INTENDED TO PROVIDE
AND IF NOT THEN WE NEED TO SEE
INTERVENTIONS AND WE NEED TO
SEE THEM. AT THE PILOT PROGRAM
STAGE BEFORE THERE IS A
DECISION MADE TO EXPAND THIS
PROGRAM LARGER OR ALTERNATELY
NOT TO PURSUE IT SO I HOPE I
ANSWERED YOUR QUESTION. YES YOU
DID AND I JUST WANNA SAY THANK
AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT I
WANTED TO THE POINT I GUESS I'M
TRYING TO MAKE AS WELL AS THAT
YOU KNOW. THERE'S SO MANY OTHER
ISSUES THAT COULD HAVE HAPPENED
BECAUSE OF LACK OF OVERSIGHT
WHICH IS THESE HIGH INTEREST
RATES WHICH PUTS PEOPLE DEEPER
IN. DEBT AND THAT- A MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT SITUATION THAN THEY
NEED TO BE- SO I APPRECIATE
THAT AND SO I'LL LEAVE IT THERE
BUT WELL I WHAT I WILL SAY IS
I'M JUST SORT OF. TAKEN ABACK
BY THE LACK OF DATA COLLECTION
THIS LOAN REPAYMENT PROGRAM
THAT SHOULD BENEFIT PEOPLE AND
THEN THE CONSUMER BEHAVIOR
TRENDS SHOULD BE A GOAL AS YOU
MENTIONED. I NEED THAT DATA TO
BE ABLE TO ASSUME- THAT YOU
KNOW THIS IS WORKING OR NOT AND
BE ABLE TO ADJUST POLICIES FROM
THERE ON SO THANK. YOU VERY
VERY MUCH FOR ANSWERING THAT
QUESTION. I YOU SENATOR BECAUSE-
I KNOW SENATOR BRAD- HOW A LOT
OF CONCERN WHEN WE- INITIALLY
TALKED TO BE ABOUT THE AUDIT
ABOUT THE SOCIAL ECONOMIC
BENEFITS- THAT CARBS CLAIMING
SO THINK PRESS. ASKING THAT
QUESTION ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
BRADFORD AS WELL. I WAS MOVED
TO SENATOR DOLLY POLICE. I
THINK THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS I. WANTED TO- JUST
FIRST OFF THANK GOD- SENATOR
LAYERED FOR HIS OPENING
COMMENTS IT'S BEEN TWELVE YEARS
SINCE TWO THOUSAND. AND EIGHT
WHEN WE WHEN THEY PASSED AB
THIRTY TWO AND I DON'T KNOW IF
THERE'S A BEER THE ONLY MEMBER
SITTING THAT ACTUALLY WAS HERE
THAN THAT WHEN I HAPPEN I'M NOT
SURE- BUT IN THE AUDITOR'S
REPORT- SO AND SINCE THEN WE
HAVE WE HAVE SEVEN AS OF
OCTOBER LAST YEAR. THERE WERE
SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND JOBS
SOLD IN CALIFORNIA. AT THE
AUTHORS REPORT NOTED ALL THE
STATE'S ZAB GOALS HAVE BEEN
ESTABLISHED THROUGH EXECUTIVE
ORDER FIRST GOVERNOR BROWN WITH
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION BY
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE AND THEN
FIVE MILLION BY TWENTY THIRTY.
AND THE GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER DIRECTED THEY
ARE BE TO ACHIEVE A HUNDRED
PRESENTS HAVE CELLS BY TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE. WHICH IS FOURTEEN
YEARS FROM NOW SO AT THE RATE
WE WENT IN THE PAST AND THE
RATE WE'RE GOING. MY QUESTION
IS NUMBER ONE WHAT. WHAT
STATUTORY AUTHORITY WILL BE
RELIED ON TO ADOPT REGULATION
TO BAN THE SALES OF INTERNAL
BUSTIN CAN ENGINE BY TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE. AS DIRECTED BY THE
GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S EXECUTIVE
ORDER. SO I GUESS I CAN SAY
THAT EXECUTIVE ORDER WASN'T
WASN'T A PRIMARY FOCUS OF THE
AUDIT HOWEVER I'M I'M DEFERRED.
ON THE F. LEGAL COUNSEL HERE I
DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S SOMETHING
YOU CAN SPEAK TO OR NOT IT
WASN'T- ADDRESS FOCUSED. THAT
WASN'T A DIRECT FOCUS OF OUR
OUTAGE. BUT IN SO FAR AS WHAT
KIND OF STATUTORY AUTHORITY THE
LEGISLATURE CAN PASS WHAT IT
WANTS TO AS LONG AS IT'S NOT IN
CONFLICT WITH FEDERAL LAW.I
MIGHT THAT'S MY POINT IS THAT
THE LEGISLATURE HASN'T PASSED
THESE HAVE BEEN DONE BY
EXECUTIVE ORDER SO THAT WAS MY
QUESTION ACTUALLY. AND SENATOR
IT MIGHT BE- PRUDENT UPON US
WILL ASK CARP THAT QUESTION
WHEN THEY WHEN THEY COME UP
SINCE WILL BE THE IMPLEMENTING
BODY. OKAY THAT'S MY ONLY
QUESTION FOR RIGHT NOW THAN.
OKAY THANK YOU SENATOR WITH
THAT WILL MOVE TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRAZIER THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FONG. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. THIS IS KIND OF
REMINISCENT OF. MY ROLE AS THE
CHAIR OF TRANSPORTATION THE FOR
ALMOST SIX YEARS AND- BEFORE
THAT THE CHAIR OF
ACCOUNTABILITY MINISTRY TO
REVIEW WHICH I HAD MY FIRST CAR
APPEARING IN THE DISTRICT.
EIGHT YEARS AGO AND- HE MIGHT
BECAME THE CHAIR OF
TRANSPORTATION WE WERE MADE
AWARE OF THE FIFTY PLUS
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS THAT
WERE ADMINISTERED BY CARBON-
AND- WE DID HAVE HEARINGS TO
ASCERTAIN. WHAT THEIR METRICS
OF PERFORMANCE PLUS. AND AFTER
HAVING TO HAVE I BELIEVE IT WAS
THREE SUBSEQUENT HEARINGS TO
GET THE INFORMATION. THE SAME
KIND OF RESULTS JUST CAME OUT
OF THIS AUDIT IT'S LIKE DEJA VU.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE'VE ASKED THEM IN THE HOUSE
YOU KNOW WHAT WAS THE OBJECTIVE
OF THE PROGRAM. DID YOU
ACCOMPLISH THE GOALS OF THE
PROGRAM HOW MUCH DOES IT COST.
AND WHAT WAS THE- METRIC
TONNAGE THAT WAS REDUCED.
NOBODY HAD ANY KIND OF DATA
WHATSOEVER TO TELL US. WE WOULD
HAVE HOUGHT THAT THROUGH THAT
PROCESS WITH THE TRANSPORTATION.
COMMITTEE THAT THAT WOULD HAVE
EVOLVED. BUT IT SEEMS TO COME
FORWARD THAT. THERE'S THIS KIND
OF VIEWPOINT THAT HAVE WILL
JUST COME TO YOU AND WE'LL DO
WHAT WE WANTED TO. AND YOU KNOW
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT IF YOU
LOOK AT. THE MONIES THAT HAVE
BEEN SPENT SINCE. CAP AND TRADE
IS BEEN INVOLVED. 25% OF CAP
AND TRADE GOES TO HIGH SPEED
RAIL. ANOTHER 25% OF CAP AND
TRADE GOES TO TRANSIT. WE HAVE
GONE THROUGH A HUGE RECESSION
FROM TWO THOUSAND EIGHT AND
RECOVERED LATE TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE AND AN ARMED WE JUST HAD
A HUGE PANDEMIC. BUT THERE WAS
NEVER ANY RELIEF FOR GOALS OR
ANYTHING THROUGH INDUSTRY SO
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE ECONOMIC
IMPACTS THAT WERE INVOLVED IN
PEOPLE FOR REGULATION TO COMPLY.
THERE WAS NO COMPASSION
WHATSOEVER IT WAS ONLY ONE
GOAL. AND YOU HAD TO COMPLY NO
MATTER WHAT. I'VE SEEN
BUSINESSES COMPLETELY
DEVASTATED BECAUSE OF THE TRUCK
AND BUS ROLL. PEOPLE LATER ON
IN LIFE THAT YOU DON'T WANT TO
RE INVEST. HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS IN
EQUIPMENT SO THEY CAN FINISH
OUT THE LAST TWO OR THREE YEARS
OF THEIR- YOU KNOW WORKING LIFE-
I AM SO HAPPY THAT WE WERE
FINALLY I THINK THIS IS THE
FIRST AUDIT OF THIS AGENCY. L.
I AM HAPPY AND I CAN'T THINK
THE STATE AUDITOR AT A NOT FOR
MAKING THIS. EFFORT WHO IS ALSO
A FANTASTIC UMPIRE. THROUGH THE
JOINT BASEBALL SOFTBALL UP BUT-
MISTER CHAIR ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT THIS WAS CLEARLY OUTLINED
IN THE TRANSPORTATION HEARINGS
IS THIS EXACT EXAMPLE WHAT WAS
CLEARLY BROUGHT FORWARD IN THE
A LOT OF. WE HAVE THE ROLE AS A
AS A BODY TO PROVIDE OVERSIGHT
FOR THE MONEY THAT IS SPENT.
WHEN YOU LOOK SENSE CAP AND
TRADE DISPENSED INSTALLED IN
TWELVE TWENTY THIRTEEN I THINK
INVESTMENT WAS STARTING TO BE
MADE. TWELVE POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS HAVE BEEN INVESTED TO
REDUCE I THINK APPROXIMATELY
FORTY FIVE MILLION METRIC TONS
OF. CARBON WHICH IS VERY VERY
BOTTOM PLATES VERY. I AM VERY
PROUD OF THAT. BUT IN THEIR
SCOPING PLAN THEY DON'T
IDENTIFY NATURAL CARBON
EMISSIONS. AND SO THAT FORTY
FIVE MILLION METRIC TONS AND
TWELVE AND A HALF BILLION
DOLLARS THAT WAS SPENT. WITH
NEGATED BY THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
WILDFIRES IN CALIFORNIA WANT TO
TALK ABOUT DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. EVERYTHING IN
CALIFORNIA WAS A DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITY WITH ALL THAT SMOKE.
SIXTY EIGHT MILLION METRIC TONS
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN- NEGATING
SEVEN YEARS OF INVESTMENT.
SEVEN YEARS WE NEED TO BE ABLE
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE THE
BIGGEST BANG FOR OUR BUCK AND
INVESTMENT TAILPIPE EMISSIONS
ARE IMPORTANT BUT IF YOU KEEP
THROWING BAD MONEY AFTER GOOD.
AND THEN WE HAVE THESE NATURAL
OCCURRING WILDFIRES IN SANTA
CRUZ AND ALL OF THESE AREAS ARE
DEVASTATED. WE ARE NOT MAKING
ANY ACCOMPLISHMENTS WHAT SO
EVER. TAKE TWO STEPS FOUR AND
FIVE PACK. TWO HUNDRED MILLION
METRIC TONS OF BEEN ADMITTED
AND THREE YEARS OF WILDFIRES.
WE NEED TO RETIRE PRIORITIZE TO
BE ABLE TO CATCH UP ON THE
LARGEST CARBON EMITTER. AND BE
ABLE TO COME BACK. AND SAY OKAY
WE'VE GOT A HANDLE ON THIS NOW.
WELL WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO WORK
TOWARDS THAT. MISTER CHAIRMAN I
APPRECIATE YOUR LETTING ME
SPEAK MY PIECE THANK YOU SEVEN
MEMBER FRAZIER I THINK YOU JUST
HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THE
FRUSTRATIONS OF MEMBERS HAVE I
KNOW YOU SAID YOU HAD A NUMBER
OF HEARINGS. ON CARBON STILL
SAYING THE LACK OF DATA I THINK
IS WHAT THE AUDIT REPORT IS.
KIND OF ALLUDED TO SO THAT WE
CAN MAKE MORE INFORMED
DECISIONS- WITH THAT WILL MOVE
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG. I
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- I WANT.
BUILD OFF OF- SOME QUESTIONS
THAT- THE ASSEMBLY
TRANSPORTATION CHAIR MENTIONED
ABOUT WHETHER. CAR BIZ RIGHT
ENTITY- TO EVALUATE ITS
PROGRAMS AND I'VE HEARD FROM I
GUESS IT READING THAT THE AUDIT
REPORT THERE IS SOME PROGRAMS
THAT THAT I IDENTIFIED THAT
INDICATE THAT CAR CAN COLLECT
THE DATA AND IT DOESN'T. AND
THEN THERE ARE SOME PROGRAMS
THAT STATE THAT INDICATE THAT
CAR DOESN'T HAVE THE CAPABILITY
TO COLLECT THE DATA RIGHT NOW
I'M INTO IT KIND OF COVERS THAT
SPECTRUM- SO I GUESS AND FROM
MY UNDERSTANDING AND OF COURSE
WHAT ON. WHAT THE
TRANSPORTATION CHAIR FROM THE
SENATE HAS SAID IS THAT WE KNOW
WE'RE EVALUATING IN THE BUDGET
YOU KNOW BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
THAT ARE GOING TO BE GOING TO
HE'S PROGRAMS BUT WE CAN'T AS A
LEGISLATURE EVALUATE WHETHER
THINGS ARE WORKING OR NOT. AND
YOU KNOW IF YOU'VE GOT.
PROGRAMS THAT CARVER SAYING
WORKS BUT THERE'S NO EVIDENCE
TO BACK IT UP AND THEN THERE.
BOB GRAHAM'S THAT DON'T HAVE
ANY DATA WHATSOEVER SO. HOW DO
I JUST SUPPOSE THAT REALITY
WITH THE TIMELINESS OF THE FACT
THAT WE'RE MAKING DECISIONS
RIGHT NOW. SO AND SO HOW DO I
HOW DO I EVALUATE THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS WERE. YOU
ASKING FOR AN ANNUAL REPORT.
BUT WE'RE MAKING DECISIONS NOW.
I CERTAINLY. HAS WITH THE WITH
THE CHALLENGE THERE AND I CAN
ONLY SAY IN TERMS OF THE TIMING
OF OUR REPORT OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT THOSE ARE
ARE IN PART A FUNCTION. WHAT
KIND OF THE LACK OF A STRONG
FOUNDATION FOR MANY OF THE
PROGRAMS- I JUST WANT TO BACK
UP SLIGHTLY TO CLARIFY THAT I
THINK. YOU KNOW THERE IS A
SPECTRUM OF LEVEL OF DIFFICULTY
POTENTIAL LEVEL OF EFFORT TO
SOME OF THIS DATA BUT I DON'T
KNOW THAT WE IDENTIFIED
REPORTED ON MANY THAT ARE
SQUARELY WITHIN THE CAR CANNOT
ACCESS. THAT ARE HAS NO WAY OF
THE- HEATING OR- IF FOR NO
OTHER REASON THAN- CARB IS NOT
DEMONSTRATED THE EFFORT FROM
OFFER TO DO SO. SO THAT THAT
LACK OF DATA COLLECTION- THAT
LACK OF A PROGRAM AND YOU KNOW
DESIGN OR SYSTEMS BUILT INTO
PLACE TO BE. HERE IT IS AND TO
BE RESPONSIVE TO DATA WHEN IT
COMES AND OTHER P. BEHAVIORAL
DATA. BUT- BE- THEY ABOUT. THE
NEW YOU KNOW THE NUMBER OF.
BEING STOLEN CALIFORNIA RIGHT
YOU KNOW IT'S A THAT COME TO
REGULAR. OF TO THE SYSTEM
THAT'S CURRENTLY BEING USED.
THE WILL TAKE TIME FOR CAR TO
PUT IN PLACE. AND TO. TEST YOU
KNOW THE- THEIR ASSUMPTIONS
KNOW WE'VE- WE IDENTIFY I THINK
THE REPORT WHERE THERE'S LOW
HANGING. AND WE EXPECT TO BE.
JUDICIOUS IN AND CRY. OF
GETTING AFTER THAT STUFF FIRST
AND FOREMOST AND- MAKING- YOU
KNOW LARGE CONCLUDE. FOR FROM
THAT THERE COLLECTION THEY IF
THEY WERE AND THEIR SIR EFFORTS.
THAN YOU KNOW YOU COULD YOU
COULD TEST SOME BASIC
ASSUMPTIONS AT LEAST ON THE
SUBJECT. SIDE CATCH THE VERY
QUICKLY. BUT I'M FOR. YES
THERE'S GOING TO HAVE TO BE
INTERNET. AND A COMPLEX PROCESS
DID NOT THAT. SO I THINK YOU
KNOW. FINANCIER QUESTIONS I CAN
THERE IS YOU KNOW THE LEGACY OF
THE TIME LAG BETWEEN WHEN SOME
OF THESE PROGRAMS HAVE GONE IN.
PLACE THE MONEY THAT'S BEEN
SPENT ON THEM AND WHEN WE FIND
OURSELVES NOW. SO THERE'S A
LITTLE BIT NOT ISN'T THE
SITUATION OF MISSED OPPORTUNITY
WITH RESPECT TO THAT AND- THAT
WAS CERTAINLY. NOT FRUSTRATING
TO US AS A TEAM BUT WE TRIED
TO- BE STRATEGIC AND BE DIRECT
ABOUT WHERE CARP SHOULD GO IN
ORDER TO. RECTIFY THAT GOING
FORWARD. SO I'M I'M- I
APPRECIATE THAT- AND- THAT
PERSPECTIVE I GUESS- I KNOW I'M
GONNA CHANNEL MY- FRUSTRATIONS
I THINK FOR- THROUGH THE- WHAT
WAS SAID- TO THE FORMER
TRANSPORTATION CHAIR OF THE
ASSEMBLY. THAT YOU KNOW YOU
WOULD THINK THAT THESE THINGS
WOULD HAVE BEEN PUT INTO
MOTION. A DECADE AGO. AND NOW
WE'RE- OVER A DECADE IN AND WE
STILL DON'T KNOW OR WE MAY NOT
HAVE THE ABILITY. TO KNOW
WHETHER THESE PROGRAMS OR EVEN
AN ACTIVE OR NOT. AND THEN AT
THE SAME TIME THE VERY AGENCY
THAT IS. NOW GONNA COME BEFORE
US AS A LEGISLATURE IS ASKING
FOR MORE MONEY. TELLING US TO
THESE PROGRAMS ARE WORKING WE
DON'T KNOW IF THEY'RE WORKING
OR NOT- SO I THINK THAT'S THE
BIG CHALLENGE WE HAVE AS-
THROUGH THIS AUDIT AND AS- THE
VICTIMS RAISING COMMITTEES AND
THROUGH- THE BUDGET PROCESS. IS
WE ARE TRYING TO GET. THE CAR
BACK TO- GIVE US REAL TIME
INFORMATION WHICH IS CRITICAL-
AND IF WITH AT THE SAME TIME
ALSO. UNDERSTANDING THAT THEY
MAY NOT BE VERY OBJECTIVE. IN
TERMS OF WHETHER. THE PROGRAMS
ARE WORKING OR NOT. I'VE NEVER
HAD AN AGENCY TESTIFIED BEFORE.
US THAT SAID THEIR PROGRAMS ARE
WORKING. THE SAY THAT THERE
WORKING ANYMORE FOR. AND WHEN
YOU'VE INDICATED THAT THE FACT
THAT. THE OBJECTIVES AND THE
AND THE- AND THEM- OF THE
PROGRAMS ARE NOT ALIGNED WITH
THE GOALS AND THE REPORTS-
THAT'S VERY DISCONCERTING FOR
SOMEONE LIKE MYSELF AND I'M
SURE OTHER MEMBERS LEGISLATURE.
WHO- PRIDE THEMSELVES ON TRYING
TO HOLD ON AGENCIES ACCOUNTABLE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOGGY AND I
KNOW YOU SERVE UP BUDGET
COMMITTEE WITH MAYBE YOU. MIGHT
BE PRUDENT TO ASK CAR WITH THEY
WANTED TO FOR SOME OTHER BUDGET
TO THIS DATA COLLECTION FROM
THE THIRD PARTY PROVIDERS WELL
AND THIS MAY BE ADDED. TO THE
CHAIR MAY BE SOMETHING WHERE
YOU KNOW SUB SIX MAP THAT. WILL
DO SOME PART PROGRAM EVALUATION
AS WELL WITH THAT WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE TO OUR REMOTE
PARTICIPATION- SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE SKI. GETS ON THE WHITE
HOUSE KIANA. OKAY WILL COME
BACK TO SENATOR WHITE HOUSE YOU
LET'S MOVE TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON. CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
PLEASE PROCEED MR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- DON'T KNOW IF THIS
QUESTION WAS ALREADY ASK LET
ME. ASK IT AND I JUST RELY ON
YOU JUST TELL ME ABOUT THIS IS
QUESTIONS BUT ASK ALREADY
ACCORDING TO THE AUDITOR'S
REPORTS PAGE THIRTY TWO ONE
CAUGHT YOUR ATTENTION PAGE
THIRTY TO- THIRTY THROUGH
THIRTY THREE YOUR PREVIOUS
REPORTED- TO THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE THAT YOU WOULD NEED
TO PAY TWO POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS REBATE TOTALING FIVE
POINT. SIX BILLION TO GET FIVE
MILLION THEY- ON THE ROAD TO
MEET THE GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE
ORDERS HOW DO YOU HOW DID YOU
DETERMINE. THAT YOU WHAT NEEDS
OF THE TO SPEND FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS IN PUBLIC FUNDING TO
ACHIEVE THE GOVERNOR'S TARGET
TARGET WITHOUT COLLECTING THE
VALUATION ARE THE RELEVANT DATA
NEEDING- THAT WAS NOTED IN THE
AUDITOR'S REPORT. IS EVIDENCE
DO YOU UNDERSTAND THE QUESTION.
YES SIR BARCELONA CLARIFY THE
I'M NOT SPEAK ON OF AUDITORS
IT'S REALLY THAT IS BUT I COULD
I COULDN'T COVERAGE FOR I WAS
PERSPECTIVE I'M HAPPY O TALK
ABOUT THAT ISSUE IN THE REPORT
IF YOU'D LIKE ME TO. WOULD YOU
PLEASE YES SIR SO- THE WAY CARD
OBTAINED THAT NUMBER IS THAT
THE QUESTION FROM THE
LEGISLATURE IS A VERY PERTINENT
ONE WHICH WAS. WE HAVE THIS
GOAL. IT'S REALLY THE QUESTION
WE'VE BEEN ASKING. IN A SENSE
WHAT WILL IT TAKE RESOURCE WISE
TO GET US TO THAT GOAL. AND
WHAT WE WOULD HAVE EXPECTED
CARD TO HAVE IN RESPONSE WAS TO
NOTE. WELL IF WE KNOW IF WE
MAKE AN INVESTMENT ON THE FRONT
END HERE'S WHAT WE KNOW WE'LL
GET OUT IN TERMS OF VEHICLES ON
THE BACK END. BUT INSTEAD
BECAUSE CARL HASN'T. CONDUCTED
THE TYPES OF DATA ANALYSIS THAT
WE'VE BEEN DISCUSSING TODAY.
WHAT CAR DID WAS THE INVERSE OF
THAT. THEY JUST ASSUMED YOU
KNOW A SCENARIO IN WHICH FIVE.
MILLION VEHICLES WILL BE SOLD.
AND THEN YOU JUST HISTORICAL
DATA TO SAY WELL WE ON AVERAGE
PAY FOR ABOUT ONE OUT OF TWO IS
THAT IS THAT ARE SOLD IN THE
CALIFORNIA. IN CALIFORNIA TO
SEE THE R. P. THEREFORE WILL
JUST DO THE MATH. AND SO THAT
TO US IS A BUDGETING EXERCISE.
IT'S NOT AN EXERCISE IN TRYING
TO ACCOMPLISH. WHAT THE PROGRAM
IS SET TO DO WHICH IS YOU.
MONEY I FRONT TO GET A RETURN
ON THE SUFFICIENCY OF THAT
VEHICLE MARKET GOING FORWARD.
OKAY SO WHAT IN YOUR OPINION
WHAT DO YOU THINK IT'S GOING TO
TAKE. A TAXPAYERS MONEY IN
ORDER TO REACH YOUR GOAL. TO
REACH THE GOVERNOR'S GO. I'M
AFRAID I CANNOT SPEAK TO THAT
NOW IF CARP WERE TO HAVE
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW
EFFECTIVELY GIVEN REBATE IS AT
YOU KNOW BETTER INFORMATION
ABOUT ON AVERAGE WHAT IS A
REMAKE IT YOU IN TERMS OF NOT
JUST REAL GHG EMISSIONS. BUT
ALSO IN TERMS OF MARKET
RESPONSE IN TERMS OF HOW WE
INVEST NOW TO DRIVE. PRICES
DOWN BUT WE KNOW WHEN WE'VE
MADE SUFFICIENT- INVESTMENTS
THAT INCENTIVES MAY NOT KNOW
HOW TO BE NECESSARY IF I HAD
DONE THE RESEARCH TO KNOW OUR
INCENTIVE AMOUNTS THE MOST
AFFECTED THEY COULD BE. THEN WE
MIGHT BE ABLE TO RUN THOSE
NUMBERS FOR YOU SERVER RIGHT
NOW. TARGET OR NOT YOU KNOW
WHAT AND WHAT ALL THAT ANYBODY
COULD GIVEN ITS LACK OF DATA
WHICH IS TO SAY WELL WE'RE JUST
REVERSE THE QUESTION KIND OF ON
ITS ON ITS HERE AND RESPOND
BACK ABOUT YOU KNOW. GIVING
HISTORICAL. TRENDS WHAT THIS
WOULD LOOK LIKE IN BUDGET TURNS.
OKAY THANK YOU TEACHER I WANT
TO HAVE OUT OF THE QUESTION
BUT- YEAH. RIGHT NOW ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU SIMPLY MEMBER GIPSON
PERHAPS WE CAN CIRCLE BACK TO
THOSE QUESTIONINGS OF CARB WHEN
WE BRING UP THE NEXT PANEL.
WITH WITH THAT WE'RE GONNA MOVE
TO. LET ME ASK FEDERAL ACCOUNTS
HE'S ON THE LINE. IF NOT THEN
WE WILL MOVE TO SENATOR BACKER.
RIGHT. THANK YOU WHICH ONE TO
BUY IT CONFIRM HERE M. THE
HEADLINES WERE QUITE DRAMATIC
EXIT IS NOTHING HERE SHOWS THAT
CARBS PROGRAMS ARE COURT
CORRECT WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
AN E. D. D. S. SITUATION WITH
SIGNIFICANT WASTE IT SEEMS LIKE
THE MAIN FINDING IS THAT CORBYN
CLICKED AS MUCH DATA AS THEY
SHOULD- PROBABLY IN. BENEFITS
AND POSSIBLY COULD BE
OPTIMIZING THE USE THE FUNDS
BETTER IS THAT SEPARATE. YES
THAT'S CORRECT IN THE SENSE
THAT WE YOU KNOW WE DON'T
CURRENTLY HAVE SUFFICIENT DATA
TO MAKE INFORMED DETERMINATIONS
ABOUT THE RELATIVE BENEFITS OF
PROGRAMS OR HOW EFFECTIVE THEY
ARE COMPARED TO OTHER USES
JEFFERIES OF THE MONEY. FOR
THAT REASON YOU KNOW WE DON'T
WE DON'T HAVE ANYWHERE IN OUR
REPORT RECOMMENDATIONS ABOUT
PROGRAMS THAT SHOULD GO AWAY
PROGRAMS THAT SHOULD BE
EXPANDED WE CERTAINLY WOULD
LOOK TO MAKE THOSE TYPES OF
RECOMMENDATIONS WHERE THE DATA
ARE AVAILABLE SO- OUR
CONCLUSION HERE IS THAT WE
DON'T KNOW WE HAVE REASON TO
BELIEVE THAT THERE SOMEWHERE ON
THE SPECTRUM BETWEEN. YOU KNOW
100% EFFECTIVE AND NOT IT NOT
EFFECTIVE AT ALL BUT THE
EVIDENCE REALLY ISN'T ISN'T
THERE TO SHOW US WHERE ARE NOT
CONTINUE ON A GIVEN PROGRAM
WOODLAND WHICH OF COURSE
INHIBITS STATE'S ABILITY TO
PICK THE WINNERS AND ENSURE WE-
RECONSIDER THE LOSERS. THAT'S
RIGHT YES AND I'M OFFERED. IN
CHILE JIMMY QUESTIONS ASKED A
RELATIVE BANG FOR THE BUCK BUT-
I JUST WANTED THAT CAUGHT ON
THE RECORD THAT WE'RE NOT
SAYING CRISTINA BAD JOB. WHICH
IS LOOKING FOR- ACCESS TO MORE.
DATA AND TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE OPTIMIZING AS WELL AS
POSSIBLE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR WE'RE GONNA THANK YOU I
THINK THIS FACT CONCLUDES THE
WHO I HAVE ON THE LIST TO ASK
QUESTIONS OF THE STATE AUDITOR
LAWCENTER Y. CASKEY IS ON- IF
NOT I WILL THANK THE AUDITOR
AND HER TEAM- MR RYAN ALREADY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION- THE- OVERVIEW OF
THE OUT OF THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD. AND WITH THAT
ME ASK ONE MORE TIME IF CENTER
THE WHITE HOUSE GUISAN.
RESPONSE FOR THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD. WE HAVE
RICHARD CORY THE EXECUTIVE
OFFICER JENNIFER PRESS CHIEF
SUSTAINABLE TRANSPORTATION
COMMUNITIES DIVISION SAID THE
VERGE S. CHIEF MOBILE SOURCE
CONTROL DIVISION. AND LET'S GO
AHEAD AND- BEGIN WITH THE NEXT
PANEL PLEASE. MISTER COREY. YES
THANKS THANKS SHERRY AND I HAVE
BEEN HAVING SOME- CONNECTIVE
ANY ISSUE SO DR BURGESS WILL
BACK ME UP IF I DROP OFF DURING
MY REMARKS BUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH TO YOU. AND THE MEMBERS
AND THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK HERE I ALSO WANT TO
THANK THE STATE AUDITOR. IN HER
TEAM FOR THEIR WORK ON THE ON
IT OVER THE PAST YEAR. AND
ACKNOWLEDGE THE AUDITORS
FINDINGS AND OUR COMMITMENT OUR
COMMITMENT TO MAKE IMPROVEMENTS
WHICH I'LL BE DISCUSSING IN A
MOMENT. BUT FIRST I'D LIKE TO
START BY DISCUSSING CARDS TRACK
RECORD IN REDUCING EMISSIONS
AND IMPROVING AIR QUALITY. OVER
THE LAST COUPLE DECADES WE'VE
SEEN OZONE IN THE SOUTH COAST
INSTANTIATED GRAYSON
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE OF THE
REGION IS NOW MEETING FEDERAL
AIR QUALITY STANDARDS. FOR
OZONE THIS OCCURRED WHILE THE
NUMBER OF VEHICLES MILES
TRAVELLED DRIVEN. POPULATION
AND ECONOMY CONTINUE TO GROW
DRAMATICALLY. SIMILAR WE WERE
SAYING MUCH LESS PARTICULATE
MATTER IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY BY COLLABORATING WITH
THEIR DISTRICT ON A RECENT
STATE IMPLEMENTATION PLAN TO
EXCEL RATE REDUCTIONS FROM
AGRICULTURAL EQUIPMENT. TRUCKS
BUSES RESIDENTIAL WOOD BURNING
WE SEE LOWER PM TWO POINT FIVE
LEVELS ACROSS THE- WITH ALL
ALSO SEEN TREMENDOUS REDUCTIONS
ARE TOXIC EXPOSURE. FROM DIESEL
PARTICULATE MATTER HEAVY METALS
AND TOXIC VOCS OVER THE PAST
DECADES EXAMPLES SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY. CANCER RISKS ASSOCIATED
WITH DIESEL PM HAS DECREASED BY
OVER SEVENTY PERCENT. WELL
DIESEL VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED
INCREASED. 80% FINALLY THE
RESULT IN CALIFORNIA'S
GREENHOUSE GAS PROGRAMS IS
CLEAR WAS CALIFORNIA CHIEF IT'S
TWENTY TWENTY GHG TARGET. ONE
SPOKE ABOUT EARLIER. SHORT
WHILE AGO BY FOR YEARS OR YEARS
AHEAD OF SCHEDULE. OUR WE
RECOGNIZE MUCH MORE NEEDS TO BE
DONE TO MEET OUR CLIMATE IN AIR
QUALITY GOALS AS 90% OF
CALIFORNIANS AS THE CHAIR
MENTIONED. STILL BRING ABOUT
HEALTHCARE. WE AGREE THAT THIS
IS UNACCEPTABLE MORE
IMPLEMENTING MEASURES TO
SUPPORT THE TRANSITION TO ZERO
EMISSION MOBILE. AND OTHER
SOURCES. AN UNPRECEDENTED SCALE
AND SCOPE INSIDE OF THE
TREMENDOUS PROGRESS I WILL NOTE
THAT WE HAVE THE MOST
CHALLENGING AIR QUALITY
PROBLEMS IN THE COUNTRY. AND
SOME OF THE MOST AMBITIOUS GHG
REDUCTION TARGETS. AND HAS BEEN
THE CASE FOR DECADES FEDERAL
AND STATE LAW REQUIRES REQUIRES
MULTIPLE STRATEGIES TO WORK
TOGETHER. WE ARE REPORT NOTES
OVERESTIMATES GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSION REDUCTIONS THAT
INDIVIDUAL TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAMS AND SHE- WHEN THE
AUTOMATED NUMBER FINDINGS
FOCUSED ON THE INTERACTION
BETWEEN REGULATIONS AND
INCENTIVES TARGETING THE SAME
EMISSIONS OR QUESTIONS WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS TO BETTER
ISOLATE. THE BENEFITS OF EACH.
NO DOUBT MORE DATA AS WELL AS
FURTHER ANALYSIS OF DATA THAT
IS COLLECTED IT WILL BE
IMPORTANT IN DIESEL. BUT THERE
ARE SOME NEW ONES AROUND THIS-ISSUE SOME BACKGROUND MAY BE
HELPFUL. AS PART OF OUR CONTROL
STRATEGY AND HER LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTION WE ACQUIRED MULTIPLE
COMPLEMENTARY STRATEGIES SOME
REGULATORY AND OTHERS AND
SENATE BASED. DESIGN WORK
TOGETHER TO COLLECTIVELY REDUCE
EMISSIONS. AS AN EXAMPLE IS THE
STATE'S THEIR STRATEGY WAS
DISCUSSED STATE ZIP REGULATION
REQUIRES THAT MANUFACTURERS TO
PRODUCE THESE VEHICLES FOR SALE
THEY'RE ALSO INCENTIVES SUCH AS
CTRP THE FEDERAL TAX CREDIT.
CARPOOL LANE ACCESS TO
ENCOURAGE CALIFORNIANS TO BUY
AND DRIVE SETS IN PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS TO
ENSURE THE VEHICLES CAN BE CAN
AND CHARGED. REMOVE ANY ONE OF
THESE PIECES WOULD HAMPER EARLY
DEPLOYMENT IS S. AS NOTED YET
HAPPENS ADS IN THE UNITED
STATES ZAB MANUFACTURE BACK
SEVERAL MANUFACTURERS OF ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES ALL THE WAY
UP TO TRUCKS COMING CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURING COMING TO
CALIFORNIA. THE L. A. ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION WILL
SAY ON ON RECORD THAT'S BECAUSE.
THE STATE'S POLICIES HERE. I
WELL THIS COMP POLICY A
GENERATE AS NEED AS NEEDED
APPROACH FOR TRANCE THE- SECTOR
ZERO MOTIONS IT'S CHALLENGING
TO ACCURATELY ATTRIBUTE
BENEFITS. TO EACH INDIVIDUAL
COMPONENT THE STRATEGY AS WELL
AS DISCUSSED LAST NOW. TO HELP
EXPLAIN HOW DIFFICULT THIS IS
IMAGINE YOU'RE SERVING A
CONSUMER. WHO RECENTLY
PURCHASED THIS APP. DID THEY
PURCHASE IT BECAUSE THE CTRP.
BECAUSE THE VEHICLE WAS DUE TO
IS YET DOES THAT REGULATION.
BECAUSE OF ACCESS TO AN HOV
LANE STICKER. THE FEDERAL TAX
CREDIT RECENT INVESTMENTS IN
INFRASTRUCTURE IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD. ET PUBLIC
AWARENESS CAMPAIGNS OR PERHAPS%
ALL OF THE ABOVE CONSUMER
BEHAVIOR IS A TRICKY THING TO
NAIL DOWN SO IF YOU SURVEYS
SOMEONE AND ASK WHY DO YOU
PURCHASE THAT YEAH. IT'S LIKELY
A COMBINATION OF THINGS NOW NOT
RESPOND THE CLEAN CUT RESPONSE
20% OF MY DECISION LET'S SEE WE
ARE PAYING 10% FEDERAL TAX
CREDIT AND SO ON. THAT'S THE
CHALLENGE. HI THIS ISN'T HOW
CAN. GENERALLY OPERATE IN
FURTHER ACADEMIC LITERATURE IS
DEMONSTRATING THAT FREQUENTLY
CONSUMERS ARE GENERALLY UNABLE
TO QUANTIFY. CHOICES AT THIS
LEVEL. OF COURSE THIS DOESN'T
MEAN WE DON'T DO OUR BEST TO
FIGURE OUT THE RIGHT
METHODOLOGY AND APPROACH TO
MEASURING PROGRAMMATIC IMPACTS.
NOR DOES IT NEED WEEK NOTHING
MORE WE CAN AND WE WILL. BUT IN
THE CASE OF INCENTIVES AND
CONSUMER CHOICE JUST WANTED TO
EMPHASIZE THE CHALLENGES. THAT
ARE PRESENT. WE'RE COMMITTED TO
DOING OUR BEST TO IMPLEMENT THE
AUDITOR'S RECOMMENDATIONS. SOME
MAY TAKE SOME TIME ONCE
RESOURCE BUT BEFORE I MOVE ON I
WANTED TO LOOK AT OUR MISSION
INVENTORY DOESN'T COUNT FOR THE
COMPLEMENTARY POLICIES AND
VOICE OVER COUNTY OF EMISSIONS
BENEFITS TO ACCURATELY ESTIMATE
EMISSIONS IN CALIFORNIA'S
EMISSIONS OF CRITERIA
POLLUTANTS. EMISSIONS OF GHGS.
EMISSION INVENTORY. QUANTIFIES
THE AMOUNT OF FOSSIL FUEL USED
IN TRANSPORTATION SECTOR AND
THE RESULTING EMISSIONS FROM
DARKNESS. WHICH POLICIES LED TO
THE DISPLACEMENT OF FOSSIL FUEL
VEHICLES WITH JABS. SENATE
MAJORITY HAS A CRITICAL ROLE IN
BOTH TRACKING OUR PROGRESS
TOWARDS OUR EMISSION REDUCTION
GOALS AND IDENTIFY WHERE WE
NEED TO PURSUE ADDITIONAL
REDUCTIONS IN SHORT. EMISSION
REDUCTIONS WE'RE SEEING IN OUR
AIR QUALITY AND CLIMATE PROGRAM
FOR DECADES ARE REAL AND BORN
OUT BY FEDERAL RATHER FUEL
CONSUMPTION IN AIR QUALITY DATA.
HOW DO YOU ADDRESS THE GENERAL
ISSUES I'LL NOW TURN OF THE
ADDITIONAL AUDIT FINDINGS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS SPECIFIC ON THE
FINDING THAT THERE AREAS WHERE
ADDITIONAL DATA COLLECTION AND
ANALYSIS. WOULD HELP KERR MORE
STRATEGICALLY IMPLEMENTED IN
SEVERAL BANDS WE AGREE. HAVING
MORE DATA IS ALSO BENEFICIAL AS
A FURTHER ANALYSIS OF THE DATA
THAT IS COLLECTED WHEN
DESIGNING IMPLEMENTING AND
EVALUATING CALIFORNIANS THE
MOTION CONTROL STRATEGIES. AND
WE ALREADY STARTED ADDRESSING
THE AUDITOR'S RECOMMENDATIONS
AND I'M COMMITTED TO DO MORE IN
THE NEXT YEAR FOR FURTHER
DRESSED ON. IT'LL TAKE MORE
TIME TO THE WORST AND TIME TO
WORK THROUGH THE PUBLIC PROCESS
DETERMINE THE MOST EFFICIENT
AND EFFECTIVE MECHANISMS TO
COLLECT AND ANALYZE. ALL DATA
AND INFORMATION AND WE'RE
COMMITTED TO DO IT. A NUMBER OF
THE RECOMMENDATIONS WILL LIKELY
COME WITH AN ASSESSMENT
ADDITIONAL STAFFING AND
RESOURCE WILL BE NECESSARY TO
AVOID. RECKON RESOURCES AWAY
FROM. REGULATORY EFFORTS TO
FURTHER REDUCE OXIC AIR
POLLUTANTS FROM TRUCKS SHIPS.
REPUBLICAN SOURCES. IN REGARD
TO THE AUDITORS FINDING
REGARDING SOCIO ECONOMIC
BENEFITS FOR CALIFORNIANS ARE
CAR EQUITY PROGRAMS. THAT WHILE
WE AGREED THAT WE SHOULD
IMPROVE OUR DATA COLLECTION
PROCESS TO BETTER QUANTIFY
IMPORTANT BENEFITS THESE
PROGRAMS REMAIN CRITICAL FOR
EQUITY PURPOSES WHILE PURSUING
THEIR CLIMATE GOALS. CARDS
EQUITY PROGRAMS ARE DEVELOPED
AND MODIFIED THROUGH AN ANNUAL
PUBLIC PROCESS WHICH INVOLVES
INPUT FROM STAKEHOLDERS
PARTICULARLY EQUITY
STAKEHOLDERS AND REACH OUT TO
INCLUDE. IN THE METHOD. AS WELL
AS GUIDED BY LEGISLATORS. FOR
EXAMPLE THE CHARGE HEAD
INITIATIVE PASSED IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN BY FORMER. PRO TEM
SENATOR- DELEON AND CLEAN CARS
FOR ALL. A STATUE BY SYMBOL
MEMBER GROUP. FOR THE EQUITY
PRO MORE THAN ANY OTHERS VOICES
OF THOSE EQUITY GROUPS AND
COMMUNITIES THAT STANDARD
BENEFIT FROM THE PROGRAM MUST
BE CENTRAL TO PROGRAM DESIGN.
TODAY MANY OF THE SOCIO
ECONOMIC BENEFITS ASSEMBLY
QUALITATIVE AS NOTED. THESE
INCLUDE BENEFITS SUCH AS MORE
RELIABLE ACCESS TO CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION FOR LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUALS IMPROVE FINANCIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES TRACTOR
REPLACEMENTS IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. CLEANER TRUCKS ARE MOST
IMPACTED ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
MOVEMENTS. OUR CARBON
KNOWLEDGES THE AUDITORS
FINDINGS QUANTIFICATION SOCIO
ECONOMIC BENEFITS ACROSS EQUITY
PROGRAMS WOULD PROVIDE USEFUL
INFORMATION TO DETERMINE WHO
WHO MATIC SUCCESS. AS FOR
APPLYING. WE'LL WORK THROUGH A
PUBLIC PROCESS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE DO SO IN A WAY THAT IS
SUPPORTIVE OF THE GROUPS ZENSAR
ADDITIONALLY THE ARTIST HONORED
AUDITOR FOR FILTER CHARGE AND
LOOK AT THE PROGRAMS TO THE
LANDS WAS A RATHER LANSING GHGS.
I MUST ALSO NOTE THE TRANCE.
SECTOR IS OUR LARGEST SOURCE OF
GHGS. ROOMS THAT FORM- OZONE
AND TOXIC POLLUTANTS LAST. MOST
OF OUR MEASURES ARE DESIGNED
REDUCING EMISSIONS OF OZONE
FORMING AND TOXIC BLOOMS AS
WELL AS JUNE CHOOSE. FOCUSING
ON A TRIPLE PLAY. PLUS
UNDERSTATING THE BENEFITS WHEN
SIMPLY LOOK AT THREE GHG
PERSPECTIVE NO DOUBT MEETING
ARE HEALTHY. ALL THE INCLINE
TARGETS WILL REQUIRE US TO PUSH
HARDER ON THE SECTOR WE WILL.
WE AGREE THAT THE AUDITOR WITH
THE HONOR THAT REDUCING GHG
EMISSIONS FROM THE SECTOR IS
IMPORTANT. AND MORE WE NEED TO
BE DONE TO DRIVE DOWN EMISSIONS
TO MEET OF THE TWENTY THIRTY
AND BEYOND TARGETS. WILL ALSO
EXAMINE EVERY OPPORTUNITY TO
ACHIEVE THOSE GOALS INCLUDING
DRIVING DOWN EMISSIONS FROM THE
STATE'S LARGEST STATIONARY
SOURCES SUCH AS REQUIREMENTS.
AND NATURAL GAS EMITTERS IS
THEIR CHIEF SOURCE OF ROOMS AT
THE COMMUNITY LEVEL WHICH
CONTRIBUTE TO OZONE TOXIC
POLLUTANTS RECOMMENDED TO DO SO
AS WE UPDATE THE STATE'S
SCOPING PLAN THAT IS COMING UP.
IN THE NEXT FEW MONTHS IT WILL
BE LAUNCHED. OUR LOOKS FORWARD
TO WORKING THE ON AMPLE ROCK.
WILL LAY TO THE DATA
COLLECTION- WITH ME TODAY ARE
AT TWO DIVISION CHIEFS FROM
CARMEN WHO OVERSEE A NUMBER OF
THE PROGRAM'S DISCUSSED IN THE
AUDIT. CITY BURGESS WHO
OVERSEES MOBILE SOURCE CONTROL
DIVISION ENGINE FOR RESCUE
OVERSEAS ASSISTING ANIMAL
TRANSPORTATION AND COMMUNITY
WAS DIVISION AND WITHOUT SHARE
I CONCLUDE MY REMARKS. RIGHT
THANK YOU MISTER COREY AND I
KNOW WE HAVE A NUMBER OF-
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS AND
APPRECIATE YOUR OPENING
COMMENTS. AND I WE'RE GONNA GO
TO JUST MOVE INTO QUESTIONINGS
WILL START WITH MEMBERS HERE IN
THE IN THE ROOM AND I'M GONNA
DEFER. TO SENATOR BRADFORD WHO
IS CHAIRING ANOTHER COMMITTEE.
AND THAT NOW IS JOINT ASSISTANT
BRADFORD. THANK YOU CHAIR SALAS
AND I WANT TO THANK THIS
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR COURAGEOUS
LEADERSHIP- THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE FOR
APPROVING MY REQUEST LAST YEAR
TO AUDIT CAR. AS WE ALL KNOW
ALL NOMINAL THIS AUDIT WAS NOT
ONLY NECESSARILY NECESSARY BUT
LONG OVER DUE. WHEN I READ YOUR
REPORT I HAVE TO ADMIT I WASN'T
SHOCKED. BUT ONLY AMAZED THAT
IT WAS WORSE THAN WE COULD'VE
EVER ENVISION. BECAUSE OF THIS
COMMITTEES THAT MAKE
COMMUNITIES I SAY THAT I
REPRESENT I'M FAMILIAR WITH THE
FAILURE OF THE CAR PROGRAMS TO
TRANSLATE THE STATE POLICIES
INTO REAL RESULTS ON THE GROUND.
THIS AUDIT REVEALED SOMETHING
EVEN MORE PROBLEMATIC WHICH IS
A LACK OF ACCOUNTABILITY
RESPONSIVENESS AND RESPECT OF
THE LEGISLATURE. IT IS BAD
ENOUGH FOR THE POLICIES AND
PROGRAMS TO BE PRIORITIZED OVER
PEOPLE. THEY HEAR THE REPORT BY
MISTER CURRY AT AS THE REPORTS
AUDIT STATED IT'S INDEFENSIBLE
AND ALMOST INSULTING. ARE THERE
ARE MANY ISSUES THAT WE NEED TO
DISCUSS TODAY AND I WELCOME
THAT CONVERSATION BUT- I HAVE
TO GET TO ANOTHER COMMITTEE BUT
I JUST WANT TO RUN TO SOMETHING
REAL QUICK- I DON'T THINK
MISTER CURRY FOR BEING HERE
TODAY BUT I WOULD LIKE TO
START. WITH HOW CARP EVALUATED
SOCIAL. ECONOMIC ACHIEVEMENTS
OF ITS PROGRAMS CAR STATE IN
RESPONSE TO THIS AUDIT THAT YOU
SURVEYS FOCUS GROUPS. AND OTHER
DATA TO EVALUATE PROGRAM EQUITY
CAR BOSSES STATED. THAT STAFF
WILL EVALUATE WHETHER TO MODIFY
FUTURE GRANT SOLICITATION
THROUGH JUST MORE MATRIX. ARBOR
THIS AUDIT FOUND CAR DOES NOT.
CONSISTENT CONSISTENTLY COLLECT
DATA TO DETERMINE WHETHER IT'S
EQUITY PROGRAMS ACTUALLY
PROVIDE SOCIAL ECONOMIC
BENEFITS. AS INTENDED. ANOTHER
EXAMPLE CAR FINANCING
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM INTENDS TO
HELP LOW INCOME CONSUMERS
FINANCE CLEAN VEHICLES INCREASE
THEIR CREDIT SCORES YET IN FIVE
YEARS THIS PROGRAM BY CAR HAS
NOT COLLECTED NOT ONE SCINTILLA
OF DATA THAT ALLOW IT TO REPORT
ON THE BENEFITS THAT THEY CLAIM
THE A G. CARBS SLIDE
PARTICIPANT. LOAN REPAYMENT
RATES AS A MEASURE OF SUCCESS
YET THE AUDIT FOUND CARP DOES
NOT COLLECT DATA ON THOSE RATES
IT DOES NOT EVEN HAVE ACCESS TO
THE LOAN DATA. THIS IS A CLEAR
EXAMPLE OF CARP USING AND I'M
GOING TO CHANGE IT PIMPING LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES AS POSTER
CHILD FOR THEIR POLICIES
WITHOUT FOLLOWING THROUGH THE
DELIVER ON THE RESULTS THAT ARE
PROMISED TO THESE COMMUNITIES.
IN FACT CARBS GRIPES ME IN FACT
THE AUDIT DESCRIBES CARP
EVALUATION OF SOCIOECONOMIC
BENEFITS AND THIS PROGRAM AGAIN
AS DISINGENUOUS AT BEST. GIVEN
THAT WHY SHOULD THIS
LEGISLATURE TAKE CARP SERIOUSLY
WHEN YOU STATE YOU WILL BE
RESPONSIVE TO AUDIT FINDINGS.
FRANKLY I THINK YOUR TRACK
RECORD GIVES UP CALL FOR ALARM.
THAT WE ALL SHOULD BE CONCERNED
WITH. ARE YOU I MEAN EVEN STATE
RECORD LAW REQUIRES YOU TO ON
YOUR CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM
DESIGNED PROGRAM THAT PROVIDES
RESULT IN JOB CREATIONS AND
THAT THOSE JOBS TO BE TRACKED
THIS IS STATE LAW BUT THREE
YEARS LATER. IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN CARP UPDATED
GUIDELINES SPECIFIED JOB
CREATION AND TRAINING SHOULD
FOCUS ON DISADVANTAGED AND LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES HOWEVER
DESPITE ALL THIS TIME. AND
SUPPOSED TO LIVE WORK THAT WAS
DONE I THOUGHT IT BOB KARP HAS
FAILED TO DO SO IN A TIMELY AND
COMPREHENSIVE WAY. THIS AUDIT
REVIEWED NINE PROGRAMS WOULD
JOB REPORTING REQUIREMENTS. AND
ONLY THREE HAD ANY JOB DATA AT
ALL. TWO OTHERS HIT DATA
COLLECTED BUT NOT REPORTED THIS
REFLECTS A FUNDAMENTAL FAILURE
TO DELIVER ON THESE IMPORTANT
EQUITY GOALS THAT CARPET SELF
IDENTIFIES AS IMPORTANT. A LOT
OF ALL OF THIS AND ALL THE
AUDIT FINDINGS I THINK WE HAVE
TO SERIOUSLY RECONSIDER THAT
THE RESPONSIBILITIES AND
AUTHORITY. THE STATE HAS GIVEN
CAR UNTIL YOU CAN ACTUALLY MEET
THE STATUTORY AND PROGRAMMATIC
GOALS. THE FAILURES IN THIS
AUDIT TO GO BEYOND SIMPLY
MISSING DATA OR INEFFECTIVE. I
MEAN I SHOULD SAY THE FAILURES
IN THIS ARTICLE BEYOND SIMPLY
MISSED MISSING THAT ARE
INEFFECTIVE ANALYSIS. THIS
AUDIT REVEALS A FUNDAMENTAL
FAILURE OF ACCOUNTABLE. TO BE
ACCOUNTABLE NOT ONLY TO THE
PUBLIC BUT TO THIS LEGISLATIVE
BODY AND TO YOUR ALL GOALS AND
OBJECTIVES OUR CLIMATE GOALS
ARE AMBITIOUS AND DEMAND BETTER
USE OF ALL. IF WE'RE WANTED G.
VENOM THIS IS ESPECIALLY TRUE
FOR CARP GIVEN ITS POWER AND
ITS VALUE TO LIVE UP TO ITS
POWERS OVER THE LAST. TWO
DECADES. CURRENT THANK YOU
SENATOR BRADFORD- YOU'RE A
SPECIFIC QUESTION IN THERE BUT
DEFINITELY MAJOR POINTS- WITH
HOW YOU FEEL. MY QUESTION IS
WHAT HAVE YOU DONE WITH THE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS BECAUSE YOU
CAN'T SHOW ANYTHING FOR BUT
CONTINUE TO. WASTE CONSTITUENTS
MONEY- MISTER COREY PLEASE-
EVERY DOLLAR IN THE LEGISLATURE
HAS APPROPRIATED WHETHER IT BE
FOR ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES
MISSION TRUCKS LOWER MISSION
CLEANER TRACTORS IS ACCOUNTED
FOR DOCUMENTED PUBLICLY
SOLICITED SOMEONE US PUBLIC
SOLICITATION GOES OUT REPORTED
THOSE PROGRAMS THAT LED TO A
CORDON PURCHASES THAT ARE
OPERATING IN LOW INCOME AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
DIESEL TRUCKS TWO ZERO EMISSION
TRUCKS. LOWER MISSION TRACTORS
AND REDUCING PM TWO POINT FIVE
IN THE BALLOT IN THE VALLEY.
CLEANER EQUIPMENT THAT'S
OPERATING IN OUR MOST IMPACTED
COURTS RAIL YARDS AND
WAREHOUSES EVERY PIECE OF
EQUIPMENT EVERY RECIPIENT OF
THOSE DOLLARS INAPPROPRIATE BY
THE LEGISLATURE DOCUMENT COUNTY
BOARD. IN RECORDED ON. KERN
APPROPRIATE AND PER GUIDE THAT
IS SUBJECT TO PUBLIC REVIEW
METHOD METHODS THAT WE GO TO
DOCUMENT WE'RE GOING TO TRY. NO
A REPORT THE SOLICITATION WHICH
IS ULTIMATELY ACTED ON BY OUR
BOARD THE PUBLIC HEARING SO
WELL DOCUMENTED WELL REPORTED
THAT I'D BE HAPPY TO SIT DOWN
WITH ANY. LEGISLATOR OR YOUR
STAFF GO THROUGH ALL THE
SPECIFICS OVER EVERYONE OF
THOSE DOLLARS. THANK YOU MISTER
COREY UNDER THANK YOU I'M GONNA
GO BACK AND FORTH BODY CLEARLY
DOESN'T SUPPORT A SINGLE THING
THAT HE JUST SAID I HAD NONE OF
THIS HAS BEEN DOCUMENTED AS
CLEARLY STATED IN THE AUDIT.
WILL MOVE ON I ACTUALLY HAVE A
QUESTION IF WE MAY MISTER COREY
I KNOW IN TWENTY NINETEEN WILL
YOU KNOW YOU SAID YOU SAID THAT
WITH LEGISLATORS AND WE DID
THAT AND YOU'VE GIVEN ME
INFORMATION I KNOW THE
INFORMATION THE CAR PROVIDED TO
MY OFFICE OR THE DISTRIBUTION
OF THE- CLEAN VEHICLE REBATE
PROGRAM- BY LOOK WHERE
DISTRICTS. AND SO WITH THAT
DATA SHOWED IS- ERR DISTRICTS
LIKE THOSE IN THE BAY AREA
RECEIVED YOU KNOW MAJORITY OF
THE FUNDING WHEN I LOOKED AT
THE DATA WAS NEARLY TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY NINE MILLION DOLLARS
THAT WENT TO THE BAY AREA I
COMPARED THAT JUST TO SOME
AREAS AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY
AND KERN RECEIVED ONLY FOUR
HUNDRED AND ELEVEN THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY DOLLARS WHICH
IS ABOUT POINT ZERO SIX
PERCENT. OF THE FUNDS AND
IMPERIAL WRIST IMPERIAL VALLEY
IMPERIAL COUNTY ACTUALLY
RECEIVED EVEN LESS ONLY A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY ONE THOUSAND
EIGHT HUNDRED DOLLARS IN
REBATES SO THIS TELLS ME IS
THAT THOSE LIVING IN AREAS WITH
BETTER QUALITY RECEIVING MUCH
MORE FUNDING TO IMPROVE THEIR
QUALITY WHILE AREAS WITH HIGH
POLLUTION LEVELS OR SEEMINGLY
GIVEN LESS ATTENTION AND
FUNDING. SO YOU KNOW ASKS THE
AUTO EARLIER YOU KNOW WHY WAS
80% OF THE CV. R. P. FUNDS THAT
WERE DESIGNATED FOR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES SPENT
OUTSIDE OF THOSE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. YOU CAN HELP US
UNDERSTAND WHY THAT'S THE CASE.
I THINK- THE COMMITTEE WOULD
APPRECIATE IT. YEAH WE ARE THE
CTRP PROGRAM IS ONE
LEGISLATIVELY APPROPRIATED TO
INSANE EARNED VALUE CONSUMER
PROGRAM BASICALLY TO SUPPORT
LEASES OR SALE WHICH IS FIRST
COME FIRST SERVE PROGRAMS
AVAILABLE TO THE ENTIRE STATE-
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTION IN A
NUMBER OF LAWS AND PASSED THE
DEFINING ITS OPERATION I AND IT
THERE'S ALSO A LOW INCOME
ELEMENT C. A. R. P. WHICH WILL
BE LOOK OVERALL CD R. P. AND
SAY WELL HOW MUCH IS GOING TO.
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
LOW INCOME. YES ABANDONED LOW
INCOME TO GET SMALLER 5% BUT A
BLANK LAY OUT YOUR QUESTION I
THINK IT'S AN IMPORTANT
QUESTION ABOUT LOOKING AT. CTRP
AND RELATED PROGRAMS FARMER.
WHICH IS CLEANER TRACTORS
GENERAL 80% OF THAT ACTUALLY
GOES INTO THE VALLEY. I TO
REDUCE DIESEL PM AND OTHER
TOXIC POLLUTANTS HEAVY DUTY
PROGRAMS FOR HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS
ARE OVER 70% OF THOSE END UP
OPERATING IN DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES SO DOES VARY BY
PROGRAM WILL DO VARIES BY. THE
WAY THIS BILL BASIC DESIGN. BUT
IF YOU LOOK AT TRUCKS YOU LOOK
AT TRACTORS. ARE DOMINATING LOW
INCOME AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES IN SEEKING ARCADY
ARE BOTH LOCAL TAX AND LOW.
INCOME IS ABOUT 25% THANK RISK
WOULD YOU JUST WITH THAT I THAT
A- OLDER VEHICLE WE TAKE OFF
THE ROAD WOULD HELP IMPROVE AND
MAKE CALIFORNIA REACH ITS
CLIMATE GOALS FASTER. I WOULD
IN FACT I WOULD ADD TO THAT AND
SAY THE CLEAN CARS FOR ALL
PROGRAM. WHICH BASICALLY IS
DIRECTED AT LOWER INCOME FOLKS.
THEY BRING OUT LOW THEY BRING
AN OLDER DIRTIER VEHICLE
RECEIVED A IN THIS IS ALSO
STATE APPROPRIATED LEGISLATIVE
APPROPRIATED. FUNDING TO GET A
MUCH CLEANER VEHICLE THE
VEHICLES ARE REPLACING OR OVER
TWENTY YEARS OLD. ON AVERAGE
YOU'RE GETTING A VEHICLE THAT'S
THAT'S ABOUT FOUR YEARS OR
NEWER AND FAR FAR CLEANER FACT
THAT THE HIGHEST SELLING
VEHICLES. WILL ABORT CLEAN CARS
FOR ALL DIRECTED LOWER INCOME
FOLKS. ARE RIGHT PLUGINS ARE
HYBRID HYBRID VEHICLES AND EVEN
ELECTRIC VEHICLES. SO YOUR
POINT IS WELL TAKEN IT TAKES
THE OLDER ARE YOUR PEOPLE OFF
THE ROAD. IN AND GETS LOWER
INCOME PEOPLE IN A NEWER.
BETTER PERFORMING VEHICLE THAT
STAYS IN FUTURE. AND SO I WOULD
IMAGINE THAT MISTER COREY THAT
WOULD BE THAT CVR P. PRO HELPS
CAL. REACHES CLIMATE GOALS-
THAT'S CORRECT ASSUMPTION I'M
SO. BASED OFF YOUR ANSWER. THAT
IS OKAY SOMETHING. I JUST WANT
TO ASK BECAUSE I WAS TO WITH
OUR BUDGET COMMITTEE AND- THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND I'M JUST WONDERING
IF CARP IS GOING TO BE PUSHING
FOR AN ALLOCATION OF FUNDS FOR
THE C. V. R. P. PROGRAM BECAUSE
IN THE GOVERNOR'S INITIAL
BUDGET IT'S ELIMINATED. AND SO
FROM CARBS PERSPECTIVE TRYING
TO MEET MEET OUR CLIMATE GOALS
WILL YOU BE PUSHING TO
REINSTATE THAT MONEY INTO THE
BUDGET ON BEHALF OF THE
ADMINISTRATION. THAT WOULD THE
COURSES YOU KNOW THE
ADMINISTRATION IN CONSULTATION
WITH THE LEGISLATURE THAT'S
SUBJECT TO A SPECIFIC
APPROPRIATION- IN A PLAYED OUT
IN THE BUDGET PROCESS BUT WHAT
I WOULD SAY IS. WE KNOW WE NEED
MORE ELECTRIC VEHICLES IN
LONDON LET ME BE REALLY CLEAR
ON THIS BECAUSE I THINK THE
NEXT GUY THE MESSAGE WAS MUTED.
DURING THE CONVERSATION. NOT
ONLY DO WE NEED ELECTRIC
VEHICLES TO TRANSITION TO
REDUCED YIELDS CLINICIANS. WE
CAN'T GET TO OUR HEALTH BASED
AIR QUALITY STANDARDS STANDARD
YOU TALK ABOUT IN THE VALLEY
AND SOUTH COAST. WITHOUT
TRANSFORMING THE
TRANSPORTATION. YOU DO THE
ANALYSIS IT CAN'T HAPPEN. I AM
IN NO DOUBT I TALKED ABOUT THE
FACT WE ARE HAPPY TO COUNTRIES
EV'S. AND WE HAVE THE MAJOR.
THE MAJOR EVEY MANUFACTURE IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE. ZERO
EMISSIONS FORKLIFTS AND YOUR
MISSION BUSES AND TRANSIT BUS
MANUFACTURERS COMING TO
CALIFORNIA. BUT THE POINT THAT
THE AUTHOR MAY GOD BE. WITH
THIS AGREEMENT WE NEED MORE WE
NEED TO KNOW FASTER. APPRECIATE
THAT AND- YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY
IT'S LUKE'S THE LEVEL OF
FRUSTRATION FOR SOME OF THE
MEMBERS THAT REPRESENT. SOME OF
THE HIGHER POLLUTION AIR
DISTRICTS AND ONE WE'RE LOOKING
AT THE FUNDS. ESPECIALLY WHEN
YOU LOOK AT TWO HUNDRED AND
NEARLY TWO HUNDRED TWENTY NINE
MILLION GOING TO THE BAY AREA.
AND POINT 006% GOING TO PLACES
LIKE KERN COUNTY WITH. FOUR
HUNDRED AND- ELEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS IT. IT DOESN'T SEEM.
THERE BE IS PRIOR. THOSE NANA
AREAS TO RECEIVE SOME OF THIS
FUNDING TO HELP OFFSET AND HELP
CALIFORNIA MEET ITS GOALS-
BECAUSE I MEAN IF CALIFORNIA
WERE TO ADOPT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET THE WAY IT IS WITHOUT-THE C. V. R. P. PROGRAM THE
FORTY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLAR
REBATE WHAT HAPPENS TO ALL
THOSE LOW INCOME CUSTOMERS- IF
THEY CABS- PARTAKE IN THE
SEVERE P. PROGRAM. HI THIS IS
JENNIFER GRASSO THE CALIFORNIA
AIR RESOURCES BOARD IT LOOKS
LIKE RICHARD ADAMS INTERNET
CONNECTIVITY. HAS AT WORKING
OUT MANY I AM. DR BURGESS DID
YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT SENIOR
PAYING- JUST THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY AND THINGS LIKE
TEND TO BE HERE- AND FOR
LETTING ME PINCH HIT FOR A FOR
A MISTER COREY. SO I'LL JUST
WRITE THAT YOU SEE THE R. P.
EXISTS ALONGSIDE A NUMBER OF
OTHER EQUITY PROGRAMS INCLUDING
CLEAN CARS FROM WHICH WE'VE
DISCUSSED TODAY. THAT'S
RESULTED IN ELEVEN THOUSAND CAR
SCRAPPED REPLACED ON THE ROAD
AND THAT FUNDING GOES TO LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS- AND PRIORITY
COMMUNITIES THE FINANCING
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM WHICH IS
ALSO BEEN DISCUSSED AS
BENEFITTED TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED. LOW INCOME CONSUMERS
AND I DO WANNA TAKE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CRACK SOMETHING
I HEARD EARLIER WHICH HAS TO DO
WITH THE INTEREST RATES
INTEREST RATES IN THIS PROGRAM
ARE CAPPED AT 8212% AND THE
AVERAGE CONSUMER RECEIVES. A
RATE OF. ABOUT FIVE POINT 6%
THANK YOU- I DON'T THINK THAT A-
WHAT HAPPENS TO LOWER CUSTOMERS
THEY DON'T RECEIVE THE SENIOR
P. REBATE. UNIMAGINED THEN
THEY'D BE PRICED OUT AND THEN
AGAIN. I KNOW MISTER COREY
SAID. YOU KNOW IT'S ON A FIRST
COME FIRST SERVE BASIS BUT THAT
DOESN'T SEEM TO BE IN ALIGNMENT
WITH. TRYING TO GET THE MOST
AMOUNT OF REDUCTIONS ARE BANG
FOR BUCK- THAT THE AUDITOR
TALKED ABOUT IN SOME OF THESE
HIGH ATTAINMENT AREAS I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU HAVE A COMMENT ON
THAT. WHY WOULD ANYONE LIKE TO
ADDRESS THAT. YEAH CHAIRMAN
THIS IS A MISTER COREY RICHARD
I JUST READ JOIN YOU MIGHT
SIGNAL WAS INTERRUPTED SO IF
ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES ARE YOUR
QUESTION THAT THEY CAN RESPOND.
TO MY UNDERSTANDING OF THE
QUESTION IS THAT IT'S RELATED
TO OPPORTUNITIES FOR LOW INCOME
PARTICIPANTS TO PARTICIPATE AND
RECEIVE A CLEANER VEHICLE IT'S
NOT THROUGH THE CVR P. PROGRAM.
ONE ADDITIONAL PIECE OF
INFORMATION THAT I THINK MIGHT
BE HELPFUL AND IS RELEVANT HERE
WHICH IS THAT CLEAN FUEL
REWARDS PROGRAM. WHICH IS AN
OPPORTUNITY THAT COMES FROM OR
ELSE IF THIS PROGRAMS UTILITIES
ACROSS THE STATE HAVE COME
TOGETHER TO OFFER FIFTEEN
HUNDRED DOLLARS ON THE HOOD-
FOR IT CONSUMERS LOOKING TO
PURCHASE A NEW VEHICLE SOTHAT
THAT IS ALSO ANOTHER AVENUE FOR
FOLKS WHO ARE LOOKING TO
PURCHASE A CLEAN. NEW VEHICLE
IN ADDITION TO FINANCING
ASSISTANCE. IN THE CLEAN CARS
FOR ALL PROGRAM. I'M WHAT THOSE
ADDITIONAL PER. BECAUSE YOU
KNOW DAUGHTER AND MENTIONED
OVERLAP. ARE WE STILL HEARING.
THESE PROGRAMS TOWARDS THESE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES ARE
LEASES COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
DEFINITELY A- HIGH ATTAINMENT.
POLLUTED AREAS OF THE STATE. WE
ARE IN LET ME- SPEAK
SPECIFICALLY CHAIR OF THAT
QUESTIONS ARE THINKING ABOUT A
FEW QUESTIONS ONE. INKHEART IS
FOR ALL PROGRAM DIRECTOR DR
BURGESS JUST JUNE. DIRECTED AT
GETTING LOWER INCOME FOLKS WE
HAVE OLDER DURING YOUR VEHICLES
IF THEY REPLACE WE GET INTO
FOUR IN TERMS OF TAKING AN
OLDER VERY VEHICLE OFF THE ROAD
GETTING AND THEN I CALLED
NICOLE THERE IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES THE POINT THAT WE
MADE ABOUT FARMER 80% OF FARMER
MISDIRECTED THE VALUE TO GET
INTO CLEANER TRACTORS AND OTHER
EQUIPMENT. ALSO THE VALUES YOU
WELL NO SUBSTANTIAL LOWER
INCOME COMMUNITIES COMMUNITY A
COLOR HEAVY DUTY FOCUS ON
CLEANER TRUCKS WAS CLEAN
PRODUCTS PREDOMINANTLY OPERATE
IN DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES I
THINK IT'S OVER 70% SO THOSE
REDUCTIONS OF DIESEL PM WHICH
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT THOSE
COMMUNITIES. NETWORK WAREHOUSES
RAIL YARDS IMPORTS RECEIVE A
DISPROPORTIONATE BENEFIT FROM
THOSE RCURSOS. PROGRAM THROUGH
ACTIONS. HELLO RIGHT THANK YOU
MISTER CREATE DO HAVE THIS LOOK
ABOUT THEIR REAL TO ABOUT
MEMBERS OF BROUGHT UP- AND LET
ME JUST A FOR TO THOSE MEMBERS
SASS REMASTER QUESTIONS-
SENATOR DOLLY I KNOW YOU HAD A
QUESTION EARLIER. THAT I
BELIEVE WAS MORE DIRECTED
TOWARDS- THIS PANEL. I KNOW
FIRST FIRST ARE LIKE TO MAKE A
COMMENT I I'M- SOMEBODY WHO'S
I'M A FARMER BY THE WAY IN. THE
END WE HAVE THE CARL MOYER
PROGRAM WHICH WAS BEEN AROUND
FOR YEARS VERY SUCCESSFUL I
AGREE WITH YOU. THAT BUT I JUST
WANNA MAKE A COMMENT FIRST THE
VALLEY WERE. MISTER SALAS
REPRESENTS HIS IS IN A BASIN
WHERE IF YOU TOOK EVERY SINGLE
PERSON OUT OF OUT OF THE COUNTY
KERN COUNTY YOU WOULD STILL
HAVE POLLUTION THERE BECAUSE IS
TRANSPORTED. SO I JUST WANT TO
MAKE THAT CLEAR AND THAT THAT'S
TRANSPORT FROM THE WESTERLY
WINDS THAT COME FROM THE COAST
AND WE JUST SAW. IN THE
COMMENTS OF THE CHAIR MADE
ABOUT HOW MUCH MONEY SPENT.
MAKING SURE THAT YOU KNOW BAY
AREA FOLKS DRIVE A TESLA AND
GET ENOUGH THAT IN THE IN THE
CARPOOL LANE AT THE EXPERIENCE
OF TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE
GET. REALLY DISADVANTAGED
PEOPLE IN DESERVES AND YOU'RE
RIGHT THERE TO FOR IF YOU GET
HIM OUT OF THE BAD CAR AND YOU
GET HIM INTO A CAR THAT IS MORE
AFFORDABLE IS GREAT BUT THERE'S
CHARGING SYSTEMS THAT NEED TO
BE AVAILABLE THERE'S THOSE
THINGS BUT- BUT I WANT TO GET
TO MY MAIN POINT MY MAIN POINT
IS. I ASKED EARLIER WAS. AS
AUDITORS REPORT NOTED ALSO. THE
STATE'S ZAB GOALS HAVE BEEN
ESTABLISHED BY EXECUTIVE ORDER.
THE ORDER THE FIRST ORDER WAS
WITH GOVERNOR BROWN ONE AND A
HALF MILLION. ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
AND FIVE MILLION BY TWENTY
THIRTY. GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER DIRECTS THE ARB
TO ACHIEVE A 100% ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES BY TWENTY THIRTY FIVE
CYNDER LAIR CORRECTED ME AB
THIRTY TWO WAS PASSED IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SIX. FOURTEEN
YEARS FORTY SIX FIFTEEN YEARS
WHICH FOURTEEN YEARS TILL
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE FIRST OF ALL
THE FIRST QUESTION IS WHAT
STATUTORY AUTHORITY WE'LL BE
RELYING ON TO ADOPT REGULATIONS
TO BAN THE SALES OF INTERNAL
BUS DIDN'T IT COMBUSTION
ENGINES BY TWENTY THIRTY FIVE
AS THERE AS A DIRECT. AS
DIRECTED IN GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER THAT'S THE
FIRST QUESTION. YEAH LET ME- GO
READ OUT THAT THE- WHAT WHAT WE
WILL BE DOING IN IN HELPING
UNDERSTAND REGULATION. SO THE
DEREGULATION IS A MANUFACTURER
A REQUIREMENT FOR PRODUCTION
IT'S NOT A BAN OF THE USE AND
OPERATION OF INDIAN USE. IC
ENGINE BUT TO YOUR QUESTION
AUTHORITY AB THIRTY TWO. STATE
LAW FEDERAL CLEAN AIR ACT WE
CAN'T GET TO THE HEALTH BASED
AIR QUALITY STANDARDS THAT YOU
TOUCHED ON IN THE VALLEY
WITHOUT TRANSITION CLEANER
TRANSPORTATION SO THOSE LAWS
THAT FOCUS ON OZONE. AND TWO
POINT FIVE TOXICS AND GHGS ALL
HAVE A BEARING ON SUPPORTING A
TRANSITION TO A CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION MOST OF THE WORK
THAT WE'RE DOING BOTH THROUGH
REGULATIONS AND INCENTIVES
BECAUSE YOU ALL HAVE NOTED. WE
NEED FAR MORE- I LIKELY
INJUNCTION CARS WE HAVE TODAY.
OKAY NOW MIGHT RIGHT I WANT TO
MAKE ANOTHER COMMENT WHAT YOU
WHAT YOU HEARD EARLIER YOU WERE
ON I GUESS. YOUR EARLIER SO I
REPRESENT THE FIRST SENATE
DISTRICT WHICH IS TAHOE THE
OREGON BORDER ALL THE WAY DOWN
TO SACRAMENTO WHICH IS MOSTLY
FORESTED IN OUR WATERSHEDS.
WHICH HAS BEEN SPEWING OUT
CARBON WE HAD FOUR POINT TWO
MILLION ACRES LAST YEAR BURNED
IN CALIFORNIA AND MANY MILLIONS
THE YEARS PASSED SINCE TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE WE HAD BIGGEST
FIRES IN THE STATE'S HISTORY.
AND MORE DEVASTATION IN HOMES
AND IT IMPACTED AND DEATHS.
WHICH WE DON'T EVEN COUNT IN
OUR CARBON OUTPUT. IT TO MEET
THESE GOALS SO I KNOW THAT'S
NOT YOUR DEPARTMENT I'M RUNNING
A BILL THAT WILL REQUIRE YOU TO
COUNT THAT HOPEFULLY WILL GET
PASSED AND SIGNED INTO LAW. THE
LAST QUESTION I HAVE WHICH IS
SOMETHING I HOPE YOU CAN ANSWER
AFTER READING THIS AUDIT REPORT
AND THERE'S MANY MORE THINGS I
COULD TALK ABOUT THERE'S JUST
VERY FRUSTRATING I THINK.
SENATOR BRADFORD. DID A VERY
GOOD JOB OF ARTICULATING THE
FRUSTRATION THAT I THAT THAT IS
HAPPENING HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE. BUT TO MEET THOSE
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE GOALS. HOW
ARE YOU GOING TO DO IT WE GOT
TO HAVE SOMETHING BETTER THAN
WHAT THIS AUDIT REPORT SAYS.
AND WE'RE NOT GONNA BE HAVE THE
ABILITY TO BUY. ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE. THIS IS ANY FACTORS
WON'T HAVE A NEW ONE I SHOULD
SAY. AND WE'RE GONNA RELY ON.
PRETTY SOON. THE COMBUSTIBLE.
WILL OUT SOME POINT. AND WILL
BE FORCED TO BUY ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE IN CALIFORNIA HOW ARE
YOU GOING TO MEET THAT GOAL.
RIGHT SO FIRST ELEMENTARY YOUR
QUESTION RECOGNIZING THE
MAGNITUDE OF THE CHALLENGE IT'S
SIGNIFICANT THERE'S JUST NO
DOUBT ABOUT THAT YOU'RE NOT
GONNA GET A SUGAR COAT IT'S-
EASY. BUT YOU WILL GET THE FACT
THAT. THE CURRENT PURCHASES
TODAY ABOUT OF NEW VEHICLES
THAT ARE ZERO ABOUT 8% IN THE
TWO AND THE NUMBER OF MODELS IN
VEHICLES AND AFFORDABILITY AND
RANGE AND THE FACT THAT WE'RE
PRODUCING VEHICLES IN THE STATE
AND- PUTTING IN CHARGING
STATIONS THE RAMP UP THE
INCREASES ON PRESIDENT. BOTH
THE PRODUCTION MANUFACTURING
THAT WE'RE SEEING IN THE STATE
AND THE NUMBER OF VEHICLES SO
REGULATION. IN CENTER
PARTNERING WITH OTHER STATES
PARTNERING WITH THE
MANUFACTURERS I SUPPORT FOR
CONTINUED INFRASTRUCTURE
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS IN
CALIFORNIA BOTH STATE AND
FEDERAL DOLLARS CONSUMER WORK
CONSUMER EDUCATION EVERYONE OF
THOSE ELEMENTS ARE GOING TO BE
NECESSARY FOR THIS TRANSITION
MOMENTS FUNDAMENTAL NOT JUST TO
GHGS NIGHT REALLY WANT TO
UNDERSCORE THIS POINT BECAUSE I
THINK THAT TENDS TO BE THE
FOCUS OF THESE CONVERSATIONS
WHEN. THE FOCUS ON A BE ON
REDUCING KNOX EMISSIONS TOXIC
EMISSIONS WITH POLLUTANTS
BASICALLY CONTRIBUTE TO OZONE
AND PM TWO POINT FIVE THAT
SIGNIFICANTLY ADVERSE PUBLIC
HEALTH. NOT UNDER THE SICK OF
THE STATE THE CHALLENGE BUT
THERE'S REAL RESULTS IN
PROGRESS IN CALIFORNIA IS
UNPRECEDENTED HOW IT'S MOVED
FORWARD. THANK YOU SENATOR
DOLLY- THIS CAR IF I COULD JUST
ASK A CLARIFYING QUESTION TO
MISTER DALI- COMING BECAUSE I
THINK HE'S MISTER DALI AT MIGHT
BE REFERRING TO WHAT I'M
THINKING OF IS- PAGE THIRTY TWO
THIRTY THREE OF THE AUDITOR'S
REPORT. WHERE IT WAS REPORTED
IN OUR BUDGET COMMITTEES THAT
YOU WOULD NEED TO PAY OUT TWO
POINT ONE MILLION- REBATES
WHICH IS ROUGHLY ABOUT FIVE
POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS. TO
GET FIVE MILLION ORE IS THAT
THIS. YOU KNOW ON THE ROAD JUST
TO MEET THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER. SO I WAS JUST
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
CARP COME UP WITH THE FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS PUBLIC FUNDING
TO ACHIEVE THAT IF THEY DIDN'T
HAVE THE DATA THAT THE AUDITORS
REPORT IS SAYING THAT. YOU'RE
LACKING. NOT VALID THANK THEY
YOU JERRY THIS WAS. STRAIGHT UP.
IT WAS A QUESTION. THAT WE
RESPONDED TO. WITH A FAIRLY
SIGNATURE SIMPLISTIC. RESPONSE
BASICALLY IT WAS. ASSUMING A
CERTAIN PERCENTAGE OF
INDIVIDUALS AND THAT HARD TO
SAY JAB SEEK STEVIE RP. AND IT
WAS BASICALLY DURING.
THE-
DURING STRAIGHTFORWARD. IN
UNDER- MARC AND HIS CHARACTER
WAS FAIR DIGITAL WAY HE SAID
THAT WE ARE RESPONDED TO THAT
QUESTION SO THAT'S TO PUT THEIR
LIVES ON THROUGH THE C. V. R.
P. PROGRAM THAT'S CURRENTLY NOT
FUNDED. SACRAMENTO YOU MAY
THERE'S NOT AN APPROPRIATION IN
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET I THINK IS
WHAT YOU KNOW THERE'S FUNDING
FOR CTRP STILL BEING PAID OUT
BUT IT'S CURRENTLY NOT THE
BUDGET THAT'S A CORRECT
STATEMENT AND I KNOW THAT YOU
ALL ARE TALKING MINISTRATION
AND FORMER FINANCE CORRECT YEAH
AND YOU KNOW I'M JUST SAYING IF
IT'S A PROGRAM THAT WORKS THEN
WE SHOULD PROBABLY THE GOVERNOR
PROBABLY SHOULD ADDED IN HIS
INITIAL BUDGET BUT OBVIOUSLY WE
WANT TO TARGET THOSE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES WITH
THE HIGHEST AMOUNT OF
POLLUTION. SO I APPRECIATE THAT
MR KOREAN AND I DIDN'T HEAR
EXACTLY THE ANSWER TO SENATOR
DOLLIES- FIRST QUESTION THOUGH
WHICH WAS THE- THE STATUTORY
AUTHORITY TO GO AHEAD AND ADOPT
THE REGULATIONS FOR THE BANNING
OF THE INTERNAL COMBUSTION
ENGINE CAN YOU TELL ME WHERE
WERE THAT AUTHORITY LIES ARE
WHICH YOU ARE RELYING. YEAH
THANK YOU TO ACTUALLY THOUGHT I
DID RESPOND. FIRST THING I SAID
WE DON'T BAN. ENGINES WHAT WE
DO IS E TALK REGULATIONS.
REQUIRING THAT MANUFACTURERS
PRODUCE A PROGRESSIVELY.
LEASING PERCENTAGE OF ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES ARE VERY
DIFFERENT THINGS. BUT IF YOUR
QUESTION THEN IS WILL ON WHAT
AUTHORITY. I STATE AUTHORITY
TOXICS. CRITERIA POLLUTANTS THE
AUTHORITY AB THIRTY CHANNEL
FEDERAL CLEAN AIR ACT
AUTHORITIES CHEAP ARE IMMUNE
AIR QUALITY STANDARDS SO. I'M
NOT AUTHORITY BOARD BOX HE'S
DIESEL PM OR- AND ACTIVATE
SHE'S ESTABLISHED AT BOTH THE
STATE AND FEDERAL LEVEL SO
MULTIPLE CITATIONS THERE. THANK
YOU FOR THAT CLARIFICATION IT
DOES GET A LITTLE CONFUSING
WHEN WE SEE PRESS RELEASES
ISSUED BY. THE VERY SAID
MINISTRATION AGENCIES AND FROM-
THE DIFFERENT GROUPS THAT USE
DIFFERENT LANGUAGE- WITH THAT
WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND
MOVE TO SENATOR GONZALEZ TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG AND I KNOW
SOMEONE MEMBER GIPSON- STILL
HAS THIS QUESTION FROM THE
PREVIOUS PANEL. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
MISTER COREY- EIGHT I THINK
YOU'D MENTIONED IN THE VERY
BEGINNING THAT YOU ARE TAKING
ACTION ON SOME OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND FINDINGS
FROM THE AUDIT SO CAN YOU
ELABORATE ON WHAT THOSE.
ACTIONS ARE SO FAR I MEAN I
KNOW THAT THERE'S A LOT IN HERE
BUT- PLEASE CHECK SOME LIGHT ON
THAT. YES THANK YOU WE TRY TO
BREAK IT DOWN IN TERMS OF WANT
WHERE THEIR OPPORTUNITIES IN
THE SHORT RUN TO GET. BETTER
QUALITY AND MORE COMPLETE DATA.
I IN WHAT IS THE MECHANISM FOR
DEALING. ONE IS THE
SOLICITATIONS THAT WE GO
THROUGH FOR A GRANT FROM
INSTANCE. SO INCLUDING X. X.
STRENGTHENING THAT EXPLICIT
LANGUAGE. TO THE GRANT
AGREEMENTS THAT WE HAVE WITH.
ADMINISTRATORS OR ART
RECIPIENTS. IN THREE THE DATA
WE HAVE IN TERMS OF THE
UNDERLYING ANALYSIS OF THOSE IN
THE IMMEDIATE NEAR TERM THINGS
THAT. JUMPED OUT AT US WHERE WE
CAN. STRENGTHEN OUR THE ONE
COLLECTION OF DATA INTO THAT
THE- ANALYSIS OF DATA THAT WE
ACTUALLY HAVE. THERE CERTAINLY
IS MORE AND WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
UPDATES IT WILL BE REQUIRED TO
PROVIDE THE AUDITOR. BUT THOSE
ARE THE THOSE ARE THE- A FEW
EXAMPLES. OF JUMPED OUT TO ME
IMMEDIATELY. OKAY THANK YOU AND
CAN YOU I'M A LITTLE BIT TO THE
JOB TRAINING COMPONENT BECAUSE
WE- HADN'T HEARD ABOUT IN THE
PREVIOUS PANEL AND- IN TERMS OF
YOU KNOW THEY SOAK SOCIO
ECONOMIC PROGRAMS AND BENEFITS.
YOU KNOW WE HAVEN'T REALLY
HEARD MUCH OF WHAT IS HAPPENING
ON THE JOB TRAINING FRONT. THIS
IS WHAT WE'RE GOING TO ASK MY
COLLEAGUE DR VIRGINS TO SPEAK
TO. THANK THANK YOU SO MUCH A
QUESTION- SO WHEN IT COMES TO
THE JOBS QUESTIONS SPECIFICALLY
I THINK IT WAS MENTIONED THAT
THE LEGISLATION START
COLLECTING THAT DATA FOR ALL
CARPENTRY FUNDED PROGRAMS
INCLUDING ONES THAT CARP. THAT
PASSED FIFTEEN IN TWENTY
NINETEEN THERE WAS A TOOL WAS
MADE AVAILABLE FOR ALL OF US WE
STARTED USING THAT SO WE'VE
STARTED USING THE TOOL WE LOOK
FORWARD TO REPORTING MARC MORE
JOB STATE AT OUR UPCOMING
FUNDING PLAN. AND WE'RE
CURRENTLY WORKING INTERNALLY TO
YOUR BEEF UP OUR SURVEYS WITH
RESPECT TO HOW EXACTLY WE QUERY
THESE DIFFERENT PROGRAMS TO
OBTAIN THAT INFORMATION- I
WOULD LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT MAYBE
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT WE DO
CURRENTLY BUT I WOULD LIKE TO
HELP OF COURSE UNDER SCORE THAT
WILL BE MOVING FORWARD- AND
DOING A MORE ROBUST JOB OF
ENSURING THAT OUR GRANTEES
COLLECT THAT DATA. SO
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTION YOU KNOW
LIKE ALL AGENCIES YOU KNOW WE
BELIEVE THAT WE'VE YOU KNOW
APPLIED THE METHODOLOGY FOR HOW
TO COLLECT THIS DATA
APPROPRIATELY BUT WILL BE ABLE.
TO BEEF IT UP AND WILL BE
LOOKING TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
INCLUDED ALL OUR GRANT
AGREEMENT SO WE CLICK JOBS DATA.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK CENTER GONZALEZ WILL MOVE
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG AND
THEN TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- I
WANTED TO FOLLOW UP ON THE
QUESTION TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM
KERN COUNTY- IN TERMS OF THE
CLEAN VEHICLE ASSISTANCE REBATE
PROGRAM- WHICH PROVIDES- HAS
YOU KNOW GRANTS AND AFFORDABLE
FINANCING- SO TO HELP INCOME
QUALIFY CALIFORNIANS. PURCHASE
NEW OR USED HYBRID AND DEATHS
RIGHT. SO JUST SO I'M CLEAR R.
ALL SENDS ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE
GRANTS UNDER THIS PROGRAM. I'M
GONNA ASK OUR DOCTOR BURGESS
CHICKEN RESPOND IT'S A PROGRAM
SHALL HAVE MORE DETAIL ON.
RIGHT SO THROUGH THE STATE
RIGHT FINANCING ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM- THERE'S A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT VEHICLES THAT ARE
ALLOWED TO PARTICIPATE
EVERYTHING FROM HUNDRED TO PLUG
IN VEHICLES- AGAIN I'VE HEARD
THIS CHARACTERIZED AS A LITTLE
PROGRAM I DO WANT TO UNDERSCORE
THAT THIS IS REALLY A LOAN LOSS
PROGRAM SO WE LOOK TO. PARTNER
WITH BANKS- TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY HAVE THE BACKING THAT'S
NEEDED TO PROVIDE COMPETITIVE
RATES TO FOLKS WOULDN'T
NECESSARILY BE ABLE TO ACCESS
THAT OTHERWISE. SO THEN- SO ARE
YOU I'M SURE YOU'RE AWARE AND I
GUESS MAYBE YOU CAN JUST CLICK
BY SO. WHEN I LOOKED UP AT THE
WEBSITE THE CLEAN VEHICLE
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM WEBSITE. AS
OF AUGUST TWENTY TWENTY THERE
WAS SEVEN HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
GRANTS. FOR A TOTAL OF THREE
POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS IN
SPENDING AND THEN. LAST WEEK AS
OF JANUARY OR AS OF JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE I GUESS MAYBE
THAT'S THE MOST RECENT- ON THE
WEBSITE. IT WAS ONE THOUSAND
SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT GRANTS FOR A
TOTAL OF EIGHT POINT THREE
MILLION. DOLLARS AND I'M SURE
THERE'S AND IF YOURS ARE THEIRS
AT THAT THOUSANDS OF OTHER
ADDITIONAL APPLICATIONS PENDING
WITH SO I GUESS THAT NUMBER
COULD BE. MAYBE TEN MILLION
DOLLARS AS OF TODAY ARE YOU
AWARE OF THAT SURGE OF.
APPLICATIONS YES THIS IS. A
VERY POPULAR PROGRAM AND WE'VE
EXPERIENCED A SURGE BEFORE- AND
SO YOU KNOW RIGHT NOW WE'RE AT
THE POINT WHERE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT HUNDRED. WILL BYERS HAVE
RECEIVED LOANS- AND NOT NOT TO
BREAK THE NEWS EARLY BUT WE
WILL BE GOING INTO A
RESERVATION MODE- FOR THIS
PROGRAM- SHORTLY SO THEN WHAT
IS THE INCOME ELIGIBILITY. OF
THE NETWORK SO ALL OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE OF THESE
GRANTS- DO YOU KNOW THE- THE
AVERAGE INCOME OF THOSE
APPLYING. THE AVERAGE INCOME OF
PARTICIPANTS IS- THIRTY NINE
THOUSAND DOLLARS WITH AN
AVERAGE HOUSEHOLD SIZE OF JUST
OVER TWO PEOPLE. BUT IF YOU'RE
A FAMILY OF FOUR WHAT'S IT DID
THAT THAT INCOME LIMIT WE GO UP
TO LIKE A HUNDRED FOUR THOUSAND.
IS THAT CORRECT. IS MY
INTERPRETATION CORRECT. I'M SO
SORRY I WOULD NEED TO DOUBLE
CHECK THAT AND GET BACK TO YOU
SO IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
THERE WAS THAT THERE WAS A
CHANGE WITH THAT INCREASE THE
INCOME LIMIT. 64100% OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL SO THAT
IF SOMEONE OF THOSE IF THERE
WAS A FAMILY OF FOUR ON THE
WEBSITE IT SAID THAT YOUR AND
YOUR INCOME ELIGIBILITY PRETTY
HARD FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS. IS
THE IS THE WEBSITE CORRECT.
RIGHT FOR HIM YES THE 4100% OF
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL IS
CORRECT- AND I DID AFTER I WAS
GIVING YOU PREVIOUSLY BASED ON
ACTUAL APPLICANTS SO THE IN
TERMS OF OUR ACTUAL
PARTICIPANTS THE AVERAGE
INCOME. IS THIRTY NINE THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND YES- YOU ARE CAPPED
AT 4100% OF FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL FOR PARTICIPATION OKAY
AND WITH THAT BORDER PERCENT
WAS THAT THE RECENT CHANGE WAS
ALWAYS THERE. IN THE PROGRAM.
WITH THE INCOME LIMIT INCREASE
WAS THAT ALWAYS AT THEIR HOME
WAS THAT CHANGED RECENTLY. YOU
DON'T NEED TO DOUBLE CHECK
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
WE'LL GET BACK TO YOU. YOU
DON'T KNOW IF THE PROGRAM
CHANGED OR NOT. YOU KNOW THE
PROGRAM RECENTLY REOPENED AS I
MENTIONED WE EXPERIENCED A
SURGE PREVIOUSLY. AND SO IN THE
LAST YEAR WE HAVE REOPENED THE
PROGRAM TO DO STATEWIDE- BUT IT
IS ALWAYS BEST FOR HER PERCENT
OR FINANCING ASSISTANCE. OKAY I
GUESS IT MIGHT BE MY CONCERN
IS. A WHAT DO YOU HAVE
SAFEGUARDS TO ENSURE THAT THOSE
APPLYING FOR LOANS AND REBATES
THAT THEY ARE INDEED. YOU KNOW
LOW INCOME. YES GREAT QUESTION
SO YES WE DO WE DO HAVE THE
STATE PLACE WE DO PARTNER WITH
OUR GRANTEES TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE DOING CHECKS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE- ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS. AT AND THIS IS
TRUE ACROSS ACROSS OUR
PROGRAMS. FINANCING ASSISTANCE
OR OTHERWISE. YOU COULD YOU
COULD YOU OUTLINE WHAT THOSE
SAFEGUARDS WOULD BE OR WHAT
THEY ARE. I'M HAPPY TO LOOK
INTO TO THAT THE SPECIFIC
DOCUMENTATION THAT WE ASK OF
OUR PARTICIPANTS. OKAY I MEAN
THIS IS CERTAINLY A CONCERN
RIGHT GIVES ONE SENATOR
BRADFORD WAS OUTLINING IS THAT
YOU KNOW MATTHEW PRETTY BASIC
QUESTIONS AND I GUESS. YOU KNOW.
I DON'T WANT WE WANT PEOPLE TO
BE ELIGIBLE AND WE WANT RIGHT
PEOPLE TO BE UTILITIES I HAVE
PROGRAM AND- YOU DON'T SEEM TO
KNOW WHAT'S IT GOING TO HAVE TO
ENSURE THAT. THERE'S NO FRAUD
AND ABUSE IN THE PROGRAM- AND I
ONLY SAY THAT AND I GOES YEAH
IT'S LEADING UP TO THIS
QUESTION WHICH IS. YOU KNOW
I'VE I'VE SEEN SOME ONLINE
COMMENTS IN AND SOME OF THE
WEBSITES THAT INDICATED THAT.
WEALTHY CUSTOMERS ARE ACCESSING
THE PROGRAM. AND SO I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU'RE AWARE OF THAT.
BE CONCERNED BY THOSE REPORTS
BUT AGAIN WE DO ELIGIBLE
ELIGIBILITY CHECKS BUT- IF
THERE'S SPECIFIC CONCERNS THAT
THIS IS BEING GAME SOMEHOW I'M
HAPPY TO HAVE THAT DISCUSSION
WITH YOU IN YOUR OFFICE TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND THE CONCERN.
OKAY- YOU KNOW IT THAT AND I
THINK THIS IS SOMETHING ABOUT
WHERE I THINK I JUST WANNA
HIGHLIGHTED THIS IS A
TRANSPARENCY ISSUE RIGHT I
THINK IT I WANT I WANT TO QUOTE
MR LAWRIE WHICH AT THAT. HE HE
HE ANSWERED MISTER BRADFORD BY
SAYING THAT EVERY DOLLAR. SPENT
HARD IN THESE PROGRAMS ARE WELL
DOCUMENTED. AND WELL RECORDED.
SELL IF IT IS WELL DOCUMENTED
AND WELL REPORT THEN THERE
BETTER NOT BE ANY FRAUD OR
ABUSE IN THIS PROGRAM- AND YOU
KNOW I'VE I'VE ALSO SEEN ON ON
COMMENT BOARDS AND ON ONLINE
MESSAGE BOARDS THAT.
INDIVIDUALS ARE PERMITTING THEM
TO HUNT TWO THOUSAND DOLLAR
HOME CHARGER CREDIT YOU'RE
USING THEIR TARGET CREDIT.
BUYING CHARGERS AND PORTABLE
CHARGERS. AND THEN SELLING THEM
ON EBAY. THAT'S CERTAINLY NOT
ALLOWED IN THE PROGRAM IN THE
SAN. AGAIN I'M HAPPY TO LOOK
INTO THESE ALLEGATIONS I MEAN
YOU'RE YOU'RE BRINGING UP SOME
THINGS. VERY CONCERNING AND
SOME INTERESTED IN LOOKING INTO
THAT YEAH I DO WANT TO
UNDERSCORE AT THE WAY THE
FINANCING ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
WORKS AS WE GO THROUGH THE PRE
APPROVAL PROCESS FOR EVERYONE
WHO PARTICIPATES IN THE
PROGRAM. WE LOOK AT THEIR
INCOME TAX DATA AND THEN
APPROVED. TO PARTICIPATE SO IF
THAT IS NOT OCCURRING IN THE
WAY THAT I LINED OUT OR YOU'RE
AWARE OF SOME SOME GAMING I.
WOULD WANT TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION. OKAY I MASS DON'T
WANT NOT BUT IT SOUNDS TO ME
THAT- OKAY MAYBE SOME LOOPHOLES
AND THERE MAY BE SOME SAID CAR
CHALLENGES- AND THIS IS VERY
DISCONCERTING THAT- YEAH YOU'RE
NOT. OUTLINING THE SAFEGUARDS
OR THE SYSTEM OF THE STATE OF
SAFEGUARDS IN HAND NO PROBLEM
YOU'RE TOUTING. AS SUCCESSFUL-
SO THAT'S THAT'S VERY TROUBLING
TO ME. THANK YOU MISTER PUBLIC
I MAY BE A LITTLE BIT- NERVOUS
BUT I GUESS THE THING THAT I'M
TRYING. TO DO MY BEST UNDER
SCORE IS THE HIGHEST WHICH WE
DO PRE APPROVE EVERY
APPLICATION WE DO CHECK AND
COME TAX RETURNS. AND WORK TO
PRE APPROVAL. OR THEY ATE IN
THE FINANCING ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM. I'M NOT AWARE OF ANY
PROOF OF GAMING SYSTEM BUT
AGAIN WAYS OPEN TO A
CONVERSATION. YEAH AND I AM NOT
LOOKING AT ME I DO INTEND TO
PUT ON THE SPOT AND AS AND
OTHER PEOPLE ON ON- AND CAR
BUT- I THINK THESE ARE VERY
IMPORTANT QUESTIONS AS WE-
DISCUSSED. I MEAN IF THERE IS A
DISCUSSION WITHIN THE
LEGISLATURE OF PUTTING MORE
MONEY INTO THIS PROGRAM- I
THINK WE'RE GOING TO ADDRESS
THESE THEM CHALLENGES CAN I ASK
HOW HOW MUCH IS LEFT IN THE
CLEAN VEHICLE.. I'M LEFT THIS TO BE.
SINCE SIR. I GUESS BROKE AS I
AM. WHERE ARE ABOUT TO RUN OUT
OF MONEY AND ABOUT TO ANNOUNCE
THAT WE'RE ENTERING INTO TO A
RESOLUTION. SOME OF THE
MENTIONED THERE HAS BEEN A
SEARCH ON THE PROGRAM. AND WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
ARE THE KEY MARKET. SO THAT THE
PROGRAM IS STEPS OUT RAPIDLY.
RAPIDLY RUNNING OUT OF RESOURCE.
SO HOW MUCH WOULD BE SPENT
WHOLE PROGRAM. HOW MUCH IS THAT
THE HOW AND HOW MUCH WAS A YOU
GUYS ANTICIPATING SPENDING
BECAUSE I AM GOING BACK TO WHAT
THE CHARITY INDICATED GIVE. ME
WHAT IS IT WHAT THE NUMBERS
2180% WAS GOING TO THE BAY AREA
AND- TWENTY ONE LESS LESS THAN
10% WAS GOING TO. FIX IT TRUMP
COUNTY AND HE AND I REPRESENT
THE SAME AREAS SO- WE CERTAINLY
ARE NOT VERY SENSITIVE TO THE
FACT IS IF. IF THIS PROGRAM IS
NOT TECHNICALLY WORKING.
WITHOUT WORKING AND CRANK OUT.
SO YOU CAN PROVIDE ME THE
INFORMATION I. APPRECIATE IT
THANK MISTER. THANK YOU MR FONG-
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO ASSEMBLY
GIPSON WHO IS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY LET ME ASK THERE'S
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS. THAT HAVE
QUESTIONS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY IF THEY CAN JUST. SEND
ME A QUICK MESSAGE TAX. WOOD
THE MOST EFFICIENT AND SO WILL
MOVE TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ADJOURNMENTS SALAS- ICE I WOULD
ABSOLUTELY LIKE TO GET A
RESPONSE TO A SIMILAR FARMS
QUESTION REGARDING HOW MUCH
MONEY IS LEFT IN THE PROGRAM- I
WOULD THINK THAT YOU APPEAR
BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE- THIS
QUESTION WILL BE GREATLY
ANTICIPATED. AS PART OF YOUR
PRESENTATION SO CAN YOU PROVIDE
THIS INFORMATION CALL SOMEBODY
AND FIND OUT THERE'SNO FOR YOU
ON THIS LINE THAT SOMEBODY
SHOULD BE TEXAN SOMEBODY A
RESPONSE TO MEMBER FONG'S
QUESTION THAT I AM ABSOLUTELY
CURIOUS TO HEAR A RESPONSE TO.
SO IT'S POSSIBLE I'M NOT
UNDERSTANDING THE QUESTION BUT
THERE'S BEEN ABOUT FOURTEEN
WHICH COMPANIES HOW MUCH MONEY
IS LEFT IN THE PROGRAM. IT
SHOULD LET ME TRY AND TAKE IT
STANDS I THINK I AM TRACKING
THE QUESTION BECAUSE THERE'S
THREE PROGRAMS THEY WERE TALK
ABOUT DIFFERENTLY. I WITH
RESPECT TO C. B. R. NG IT'S
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE MILLION LEFT.
WITH RESPECT. WITH RESPECT TO
LOW INCOME C. B. R. P. WE JUST
MOVED IT'S ABOUT TWENTY FIVE
MILLION SO BOTH OF THOSE ARE
ABOUT I AM IN THE BALLPARK DID
YOU CAN CORRECT ME BUT I THINK
THAT WAS THE QUESTION IS ONE OF
THE REMAINING DOLLARS IN THOSE
TWO PROGRAMS AND THAT THOSE ARE
APPROXIMATE AND I WILL FOLLOW
UP WITH THE PRECISE NUMBERS BUT
THOSE ARE. THOSE ARE PROXIMATE
ON THE SPOT RESPONSES IT SHOULD
BE CORRECT. AS I UNDERSTAND
SYDNEY INDICATED THAT- YOU
WOULD HAVE TO GO INTO RESERVE
MOLD OR- BECAUSE THIS MONEY TO
GET READY TO RUN OUT WAS THAT
CORRECT. I DON'T THIS DINNER
CHECKED VERY QUICKLY I HAD
THOUGHT WE WERE TALKING ABOUT
THE STATEWIDE FINANCING SYSTEMS
PROGRAM WHICH IS ABOUT TO GO ON
A RESERVATION MODE AND WE ONLY
HAVE ABOUT TWO MILLION DOLLARS
LEFT THEIR HEADS THE
RESERVATION MODE. MISTER COREY
YOU MENTIONED HOW MUCH WE HAVE
LEFT REMAINING IN THE C. B. R.
P. POT- IF THERE IS OTHER
PROGRAMS ON THE TABLE THAT
YOU'RE INTERESTED IN DOLLAR
AMOUNTS I'M HAPPY TO CHIME IN
THERE BUT APOLOGIES IF COST
CONFUSION. GRIPS MOVING ON UP I
WOULD ALLOW MY COMMENTS WERE-
SENATOR BRAD BURKE- I JUST FEEL
ABSOLUTELY SINCE I'VE BEEN
ELECTED. OUR CAR HAVE I BELIEVE
IN MY OPINION AND MY OPINION
HAS TOTALLY DISRESPECT THIS
LEGISLATURE. IT'S LIKE YOU HAVE
A BAD TO DO WHATEVER YOU WANT
TO DO. IT RESPECT OF THIS
LEGISLATURE- FOR THAT FOR THAT
REASON LET ME POSE THIS
QUESTION. BUT THOSE PROGRAMS
WHICH ARE INTENDED FOR SOCIAL
ECONOMIC BENEFITS. AUDIT FINDS
THAT IT WOULD ACCEPT. IT WOULD
EXPECT CARD TO DEMONSTRATE.
PROGRAM VALUED BY CLEARLY
DEFINING. AND MEASURING SOCIAL
ECONOMIC. BENEFITS IT SOUNDS
LIKE. CAR HAS MANY. OF TOOLS OF.
BUT SUCH AS THE CLEAN THE CLEAN
CAR FOR ALL SURVEY BUT IT
FAILED TO REQUIRES IT. Y
QUESTION TO MR COREY CAN YOU
EXPLAIN WHY CAR HAS FAILED IN
ITS STATUTORY OBLIGATION. SEVEN
LET ME OUR FIRST MAKE AN
IMPORTANT POINT BECAUSE YOUR
YOUR FOCUS IS RIGHTLY SO ON
SOCIAL. CANONIC SOCIAL JUSTICE
ISSUES WITH RESPECT TO CLEAN
TRUCKS WITH RESPECT TO CLEAN
CARS FOR ALL THOSE VEHICLES ARE
OPERATING IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES THE COMMUNITIES
AROUND THE STATE THEY'RE SAYING
THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE AND UP AND
DOWN THE STATE ON EIGHTY SIX
SEVENTEEN THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE
IS CONCERNEDABOUT DIRTY TRUCKS
IN THEIR COMMUNITIES. THESE
DOLLARS SUBSTANTIAL ARE
CLEANING UP TRUCKS NOT ENOUGH
DOLLARS BECAUSE THERE ARE A LOT
OF TRUCKS CLICK GETTING CLEANER
TRUCKS ON THE ROAD REDUCING
DIESEL PM A CLEAN CARS FOR ALL
PROGRAM YOU GET TALKING IT
CALLED OUT DIRECTED AT LOW
INCOME FOLKS GETTING AND THEN
MUCH CLEANER. LOWER EMITTING
VEHICLES NOW WITH RESPECT TO
YOUR JOBS QUESTION IT WAS A
FAIR CRITICISM ARE WE
COLLECTING DATA FROM CONSUMERS
THAT PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM
ABOUT THE ECONOMIC BENEFITS IN
ADDITION TO THE CALL CLEAN CAR
THAT THEY GOT. AYE THAT'S
CHALLENGING AND MY POINT IS
EITHER GOOD KNOWLEDGE IT
STRAIGHT UP GETTING THAT DATA
IT WAS NOT COMPLETE WE NEED TO
GET IT. AND SOME CONSUMERS MAY
BE. NOT AS WELL TO SHOW IT
BECAUSE IT ARE PERSONAL AND
FOR. RELATED ISSUES BUT- YOU
KNOW I AM COMMITTED TO FOLLOW
UP AND BASICALLY HAVE SURVEYS
THAT ASKED THAT DATE YOU KNOW
SO IT'S NOT ABOUT THE CLEANER
VEHICLES YOU'RE GETTING. IT'S
ABOUT JUST GETTING THE CLEANER
VEHICLE CREATE OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES JOBS AND SO ONE
THAT THAT THAT DATA IS MUCH
MORE CHALLENGING TO GET OUT AND
WE'RE GOING TO FOCUS ON. OKAY
WHAT MISTER CHAIR IF I MAY
FOLLOW UP JUST ONE LAST
QUESTION. GET ARE GIVEN ARAFAT
THE AUDIT'S FINDINGS ARE JUST
FINE- THE FACT THAT THIS BODY
IS IN THE PROCESS OF A DAY OF
ADOPTING SOME CAP AND TRADE
EXPENDITURES THEY ARE EARLY
ACTION. HOW CAN HOW CAN THE
LEGISLATURE JUSTIFY EXPANDING.
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
BEFORE THE AUDITORS
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE ADOPTED.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. CLEARLY
ALTAMONT APPROPRIATIONS IN
EUROPE IN THE ADMINISTRATION'S
COURT BUT I WOULD MAKE THIS
OBSERVATION AND I THINK IT'S AN
IMPORTANT ONE. I CALIFORNIA HAS
THE WORST AIR QUALITY IN THE
UNITED STATES AND HAS MADE
ENORMOUS PROGRESS UNDENIABLE
PROGRESS IN IT AS THE
POPULATION INCREASED THE NUMBER
OF VEHICLES AND SO FORTH.
PEOPLE FROM AROUND THE COUNTRY
AROUND THE WORLD COME HERE TO
SEE HOW WE'RE DOING IN ADDITION
TO THOSE IMPROVEMENTS AND WE
STILL HAVE AREAS WITH THAT HOW.
MUCH MORE IMPROVEMENT.
CALIFORNIA IS A MAGNET. FOR
CLEAN CAR- MANUFACTURES ZERO
MISSION ZERO EMISSION TRUCKS
ZERO MOTION. FORKLIFTS ZERO
EMISSION BUSES. IT IS A DIRECT
RESPONSE FROM THE LEADERSHIP OF
THE LEGISLATURE IN ITS
COMMITMENT TO CLEAN AIR AND THE
FACT THAT IS SUPPORTING
PROGRAMS INSTEAD OF PROGRAMS
THAT ARE SERVING AS A MAGNET
FOR MANUFACTURING AND JOBS COME
TO CALIFORNIA YOU DON'T HAVE TO
BELIEVE ME LOOK AT THE I. L. A.
R. ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION AND OTHER ECONOMIC
OUTFITS THAT LOOK AT THIS DATA
INDEPENDENTLY AND SAY THE SAME
THING. I'D HURRY UP. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU BELIEVE THAT
CONCLUDES THAT YOU'RE
QUESTIONING MISTER GIBSON. YES
RIGHT NOW ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
WE'RE GONNA RETURN IT BACK TO
YOU- MEMBERS ON THE DIETS I
JUST HAD. TWO QUICK CLARIFYING
QUESTIONS- ONE THAT WAS RAISED
EARLIER ABOUT. THE
ACCOUNTABILITY A LOT OF THIS IS
STEMMING FROM THE LACK OF DATA
THAT WAS OUTLINED IN THE
AUDITOR'S REPORT NEEDING SOME
OF THE STATE IT WAS INDICATED.
THAT THAT CAR HAS THE FUNDING
THE AUTHORITY AND SOME OF THESE
THIRD PARTY CONTRACTS- TO TRACK
THE EFFICACY OF SOME OF THE
PROGRAMS WERE DISCUSSING TODAY-
BUT- I JUST WANTED TO GET YOUR
PERSPECTIVE MISTER COREY- WHY
ISN'T THE DATA AVAILABLE IF.
YOU GUYS ARE CONTRACTING WITH
INDIVIDUALS TO PROVIDE THIS
DATA. WELL THANK GOODNESS
FOLLOW UP IS WHAT DATA ARE YOU
TALKING ABOUT BECAUSE LET ME BE
CRYSTAL CLEAR ON THIS DATA ON
THE VEHICLES THAT ARE BEING
FUNDED. WHETHER THEY'RE NEW OR
USED CLEANER VEHICLES THE DATA
OUT WHERE THOSE VEHICLES ARE
GOING. THE TOTAL AT YOU
BENEFITS AND MISSION REDUCTIONS
OVERLY OVERALL PROGRAM IT'LL
DAY THAT'S COLLECTED SO AND
RECORD AND OUR MISSION
INVENTORY I THINK THE REAL
QUESTION THAT REALLY GOT TO THE
HEART OF THIS IS SOME OF THE
HARDER GAME. TO COLLECT QUALITY
DATA INTO A COMPREHENSIVE WAY
HI MY BIRDS ARE PARTICIPATING
IN THE CLEAN CARS FOR ALL. I
DETERMINING THAT LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUAL DIDN'T CREATE NEW
JOB OPPORTUNITIES TO THEIR
CREDIT SCORE INCREASE. THAT'S
THE KIND OF DATA THAT WE DON'T
HAVE AND WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
TRY AND GET IT AND HONESTLY WE
MAY NOT BE THE BEST AGENCIES
CORRECT MAYBE WORKFORCE AND
LABOR DEVELOPMENTS SOME OF THAT
LEGISLATORS POSE THAT QUESTION.
WE'RE GOING TO HELP ON THAT AND
I'VE REACHED OUT TO SOME
LEGISLATORS AND OTHERS REALLY
EXPLORING HOW CAN WE FULLY BE
RESPONSIBILITY AUDITORS
QUESTION. QUESTIONS ARE DO IT
AN INEFFECTIVE IN MEANINGFUL
WAY AND DO IN AN AREA WHERE WE
HAVE SUFFICIENT EXPERTISE. JOB
CREATION THAT'S WATER ARE VERY
OF EXPLOITATION THERE CERTAINLY
ARE PEOPLE MAKE CAREERS OUT OF
THIS THERE WERE WHERE THEY WERE.
ALREADY TALKING TO WE'RE GONNA
NEED SOME HELP. GOT IT NINE.
THAT YOU KNOW BECAUSE AT THE
END OF DAY WERE JUST TO MAKE
SURE WE'RE GETTING THEM BANG
FOR THE BUCK A FOR TRYING
COLLECT THIS. TO EFFECTUATE
CHANGE IN SOME OF THESE MOST
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES MOST.
POLLUTED COMMUNITIES AND
OBVIOUSLY THE DATA ABSTRACT THE
POLICY OF THE FUNDING. TO GET
THE GOALS THE CLIMATE GOALS AND
REALLY THE- HOPEFULLY THE
POSITIVE HEALTH ASPECTS WE CAN
HAVE IN SOME OF THESE MOST.
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES- SO
YOU KNOW I THINK THE END OF THE
DAY A LOT OF US ARE LOOKING FOR
YOU KNOW ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
EQUITY FOR THESE A LOT OF TIME
IN NON ATTAINMENT. HIGHLY
POLLUTED COMMUNITIES AROUND THE
STATE. LET ME JUST ASK ONE
FINAL QUESTION- AND THAT'S JUST
OF THE AUDIT THE AUDIT MADE A
NUMBER OF RECOMMENDATIONS I
BELIEVE AROUND FOURTEEN. AND I
JUST WANTED TO ASK- ARE YOU
PLANNING ON IMPLEMENTING ALL OF
THOSE BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY WE'RE
GONNA DO THE CHECK INS WITH THE
AUDITOR COMES BACK AND CHECKS
IN ON THE PROGRESS WELL THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OUTLINED IN THE
AUDITED WHAT STEPS HAVE YOU
TAKEN TO ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND WERE YOU
PLANNING ON IMPLEMENTING ALL OF
THE AUDITOR'S RECOMMENDATIONS.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND SHADES AND
SHORT ANSWER YOUR QUESTION DO
WE PLAN TO IMPLEMENT THE RECORD
WE CERTAINLY DO. I AND THE
AUDITOR THOUGH AS YOU KNOW AS
YOU'RE WELL FAMILIAR WITH.
THERE'S PERIODIC REPORTS THAT
WE WILL BE UPLOADING TO THE-
AUDITOR SITE AT THE- SIXTY DAY
MARK THAT'S NEXT MONTH. SAID
THE SIX MONTH AND YEAR AND-
ANNUALLY. THEREAFTER. TO YOUR
QUESTION AND- A MEMBER GONZALEZ
ASKED THIS TO THERE'S SOME
THINGS WE CAN DO IN THE SHORT
RUN. RIGHT TURNS OUT BY
ADJUSTING GRANT AGREEMENTS
GOING FORWARD SOLICITATIONS. BY
TWO AND WE WERE SMALL AND
EVERYONE OF THE WORK
REQUIREMENTS THAT WERE CALLED
OUT BUT THE DEGREE TO WHICH WE
CAN RESPOND AND HOW. COMPLETES
SURGEONS OUT A SHORT ALMOST LET
ME ASSURE YOU. THE SIXTY DAY
RESPONSE IS NOT GONNA BE AS
COMPLETE AS I'D LIKE IT TO BE.
IT'S TOO MUCH WILL WILL HELP
HAVE MOVED FORWARD WILL WOULD
STRENGTHEN REPORT THE SIX MONTH
WILL BE STRONGER. THE YEAR%
WALKING STRONGER THAN THAT AND
WE'RE ALREADY REACHING OUT TO
OTHERS OTHER EXPERTS HOW CAN WE
BE FULLY RESPONSIVE THE
AUDITOR'S RECOMMENDATIONS. AND
DO IN A WAY THAT HONESTLY. THE
KNOWLEDGE OF THE CHALLENGES
THAT I TALKED ABOUT WHICH
INCLUDE HOW DO YOU DISENTANGLE.
WHAT MOTIVATES A CONSUMER TO
MAKE A DECISION WHEN THERE'S
MULTIPLE. PROGRAMS INTERACT
THAT'S NOT AN ISSUE WHETHER
WE'RE GETTING A NEW CAR AND
WE'RE GETTING REDUCTIONS IT'S
HOW ARE YOU ATTRIBUTING THOSE
BENEFITS. THAT'S COMPLEX.
ECONOMIC BEHAVIORAL ECONOMICS
WE'RE LOOKING FOR SOME HELP TO
BREAK IT DOWN AND WORK THROUGH
IT. YEAH WE UNDERSTAND THOSE
CHALLENGES THANK YOU MISTER
KOREA THE CAB FROM SOME OF THE
MEMBERS QUESTIONING THOSE THEY
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
PROGRAMS WERE- BENEFITING
INDIVIDUALS AND LOWER. SOCIAL
ECONOMIC SITUATIONS. AND I KNOW
SOME OF THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
BROUGHT UP ON INCOMES OVER A
HUNDRED YOU KNOW SIX FIGURES.
AND THEY SEEM TO BE SKEWED
TOWARDS. HELPING THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WITH HIGHER INCOMES
AS OPPOSED TO LOWER INCOMES. SO
WE'RE GONNA LOOK VERY EAGERLY
EAGERLY AT THE NEXT UPCOMING
REPORTS BUT JUST KEEP THAT IN
MIND THAT. THE NUMBER OF THE
LEGISLATORS THAT YOU HEARD HERE
TODAY ARE LOOKING AT THOSE THAT
LOW SOCIOECONOMIC STATUS AND
HOW THE PROGRAMS ARE BENEFITING
THE INTENDED PLACES. YOU KNOW I
BROUGHT UP THE EXAMPLE OF 80%
EARLIER BEING SPENT OUTSIDE OF
THE DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY
BUT- THOSE ARE THE TYPES OF
THINGS I THINK I KEEP CONTINUE
TO HEAR FROM. SEVERAL MEMBERS
OF THE LEGISLATOR LEGISLATURE.
I WITH THAT LET ME ASK YOU HAVE
ANY. REMARKS I DON'T BELIEVE
THERE'S ANY MORE QUESTIONS.
LOCAL I DO NOT YEAR OKAY WELL
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY WE
APPRECIATE THAT- WITH THAT
WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND
CONTINUE WANT TO AGENDA ITEM
NUMBER FOUR WHICH IS THE PUBLIC
COMMENTS. I BELIEVE WE HAVE AN
OPERATOR ON THE LINE. OPERATOR
DO WE DON'T HAVE ANY PUBLIC
COMMENTS WE HAVEN'T YOU. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO
NOW AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
NOW. AND JUST LET YOU KNOW SO
FAR THERE ARE ABOUT TEN IN THE
QUEUE. OKAY THANK YOU OPERATOR
LET'S GO AHEAD AND MOVE TO THE
PUBLIC COMMENT SECTION. AB IF
YOU COULD PLEASE LIMIT YOUR
COMMENTS TO LESS THAN TWO
MINUTES PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELF AND IF YOU'RE WITHIN
THEIR ORGANIZATION- PLEASE TELL
US WHICH ORGANIZATION THAT IS
IF YOU ARE NOT WITH AN
ORGANIZATION PLEASE. TELL US
WHICH COUNTY YOU RESIDE IN AS
YOU PROCEED WITH YOUR PUBLIC
COMMENTS BUT PLEASE TRY TO
LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS TO TWO
MINUTES AND IF. WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING IS ALREADY BEEN SAID
PLEASE A- PLEASE INDICATE THAT
AS WELL SO WE CAN MOVE QUICKLY
THANK YOU. COOPER PHOTO I.
NUMBER TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU CHAIR NUMBERS BINDING
BANDMATE ABSENT SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE NEW SOLUTIONS AND
OWNER OPERATOR OF ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE DEPOT WAS LOCATING AND
TRACKING QUARTERS AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES WE
PLEASE SELL DOMICILE AND
MAINTAIN MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
YOUR MISSION TRUCKS AND
SHUTTLES UNDER SERVICE
AGREEMENTS. A TRIP PURCHASE
INCENTIVES REMAIN NECESSARY AND
VITAL FOR THE ZERO EMISSION
TRUCK MARKET ESPECIALLY AT THE
STILL VERY EARLY STAGE OF THE
DAPP OF THE DOCTRINE THAT
ADAPTER AND PARTICULARLY FOR
MEDIUM. AND SMALLER FLEET
OPERATORS. NOW ONLY ARE THE
INCENTIVES CREDIT. CONTINUE
ADOPTION. PROVIDING GAS
MITIGATION AND AIR QUALITY
BENEFITS THEY'RE HELPING TO
BUILD IN SUPPORT OF WORKFORCE
ECOSYSTEM OF CALIFORNIA JOBS
ZERO EMISSION TRUCKING
MAINTENANCE AND SERVICING.
KELLY IN THOSE AREAS CLOSED
OVERLY IMPACTED. ON BEHALF OF
THE WAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP TIME AND ATTENTION.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PUBLIC COMMENTS LET'S MOVE TO
THE NEXT PUBLIC COMMONPLACE.
NEXT LEVEL CAROLINE FOURTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
EVENING CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. ALEXANDER ON
BEHALF OF CAL START YOUR MEMBER
BASED NONPROFIT. AND ALSO
PROPOSED DISCLOSURE WE ARE THE
ADMINISTRATOR- THE H. THAT
HEAVY DUTY THAT YOUR INCENTIVE
PROGRAM I RESIDE IN SACRAMENTO
COUNTY BUT WE ARE HEADQUARTERED
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY- THANK
YOU HEARD A LOT ABOUT EASIER P.
ANY CARD EQUITY PROGRAMS WHICH
ARE EQUALLY IMPORTANT TO HELP
START- BUT WE DID WANT TO SPEAK
A BIT MORE ABOUT THE HEAVY DUTY
PROGRAMS WHICH ARE ALSO
DISCUSSED IN THE AUDITOR'S
REPORT. AND HEALTHCARE ADVOCATE
FOR ECOSYSTEM APPROACH TO
DECARBONIZING TRANSPORTATION
AND WE REALLY EMPHASIZED ACROSS
THE COUNTRY AND AROUND THE
WORLD. I NEED FRANKLIN HAS
BETTER ALSO PAIRED WITH
REGULATION AND THAT GIVING
DIRECTION TO MANUFACTURERS AND
FLEETS I'M WE FIND THE AUDITORS
RECORD IN SOME CASES EARLY
MISSTATES THE CAUSE AND EFFECT
FOR MEDIUM AND. HEAVY DUTY THAT
PURCHASES. I HERE MISSION VIA
PURCHASE AND ALSO. MAJOR AIR
ECONOMIC BENEFIT. OF CLEAN
VEHICLE FOR. I AM SURE HOPE
THERE ON THE LINE YOU'LL HEAR
FOR ANOTHER. LIKE DAN WHO
PURCHASED VEHICLES BUT THE
ASSISTANCE BUT H. THAT. AS WELL
AS MANUFACTURING BRINGING VERY
ADVANCED VEHICLE TO MARKET
THANK YOU I'M FAIR. THANK YOU
THANK YOU RIGHT NEXT BUBBLE
COMMONPLACE. MAXIMO TO LINE
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD-
GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE
MEMBERS CHRIS LOWELL CALIFORNIA
TRUCKING ASSOCIATION- WANTED TO
RESPOND AS ONE PART OF THE
AUDIT- REGARDING WHETHER ZERO
EMISSION OF COMMERCIAL TRUCKS
WOULDN'T FOCUS IN THE ABSENCE
OF INCENTIVES I'M AS YOU MAY
KNOW- CARB EARLY PROPOSES TO
ACQUIRE NEARLY ALL COMMERCIAL
TRUCKS IN CALIFORNIA. ZERO
EMISSION BY TWENTY FORTY. GIVEN
THAT THE VAST MAJORITY OF
TRUCKING COMPANIES OR SMALL
BUSINESSES AND GIVEN THAT YOUR
MISSION TRUCKS ARE TYPICALLY
TWO TO THREE TIMES MORE
EXPENSIVE THAN A TRADITIONAL
DIESEL. INCENTIVES TO BUY DOWN
VEHICLE AND CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE COST A CRUCIAL
PART OF THE SPEECH STRATEGY.
THE BOYS ARE MISSION TRUCKS.
COMMERCIAL TRUCKS ARE VERY
DIFFERENT THAN CARS AS ARE THE
DECISION TO GO INTO WHAT
TECHNOLOGY PURCHASE. COMMERCIAL
TRUCKS MUST MAKE ECONOMIC SENSE
FOR THEIR OPERATORS AND
INCENTIVES ARE A CRUCIAL PART
OF MAKING THE BOTTOM LINE WORK.
WE SUPPORT THE ARTISTS CALL FOR
GREATER TRANSPARENCY BUT ALSO
HIGHLIGHT THE NEED OVERALL. FOR
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE INCENTIVES
UP TO BILLIONS OF DOLLARS MORE
TAXES FOR CALIFORNIA TRUCKERS
IN THIS EFFORT I COULD QUITE
YOUR MISSION TRUCKS THANK YOU.
THANK. YOU OUR NEXT PUBLIC
COMMENT PLEASE. MAXIMO LOCAL
THIRTY PLEASE BY. GOOD EVENING
BACKGROUND ON THE AFTER THE
STATE BUILDING CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL CALIFORNIA I
WANTED TO BRIEFLY EXPRESSED
YOUR DISMAY REGARDING SOME OF
THE FINDINGS FROM AUDIT.
PARTICULARLY AROUND THE BOARD
STANDARD EVALUATE THIS
ACCIDENTS PROGRAMS ON REQUIRED
JOB CREATION AND TRAINING. AS
YOU KNOW BECAUSE PRESIDENTS
HAVE DRAMATIC IMPACTS ON THE
LIVELIHOOD OF OUR MEMBERS AS
WELL AS FOR OTHER INDUSTRIAL
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR UNION
STREET WHICH REASON IT'S
PARTICULARLY TROUBLING TO READ
DESPITE CLEAR DIRECTION
MANDATES REQUIRING JOB DATA
REPORTING CARD WAS ONLY KEEPING
AFTER A SMALL FRACTION OF THE
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS- LIKE WHY
CAN COLLEGES DOES INCLUDE JOB
TRAINING AS A PROGRAM BENEFITS
DOES NOT ALWAYS REQUIRE ITS
PROGRAM MINISTERS TO PROVIDE
DETAILED INFORMATION ABOUT THE
TRAINING. OR HOW IT BENEFITS
PARTICIPANTS GIVEN THE NUMEROUS
WAY CARD PROGRAMS IMPACTOR
MEMBERS JOBS THE BOARD BEEN
DIFFERENCE TO JOB CREATION
TRAINING IS CERTAINLY TROUBLING
WE WOULD ASK THE BOARD WERE TO
NEARLY REMEDY THESE
INADEQUACIES. MEANING FOREIGN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU PUBLIC
COMMON PLEASE. AXOLOTL LINE SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK THIS IS
WITH GAVIN THE COAL FOR CLEAN
AIR WE SPONSORED THE BILL THAT
REQUIRES INVESTMENTS IN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES SO
THIS TOPIC IS OF GREAT INTEREST
TO US AND WE AGREE WITH THE
AUDITORS THAT WE NEED MORE DATA
PARTICULARLY ON IMPACTS ON
CONSUMER BEHAVIOR ON
QUANTIFYING SOCIAL ECONOMIC
BENEFITS LIKE JOBS AND-
DEMONSTRATING BENEFITS THE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
WHILE THIS ANALYSIS GOES
FORWARD WE SHOULD NOT HAVE
PARALYSIS OF ANALYSIS AND WE
NEED TO CONTINUE THE PROGRAMS
THAT ARE BENEFITING
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
GERMAN SALAS YOU HAVE BEEN A
BIG SUPPORTER OF CLEAN CARS FOR
ALL WHICH IS PROVIDING CLEAN
SAFE MOBILITY FOR A LOT OF
PEOPLE IN YOUR DISTRICT AND
OTHER DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
AROUND THE STATE AND WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT PROGRAMS LIKE
THAT. ARE CONTINUE TO BE FUNDED.
SECONDLY WE ARE. ABOUT FALLING
SHORT OF OUR EMISSION REDUCTION
NEEDS FOR AIR QUALITY AND
GREENHOUSE GASES SO WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO DO MORE TO
REDUCE EMISSIONS FROM OIL
REFINERIES. AND TO REDUCE
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED. AND
FINALLY- IT'S A MYSTERY TO ME
WHY THIS AUDIT IS SO FOCUSED ON
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND SO
LITTLE ON AIR QUALITY AND
PUBLIC HEALTH. MANY OF YOU
MEMBERS HAVE TALKED ABOUT YOUR
CONCERN WITH AIR POLLUTION BUT
YOU DIDN'T ASK THE AUDITOR TO
ADDRESS THAT AND THAT'S A BIG
DISAPPOINTMENT TO US THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OUR NEXT PUBLIC
COMMENT PLACE. ZACKS ABOVE ALL
TRYING SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. A GOOD AFTERNOON DANIEL
BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF CARE CLUB
CALIFORNIA THE OTHER RESULTS
SUGGEST THAT CALIFORNIA NEEDS
TO DO A LOT MORE TO REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS IN THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR EVER EVER
GOING TO MEET OUR GOALS AND
FLOW THE CLIMATE CRISIS. HE
EVEN THOUGH THE AUDIT FOCUSED
ON GHG IT WE ALSO KNOW THAT WE
NEED TO GET FATO FUEL
COMBUSTION ENGINE OFF THE ROAD
FOR EVER GOING TO GET CLEAN UP.
THE STATE SENATORIAL AIR
POLLUTION. EXPECTING SINGLE
AGING TO STOP CRISIS THE ON
REALIZE. THE LEGISLATURE NEEDS
TO DO TAKE MORE AGGRESSIVE
ACTION TO OUR PLATE POLLUTING.
FOSSIL FUEL VEHICLES. WITH ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES. THE
LEGISLATURE MEANT TAKE BOLD
ACTION SUCH AS SUPPORTING THE
GOVERNOR'S CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
BUDGET PROPOSAL AND CANNOT
AFFORD TO SUPPORT HALF
MEASURES. MIKESELL CALLED THE
NEAR DEIR AL VEHICLES. ALL
STATE AGENCIES AND THE
LEGISLATURE MUST DO MORE TO
PROTECT OUR PLANET. AND
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU NEXT PUBLIC COMMENT
PLEASE. MAX HELLO CAROLINE
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SURE THE MEMBERS OF THE
CANADIAN MINING GROWING IN
AMERICA WITH THE FUNDING FOR
SUSTAINABLE ENERGY I'M CALLING
TO BALANCE THE COR OF CARBS
INTERPRETATION PROJECT WHICH
ARE NEEDED TO REACH THE STATE
CRIME HERE QUALITY COAL THE-
OTHER PERMISSION CRITICAL
VICTORIA PROJECT IS TO BE P.
ONE ACOSTA A ONE YOU CAN EXPECT.
BENEFITS WITH THE VERY FEW THAT
WERE NOT INCLUDED IN THE ON. IN
ADDITION TO THE QUANTITY
RESULTS CONFLICT FOR PAPA GET
ON. THAT SITE. EXACTLY YOU KNOW
THE CARE TO COLLECT THEIR
BEHAVIORAL THINGS. AND AUDIT.
WE CAN KERN AFFAIRS YOU MADE
NOW TO AND THE FACT THAT YOU
ARE NOT GOING TO OF THE PROGRAM
AND SURVEYS ON ONE OF THE INTO
EXACTLY YOU THE CLASS DATA. ONE
COULD YOU ENDED ON THE PROGRAM
DISH AND YOU SEE ARE. NOT A
PRINT OUT HOW. ARE WILLIAMS ARE
CRIME MAY CONSIDER PEOPLE. AND
CAR I WE ARE A LOT TWO YEARS
THANK YOUNG. THANK YOU NEXT
PUBLIC PLEASE. MAX A LOT SO I
THIRTY. PLEASE GO OUT. THANK
YOU MISTER KAREN MEMBER
PROSPECT ON BEHALF STACK
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY WE
ALSO WANT VOICE TEST FOR THE
ECLIPSE WHICH HELPS AGENCIES
LIKE OUR- APERTURES YOU'RE A
MISSION BY PASS. H. IT MAY THEM
COOPERATIVE SO WE CAN THEIR
MISSION FLEET. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT FROM COMMENT. MAX
HELLO TO LINE TWENTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS FOR THE CHANCE JIM
CATHOLICS FOUNDER AND CHIEF
TECHNOLOGY OFFICER AT MOTIV
POWER SYSTEMS STARTED ABOUT
TWELVE YEARS AGO WE'VE GROWN TO
OF IMPLYING ABOUT A HUNDRED
PEOPLE MOST IN CALIFORNIA.
RUNNING TO SMALL MANUFACTURING
FACILITIES AND- HERE IN
STOCKTON WE PROVIDE ALL
ELECTRIC TRUCKS AND BUSES THAT
I LIKE TO SAY WE FREE FLEETS
FROM FOSSIL FUEL BUT WE DON'T
DO IT ALONE WE RELY HEAVILY ON
CARDS A TRICKY PROGRAM I THINK
44% OF OUR CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
TRUCK AND BUS ORDERS WOULDN'T
HAPPEN WITHOUT H. THAT.
CUSTOMERS WOULD BUY GASOLINE
AND DIESEL- ONE EXAMPLE THE
BAKERY IN ALAMEDA WHO SEEING
INCREASED DEMAND DURING COBIT
THEY WANT TO GO ELECTRIC BUT
THEY'RE ONLY. ABLE TO
CONSIDERED BECAUSE THE NATURE.
AND ARE NINE ELECTRIC. FOR THE
COMMUNITY RESOURCE PROJECT IN
SACRAMENTO THEY'RE DEPLOYED
PROVIDING HOME ENERGY AUDITS
WEATHER WEATHERIZATION AND H.
BACK SERVICES. TO LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS IN THE AREA. OF BY
SACRAMENTO. AND THAT ARE SOME
OF THE WORST IN THE COUNTRY AND
THEN. EMAIL BAKERIES LARGEST
BAKERY IN THE WORLD THERE NOW
ROLLING OUT ELECTRIC DELIVERY
TRUCKS TARGETING A HUNDRED TO
TWO HUNDRED PER YEAR BASED ON
THE SUCCESS OF TWENTY FIVE
ELECTRIC TRUCKS. THAT THEY
BOUGHT ONLY DUE TO A TRIP.
WITHOUT THAT THOSE WOULD BE
GASOLINE AND THE NEXT ONE COULD
ALSO BE GASOLINE. MOST OF OUR
CUSTOMERS DOMICILE THEIR
VEHICLES IN MARIN URBAN AREAS
TO THE IMPACT. AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES THAT
HAS BEEN- YEAH. LARGE MOST OF
THESE VEHICLES- IMPACT THOSE
COMMUNITIES HEAVILY. AND YEAH.
REALLY I WOULD SAY THIS PROGRAM
ISN'T JUST PUTTING ELECTRIC
TRUCKS ON THE ROAD. REALLY
RETRAINING ELECTRIFICATION AS A
VIABLE OPTION PRETTY SWEET
CUSTOMERS AS THEY LOOK TO THE
FUTURE THANKS THANK YOU- NEXT
PUBLIC COMMENT PLACE. SCHERING
EVEN AT THE WE HAVE A THAT LEFT
IN THE QUEUE NEXT MOVE TO LINE
THIRTY SEVEN. GO AHEAD. I AM
WILL BARRETT WITH THE AMERICAN
LUNG ASSOCIATION THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY- WE AGREE THAT
CARD COULD PROVIDE MORE DATA
AND ANALYSIS TO ENSURE THE
PROGRAMS ARE WORKING TOGETHER
TO MAXIMIZE BENEFITS ESPECIALLY
IN OUR TO. ADVANTAGE IS NEEDED
AND- WE ALSO KNOW THAT WE WANT
TO SEE THESE BENEFITS ARE
REFLECTED IN TERMS OF
PRODUCTION THAN CRITERIA AIR
POLLUTANTS AND TOXIC AIR
CONTAMINANT. THE PUBLIC HEALTH
BENEFITS ARE NOT INCLUDED IN
THE SCOPE OF THE AUDIT. SO WHEN
EVERYONE TALKING AND WE'RE
TALKING TODAY ABOUT THE
SOCIETAL BENEFITS. PUBLIC
HEALTH BENEFITS OF REGULATIONS
THAT HAVE GOTTEN THEIR MESSAGE
HERE AGAIN THESE ARE NOT
INCLUDED IN THE SCOPE OF THE
ODD NOT A GEHRY AS
DISAPPOINTING. AS NOTED THAT
THE AT THE OUTSIDE OF THE
MEETING- BY MR STALIN. KERN
COUNTY HAS THE MOST DIFFICULT
AIR POLLUTION CHALLENGES IN THE
UNITED STATES ACCORDING TO THE
LUNG ASSOCIATION'S ANNUAL STATE
OF THE AIRPORT. OVER THE TWENTY
YEARS OF OUR REPORT KERN COUNTY
HAS BENEFITED GREATLY FROM
PRODUCTION DRIVEN BY CALIFORNIA
AIR RESOURCES BOARD REGULATIONS
AND LOCAL MEASURES. BUT WE KNOW
THERE'S A LONG WAY TO GO AND
THAT'S WHY THE WONDERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY THE CALIFORNIA MIGHT
BE MORE AND DO MORE QUICKLY TO
PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH AND
REDUCE CRITERIA AIR POLLUTANTS
AND TOXIC AIR CONTAMINANT.
THAT'S WHY WE BELIEVE CARPET
THAT THE STRONGEST
TECHNOLOGICALLY FEASIBLE
STANDARDS PLANAR ERROR. AND
THAT THE INCENTIVE INCENTIVES
THAT THE LEGISLATURE APPROVED
SHOULD ACCELERATE THE BENEFIT
THE PACKER TURN OVER TO
ELECTRIC VEHICLES ESPECIALLY IN
OUR MOST IMPACTED COMMUNITIES.
LIKE THOSE ENVISIONED THROUGH
THE CLEAN CARS FOR ALL PROGRAM
HEAVY DUTY ELECTRIC TRUCK AND
BUS PROGRAM. CARTON ALSO DO
MORE TO TRACK IN THE PANEL TO
BENEFIT THE REGULATORY BURDENS
INVESTMENT PROGRAM. BUT WE DO
HAVE TO ENSURE THAT THE AGENCY
IS EQUIPPED TO DO THAT WITHOUT
DISTRACTING FROM ITS PUBLIC
HEALTH COMMISSION A COMMISSION
THE CHAIRED BY THE AMERICAN
LUNG ASSOCIATION. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CARVE REPORTING OUT
ON THESE- CORRECTIVE ACTION
AND- CORRECT RECORDS AS NEEDED.
SO WE ALSO INCLUDING CALL ON
THE LEGISLATURE TO NOT ONLY
PROVIDE GUIDANCE TO CARVE ON
TRACKING ANALYSIS. BUT THE
SUPPORT CARD AND STRENGTHENING
AND CELEBRATING DIRECT EMISSION
REDUCTION. MEASURES INVESTING
INTO IN ADDITION THE- ZERO
TECHNOLOGIES AND INTEREST. AND
HELPING MARKETS COMMUNITY THAT
ARE AL RESIDENTS WITH MORE
EFFICIENT AND HELP YOUR KIDS
WITH A CHOICES. THAT WILL CLEAN
OUR AIR AND PER THE TITLE BUT-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
AS PER SE WITH NEXT FROM
COMMENT. NOT LINE TO PLEASE
CALL. THANK YOU- MY NAME IS
BIRD THERE AND I THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR AT BENEFICIAL
FOUNDATION- I'M COMMENTING IN
SUPPORT OF PARK TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAMS IN PARTICULAR THE
EQUITY PROGRAM BENEFICIAL STATE
FOUNDATION OF THE PROGRAM
ADMINISTRATOR FOR THE CLEAN
VEHICLE ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
WHICH HAS ALSO BEEN REFERENCED-
IN THIS CONVERSATION ABOUT
FINANCING AT THE STATEWIDE
PROGRAM- THE PAST YEAR HAS
SHOWN WITHOUT A DOUBT MORE THAN
EVER THAT CALIFORNIANS ARE
STRUGGLING AND THEY BENEFIT
FROM UP FRONT FINANCIAL
SYSTEMS- EXACTLY RIGHT NOW AND
I WAS. PRIOR ABOUT PRIOR TO THE
PAST YEAR- I APPRECIATE THE
INSIGHT OFFERED FROM THE
AUDITOR'S REPORT AND I AGREED
THAT COLLECTING TRACKING
ANALYZING AND REPORTING
QUANTITATIVE DATA IS CRITICAL
AND I WANT TO REASSURE FOLKS ON
THE CALL- AND PERSUADING THE
FASHION THAT WE DO IN FACT
COLLECT DATA- A LOT OF DATA AND
IN PARTICULAR SOMETHING THAT
CAME UP EARLIER AND I MIGHT
HAVE MISSED HEARD OR
MISUNDERSTOOD IS THAT WE DO
TRACK. THE ONES THAT ARE
REPORTED- THROUGH THE VEHICLE
PURCHASE CONTRACT THAT
PARTICIPANTS AND DEALERS HAVE
TO SUBMIT IN ORDER TO RECEIVE
THE GRANT AND THAT THE KEY
PIECE OF THE DATA THAT WE USE
THAT WE COLLECT- AND WITH THAT
BEING SAID I KNOW THAT WE CAN
IMPROVE IT AND I THINK THAT WE
SHOULD IMPROVE IT- I ALSO FEEL
THAT SOME OF THE PIECES OF ART
FROM CORE PIECES OVER PROGRAM
WERE MISSING FROM THE AUDITOR'S
REPORT ON THE QUALITATIVE DATA
THAT- AND I WISH THAT THAT HAD
BEEN. MORE REPRESENTATIVE- I'M
COMMITTED TO THE CONTINUOUS
IMPROVEMENT OF THE TVA PROGRAM
AND I'M EXCITED TO CONTINUE
TACKLING THE CHALLENGES AROUND
DATA COLLECTION AND MANAGEMENT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT
PUBLIC COMMONPLACE. NETSOL LINE.
PLEASE GO I HAD. THANK YOU THAT
THE LEAST CONTRACT BEHALF OF
COP LEGAL VOTERS AND WE WANT TO
ECHO THE COMMENTS THE OTHER
ENVIRONMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS
THAT WERE MADE HERE AND TO
SUPPORT THE NECESSARY PROGRAMS
THAT ARE NEEDED TO REDUCE
EMISSIONS AND MEET OUR TWENTY
THIRTY REDUCTION TARGETS. THAT
WE AGREE THAT- WHAT THE AUDITOR
THAT MORE DATA IS NEEDED AND WE
JUST FORGET ABOUT IT AS AN
INVITATION FOR THIS BODY TO
TAKE AN ACTIVE ROLE IN
DETERMINING REALLY WHAT DATA
AND TOOLS CARP NEEDS TO ENSURE
THAT THE STATE OF ACTUALLY
MEETING IS CALLS AND THEN
DELIVER THE RESEARCH IS NEEDED
TO ACHIEVE THOSE TARGETS.
IMPORTANTLY WE DON'T WANNA
PREMATURELY QUESTIONED THE
EFFICACY OF THESE PROGRAMS WHEN
THERE'S A CONCLUSION THAT MORE
DATA IS NEEDED WITH THAT IN
MIND WILL COST EFFECTIVENESS IS
IMPORTANT TO CONSIDER AND WE
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT OR SUPPORT
EFFORT TO PINPOINT AND
COLLECTED THE SPECIFIC DATA
THAT CAN BE COLLECTED TO BETTER
EVALUATE OTHERS DON'T YOU IT
ECONOMIC BENEFITS OF THESE
PROGRAMS. LIKE JOB CREATION AND
HEALTH AS WELL AS EQUITY THANK
YOU THANK. YOU NEXT PUBLIC
COMMONPLACE. NOT LEVEL LINE
FOUR PLEASE LAW HAD. HI MY NAME
IS DON- HERE TO REPRESENT BOTH
OF NORTH AMERICA WE ARE
INVOLVED IN THE- VOCAL LIGHTS
PROJECT BRINGING BATTERY
ELECTRIC TRUCKS INTO COMMERCIAL
SERVICE IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND WE ON MACK TRUCKS THAT HAS
DEVELOPED AN ELECTRIC REFUSE
TRUCK. I'M HERE TO RESPOND TO
THE AUDIT REPORTS QUESTION
ABOUT WHETHER CARBS INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS INFLUENCE CUSTOMER'S
BEHAVIOR DOCTORS INFORMED
PURCHASE DECISIONS ABOUT LIGHT
DUTY VEHICLES ARE VASTLY
DIFFERENT THAN THOSE
INFLUENCING HEAVY DUTY FLEETS.
WITH REGARD TO HEAVY VEHICLES
ON THE H. THAT PROGRAM I CAN
STATE BEYOND A DOUBT THAT THE
PROGRAM SUPPORTS FAILED THAT
WOULD NOT HAPPEN WITHOUT IT. WE
HAVE HAD MULTIPLE CASES WHERE
WHERE CUSTOMERS HAVE STIPULATED
THEIR PURCHASE BASED ON THE
ABILITY OF OBTAINING HFM
SENTENCED. EVENSON SAYS WERE
RELATED TO PASS SALES OF
NATURAL GAS VEHICLES. NOW THAT
WE HAVE COMMERCIALLY AVAILABLE
ZERO EMISSION BATTERY ELECTRIC
VEHICLES WHICH ARE
EXPONENTIALLY MORE EXPENSIVE
THAN DIESEL VEHICLES- PAGE
PROGRAM HAS BECOME EVEN MORE
CRITICAL TO THE- TO THE
DECISION OF FLEETS TO PURCHASE
THAT. WE HAVE BATTERY ELECTRIC
CLASS EIGHT TRUCKS FOR SALE
TODAY WHICH ARE AVAILABLE FOR
DELIVERY THIS YEAR I'M HERE TO
EMPHASIZE THAT WITHOUT ROBUST
SUPPORT FOR PURCHASE INCENTIVES
LIKE THE H. THAT PROGRAM. WHICH
WILL NOT PURCHASE THESE
VEHICLES THEREBY UNDERMINING
THE GOVERNOR STATED GOALS FOR
HEAVY DUTY THAT PENETRATION IN
THE MARKET PLACE AND THE AIR
QUALITY OF ITS CITIZENS
PARTICULARLY IN DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT LEVEL COMMONPLACE.
THANKS A LOT TO LINE FORTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
DIDN'T INVOLVE ABOUT THE DNA OF
THE TRUCK AND ENGINE
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION. IS
THE GLOBAL TRADE ASSOCIATIONS
MEMBERS INCLUDE MANY FACTIONS
OF MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS
AND LONGINES OUR VERY PROUD OF
THE NEEDS OF THE PATIENTS ON
INFECTIONS IN MAKING THE AREAS
OF REDUCING EMISSIONS AND OTHER
PARTNERS AS ANOTHER EMERGING
TECHNOLOGY IN THE MEDIUM HEAVY
DUTY SECTORS. I WAS PROBABLY TO
NO ONE'S SURPRISE THE NEW
TECHNOLOGIES ARE CURRENTLY A
LOT MORE SLEEP- A LOT MORE
EXPENSIVE. THAN WHAT'S
CURRENTLY IN THE MARKET FOR THE
TRANSFER. TAKE AWAY FROM OUR
POINT OF VIEW- JENNIFER
GRANDSON THESE CONSUMER
BEHAVIOR IN FACT MEETING
JENNIFER GRAHAM STUDENT BACK
THROUGH THAT- OUR MEMBERS AGREE
WITH THE IMPORTANCE OF A
PROGRAMS LIKE TEACHER FOR
CRITICAL INDUCING SOMEPLACE TO
PURCHASE SAYS. AFTER MANY
SEARCHES WOULD NOT HAVE
HAPPENED BUT FOR THE SENATE
PROGRAMS LIKE YOU CHIP- THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
COMMENTED WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU ON THE OTHER
POLICY MAKERS ON THIS IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION THANK YOU. NEXT
PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE. NEXT
ACROSS FORTY SEVEN PLEASE AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING SIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE KARAMANA REPRESENTING THE
BLUE GREEN ALLIANCE CALIFORNIA.
LIVING ALLIANCE IS A NETWORK OF
ORGANIZED LABOR AND
ENVIRONMENTAL ORGANIZATION
WORKING TOWARDS INEVITABLE HIGH
ROAD IN LOW CARBON ECONOMY.
FIRST WE WOULD LIKE TO SHARE
STRONG SUPPORT FOR CARDS
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS AND POLICIES
THAT XCELERATED MARKETS HAS
BEEN NATION CLEAN VEHICLE
MANUFACTURING. AND EQUITABLE
THAT THE POINT. WELL WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THESE PROGRAMS
WE FEEL IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
THIS COMMITTEE SIGNAL TO CART
IN ADDITION TO OTHER KEY
AGENCIES. THAT IS AN ECONOMIC
IMPERATIVE THAT CLEAN ENERGY
BUSINESS INVESTMENT TRANSLATE
INTO QUALITY AND HIGH WILL JOBS
FOR BOTH IN CONTENT AND
DISADVANTAGED WORKERS. BAKER
WITH SOME OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE
CALIFORNIA REPORT NOTABLY THE
NEED TO ESTABLISH COMPREHENSIVE
MANDATORY PUBLIC METRICS.
FOCUSED ON JOB HELLO THE
OUTCOME. ADDITIONALLY STRONGLY
RECOMMENDED THE COMMITTEE
HIGHLIGHTS THE NECESSITY OF
PROACTIVE WORKFORCE POLICY IN
ADDITION TO IMPROVE REPORTING.
POLICY SHOULD INCLUDE WORKFORCE
STANDARDS SUCH AS INDUSTRY
SPECIFIC OR ECONOMY WIDE WAITED
BENEFIT STANDARD. SKILLS
REQUIREMENT. ENFORCEABLE LABOR
AND EMPLOYMENT LAWS INCLUDING
THE PROPER CLASSIFICATION OF
EMPLOYEES AT THE BARGAINING
RIGHTS. AND DOMESTIC CONTENT
REQUIREMENTS. WE LIVE IN A
TRANSFORMATIONAL MOMENT IN
WHICH WE CAN LEVERAGE HIGH ROAD
JOBS ACROSS LOW CARBON VEHICLE
SUPPLY CHAIN. THANK YOU THANK
YOU TO TAKE ADVANTAGES
INCLUDING A GROWING MARKET FOR
THAT OUR PUBLIC INCENTIVES AND
OUR STRATEGIC MINERAL SUPPLY
PARTICULARLY IN THE SOUTH THE
RESOURCE AREA THE BILL THE HIGH
ROAD ECONOMY HEARING CALIFORNIA.
OTHER REPORTING ALONE WILL NOT
INSURE THE QUALITY OF JOBS
FUNDED BY CENTRAL CAR VEHICLE
INCENTIVES WORKFORCE STANDARDS
CAN ENSURE. BETTER WAGES
BENEFITS WORKING CONDITIONS
THAT CAREER LADDER SUPPORTING
MORE SKILLED WORKFORCE I WILL
NOT ONLY HELP STATE REACHES
CLINICAL. SUPPORT WORKING
FAMILIES ALONG THE WAY THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT THANK REST
CARMONA HAVEN'T HEARD YOUR
VOICE IN A WHILE IT'S GOOD TO
HEAR IT. LET'S MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT LEVEL COME IN PLEASE.
MAXIM TILL FOR FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CHURCH SHERMAN SALAS TO MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE HI MY NAME IS
JAMIE LEVIN AND I'M WITH THE
CENTER FOR TRANSPORTATION AND
THE ENVIRONMENT IN BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE PROJECT
MANAGERS OF A NUMBER OF MAJOR
HEAVY DUTY DEPLOYMENTS SPOKE
TRANSIT BUSES AND TRUCKS UP
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA- BETTER
VERY SPECIFICALLY TARGETED TO
SERVING DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES IN FACT IN THE AREA
OF TRANSIT. SPECIFICALLY WE
HAVE ROUTES THAT ARE DESIGNATED
TO OPERATE IN THE TOP 25% OF
THE DC'S IDENTIFIED BY THE
CALLIN BUYERS SCREEN THREE
POINT OH. IN IN THAT- IN THOSE
DAMAGE DEPLOYMENTS AND
DEMONSTRATIONS WE ARE-
COLLECTING EXTENSIVE DATA AND
EVALUATING PERFORMANCE AT
SENDING THAT DATA TO CARB
LOOKING AT BOTH EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS AND IS A TAD
TECHNOLOGY PERFORMANCE- IN THE
PURPOSE OF THAT PERFORMANCE
EVALUATION. IS TO BE ABLE TO
SHOW THAT THESE ZERO EMISSION
TECHNOLOGIES ARE MOVING IN THE
DIRECTION OF FULL
COMMERCIALIZATION AND TO GIVE
YOU AN EXAMPLE WELL WE'VE
DEPLOYED A NUMBER OF. FUEL CELL
ELECTRIC TRANSIT BUSES THAT ARE
PERFORMING. AT A LEVEL THAT
TRANSIT AGENCIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE ARE RECOGNIZED AS AN
IMPORTANT COMPLEMENT TO BATTERY
ELECTRIC AND THAT IS NOW
TRANSITION FROM THE SPECIFIC
TRANSIT AGENCIES WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH- IN NORTHERN AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. TO THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AS WELL WE'RE
WORKING WITH GOLDEN EMPIRE
TRANSIT IN BAKERSFIELD TO
DEPLOY- I HAD REGIONAL ELECTRIC.
FUEL CELL TRANSIT BUSES WELL
ACTUALLY I WANT TO SAY THE CARD
IS BEEN. REALLY AG COMPONENT TO
MAKING THIS POSSIBLE WITH THE
WAY THEY HAVE MANAGED TO FUNDS
AND DISTRIBUTED THE FUNDS FOR
THE PURPOSE OF US EFFECTIVELY
TRANSITIONING TO ZERO MISSION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT. THANK
YOU NEXT FROM COMMENT. ENACT A
LOT LINE THIRD PLEASE CALL OUT.
GOOD EVENING CHAIR AARON
RODRIGUEZ UNION OF CONCERNED
SCIENTISTS THOUGHT IT CLEARLY
OUTLINES OF THE STATE NEEDS TO
BE DOING MARC TO REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GASES WITH A MIX OF
QUALITY THAT INCLUDE MANDATES
INCENTIVES AND INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS ISSUE THAT CLIMATE
GOALS AND ADDRESS THE ONGOING
CLIMATE CRISIS. I KNOW I MEAN I
COMMENTED AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION ABOUT THIS AUDIT
BEING NARROWLY SCOPED AND NOT
EXAMINE CRITERIA AIR POLLUTION
WHICH WE BELIEVE WAS A MISSED
OPPORTUNITY. ADDITIONALLY
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION PER
DOLLARS SPENT IS NOT THE ONLY
METRIC THAT WE WANT TO USE IN
EVALUATING EFFECTIVENESS THE
PROGRAM SOCIAL ECONOMIC
BENEFITS SHOULD ALSO BE
EXAMINED ARE CAUGHT OUT IN THE
REPORT WELL WE MAY NOT MEET
MOLLY MAY NEED TO GET MORE
GRANULAR AND OUR UNDERSTANDING
OF DATA IT'S NOT EXCUSE TO SLOW
DOWN BUT RATHER CALL TO SPEED
UP OUR INVESTMENT IN REDUCTION.
ANYTHING MORE AGGRESSIVE ACTION
INCENTIVES OR OTHERWISE IN
ORDER TO MEET TWENTY THIRTY
GOALS WE AGREE THAT WE SHOULD
DO MORE TO REDUCE EMISSIONS AND
LEGISLATURE SHOULD HELP WITH
THAT THEIR ACTIONS THROUGHOUT
THIS LEGISLATIVE AND BUDGET
SESSION THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT. THANK
YOU NEXT PUBLIC COMMONPLACE.
AND AT THIS TIME THERE'S NO ONE
ELSE MAKE YOU. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU WELL REFER IT BACK TO THE-
WE ASK IF THERE'S A MEMBER OF
THE HERE THAT WISH TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. OKAY HEARING
AND SEEING NONE- WE WILL
CONCLUDE THE PUBLIC COMMENT
SECTION OF THE AGENDA AND MOVE.
TO WEAR THE CLOTHES OF THE
COMMITTEE I AM GOING TO. LOOK
AT THE CLOCK AND IT IS SIX PM
AND WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND
CONCLUDE THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE
AUDIT ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION
AND SENATE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE- INFORMATIONAL
HEARING THANK YOU.